mark aronson and marina budos examine
the impact of sugar on world history
they recount the role it played in the
atlantic slave trade and the industrial
revolution
during this event mr erinson and ms
budos speak to a group of students at
the brooklyn public library in brooklyn
new york
well the the first thing is today in
about an hour we're going to cover
several thousand years of world history
and touch every part of the planet are
you ready to roll you're ready to go on
the journey uh and this is a journey
that as we touch all these places
did actually start
from
a family two family stories and so if we
could look at the world map
marina and i were in
jerusalem
in israel
visiting uh uh with my uh family
and i learned i asked about the story of
one of my aunts a mysterious aunt of
mine a non-jewish woman who had married
into our jewish family and i wondered
about her what's the story about her it
turned out that her grandfather had been
a serf in russia did any of you remember
what a surf is
uh hold on you in the back row uh
could you hand this to him and
um i think it was a slave
a serf was very much like a slave he was
a person or a woman who could be bought
and sold with the land
so my aunt's grandfather was a serf but
he had invented a process for working
with beet sugar that was so useful he
became so rich he bought his freedom
when we learned about that we suddenly
learned about a connection to
marina's family
so
i had always known about my family's
connection to sugar
because my great grandparents
traveled from india
across
to guyana which is in south america but
it's considered part of
the caribbean
and they came to cut
to work on sugar plantations
so part of what fascinated us was
what is this substance
where someone in his family all the way
in russia a surf
and someone in my family looking to get
a better life
over here in india and then over to the
caribbean what is this substance that
could affect people
from such different parts of the world
and before we trace that out we want to
ask you a question how many of you think
you might have sugar somewhere in your
family background
so
that's one two three oh man we're yes
yes all right let's what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna bring it around i just wanna
hear a couple from a couple of you
where your family might have been from
okay
i think my family might have been
in the caribbean caribbean okay very
good okay
i feel my i feel my family was either in
the caribbean or in
europe
okay
okay
i think my family was either in the
caribbean or
europe okay
very good anybody else here
actually i know that my family was from
the caribbean and that's where i get it
from you get sugar so if you have the
caribbean in your background you
definitely have sugar in your background
but we believe that many more people
have sugar in their background than they
know
and we're about to take you as i say
spinning around the world and the
subtitle of our book is a story of magic
spice
slavery freedom and science and let's
start out with
magic
why might we relate sugar to magic well
sugar cane if we go back to the world
map
originally was very first uh you know
off at the edge on the far edge
we know that it was first grown in new
guinea
and it was they grew sugar cane have any
of you seen sugar cane before
have any of you ever tasted sugar cane
all right all right um
we know
that uh
we do know that uh sugar cane was first
grown in new guinea and then it was
brought up to india and the reason we
know that
is there are prayers to the goddess
durga
to the goddess durga where you would
burn various offerings to the goddess
and one of the offerings that you burned
was sugar cane
and we know that the original word in
the ancient indian language of sanskrit
for sugar was
that which brings sweetness
to the people
but
at a certain point the name for
this substance changed
and the new name for it was sharkara
which means gravel can anybody guess why
you might use a word that means gravel
for sugar cane
or for sugar uh this gentleman
um you might use um gravel because it
when you put it in your hand it kind of
like it
it came out like sand and sand is like
you're exactly right originally they had
cane
but they had learned how to make cane
into sugar and this is one of the
crucial things sugar granules
do not exist in nature
what exists in nature is the cane
we had to learn
how to turn the cane into those little
pieces of sugar
and we'll get to that but before we get
to that the question is how did
knowledge of sugar cane
spread
how did people learn about this plant
growing in new guinea this substance
used in religion in india does anyone
remember
who might have brought knowledge of
sugar
uh across
uh that back row there is great uh i
think the second guy there hasn't spoken
yet
um um christopher columbus
you're ahead you're ahead of us buddy
you're ahead we're way back
um i think it's be um it's spread
because it went across the world and i
think um china had it yeah but before
china gets it there's someone who brings
others a woman here on the end marina
um i think it was
i think it was the slaves that's later
anybody we're way back we're we're in bc
guys we're way way back the australians
nope no australians ah
the um greeks
yes alexander the great if any of you
remember the stories alexander the great
is
conquering across from greece he's
conquering across iran he's conquering
he gets to the edge of india
and his troops say i won't go any
further i've gone as far as i'm going to
go but alexander
is conquering
he has this hunger to know alexander can
never know enough
so he sends his friend the arcus in a
boat and saying go explore india find
out stuff for me and the arcs comes back
and talks about the reed
that gives honey
though there are no bees
now why would you describe sugar cane as
the reed that gives honey though there
are no
bees
because it was sweet
yes and why else
did you get a chance
because with honey um um bees usually
produce the honey and with sugar canes
they didn't need beets right because
what they knew if before people knew
about sugar cane how might they have
sweetened their food
what what ways might people have used to
sweeten their foods
they will use mashed fruits and honey
and sap from a maple tree very good very
you you all may remember that in north
america there were no bees north and
south america they didn't have honey so
what they had is maple syrup they had
the agave cactus
and in the rest of the world they had
um honey
so uh we've we've had sugar
used in magical ceremonies we've had
sugar now is spreading people are
starting to learn about it but one thing
we want to mention when you say that
they use let's say honey or fruit
is
sugar or sweetness at this time is not
the way we think about it where you're
going to have a chocolate bar or a
cookie it is just a taste it is a spice
it is something you use in your meal to
give it one of the flavors okay
let's think there's a meal you just had
where you use sweetness as part of the
meal what big meal did everybody have
just recently
breakfast okay think of a holiday
thanksgiving thanksgiving typical
thanksgiving plate you might have meat
next to sweet cranberries or relatively
sweet cranberries
that you're using sweetness there as
part of your main meal it's not maybe
you had pecan pie or sweet potato pie
later but also you had on your plate
sweetness was a spice
so this is sweetness now as a spice
and when sweetness was a spice do you
think sugar was easy to get or hard to
get
how many say easy
how many say hard
right so when it is as a spice it is
what we call a luxury item it's not
something that you can just go to the
corner store and get a bag of it's
something that will cost you a lot of
money it's very special you just use a
little bit of it
and we know that the place that really
caused the
growth of knowledge of sugar is this
wonderful mysterious
school it was a school in what is now
iran called jundi shapur
it was the first universe the first
medical college where doctors trained
while they healed patients it had an
observatory of the heavens and here to
this day
on the palace of justice in tehran
there is a sculpture of hazrat the just
who was the king
in iran
in the in the period when this academy
jundi shapur was the world center of
knowledge so people were coming from
india from greece there were christians
there and jews and and persians
all sharing knowledge about the world
and sharing in particular
knowledge of sugar sugar was also
considered a medicine
they actually gave sugar to people to
try to heal some of their ills although
they noticed that it wasn't too good for
your teeth
um
the key next step comes in the 600s and
hundreds a d
can anyone remember
what the the huge change in the spread
of knowledge the spread of information
that came in the seventh six hundreds
and seven hundreds
a.d
the big
um
the new religion that was spreading all
over the world the christians no we had
the christians already
uh yes sir in the back row
hinduism no hinduism existed already
islam islam
islam uh comes to the fore
in the 600s and as the islam islam
spreads across iran and spreads uh down
uh
crash
uh
into
china into russia into central asia into
the middle east into europe
islam has a common language that of
scholarship
which is arabic
and now they're spreading
knowledge of sugar
everywhere anyone speaks arabic they can
now learn
how to use this new substance
one way they use sugar is to make
beautiful sculptures these see these
look like trees
these were entirely built out of sugar
so what they would do is they would have
these big celebrations
where a a ruler to show what a wonderful
powerful generous ruler he was
would commission these huge sculptures
that were made out of sugar and
sometimes there were also have any of
you ever had marzipan
a mixture of sugar and almonds
and they would also make uh these
sculptures out of out of the mixture of
sugar and almonds
uh can you while arabic is spreading
spreading knowledge anybody remember
what we call numbers that we write what
do we call numbers 0 1 2 3 the way we
write them what do we call that kind of
number
uh
county numbers counting numbers or
there's another name for that kind of
number
uh numeral or what's the word that comes
just before numeral
no digits no
arabic yes
we call them arabic numerals because the
arabs brought
the knowledge of how instead of using
remember roman numerals x 1 v like all
this kind of really complicated stuff
and the romans didn't have zero
the arabs brought knowledge of the zero
and and what we call counting numbers
all throughout the world but
was there any part of the world that
didn't can you think of a part of the
world near the middle east near africa
near
asia that doesn't speak arabic at this
time we're now talking about 1100 1000
a.d
where is there a place where they don't
speak arabic
turkey uh okay what's another
possibility
china a possibility what's a a big place
where they're not speaking arabic
pakistan uh
um europe yes
you got it
as the arabs are spreading knowledge
spreading numbers spreading information
about sugar all over the world
europe is going in the opposite
direction europe is shutting down
blocking out saying we don't want any of
what you've got
so europe is withdrawing pulling it what
we ain't there yet uh
in europe however they still liked
spices and in fact
if you were having a feast you might
have
boar's head this is an actual
uh we've now used the medieval recipe to
reconstruct
uh the head of why is it green because
they would paint it with like mashed up
like parsley or something because they
wanted to have
just like the arabs made these giant
things out of sugar in medieval europe
you wanted to show you were rich
by using making something elaborate
making this and by using spices
spices but the europeans did not know
where the spices came from
so if you look at this someone
fishing in a river that they thought
came out of paradise
they thought spices floated down a river
somewhere in asia
which was where the garden of eden still
was
because because they didn't know they
didn't know
where sugar could come from
okay
so i have a question for all of you
which is we've been talking about the
spread of sugar
the arabs are the ones who've developed
it but there's one big problem with
sugar with this sugar cane in fact the
one we have here right now
what is the problem with sugar or sugar
cane
he can give you diabetes yes that's one
problem
but when you have to make sugar
it dries up when you cut it exactly take
a look at this cane you can see it's
pretty dry pretty woody do you think
you're going to get much sugar crystals
from this
absolutely not this is a reed in which
it must be milled within 48 hours of
being cut so you have to cut the cane
get it over
to some kind of process where they crush
the cane and they can get the pulp out
and then it has to be boiled and boiled
and boiled so that we can get those
crystals that we all know
and so this has to happen within a very
short period of time and it is in fact
the egyptians the arabic world that
developed the system by which
we could process these this cane all of
these reeds
and they developed something called the
anybody want to take a guess of what
they invented to make the sugar cane be
processed in a timely way what do we
call that
it's a system ah
they did use they did use mills
but what's the system called where
you've got a lot of people working to
get this sugar cane processed
what do we call that
a plantation very good so it was in the
arabic world that they first developed
the plantation where you have
lots of people
working cutting the cane getting it over
to the mill
turning those fires on so that the sugar
can be processed so this idea of sugar
cane plantations
processing sugar spreads upward into the
mediterranean islands the canary islands
okay
and
there's somebody who
we will now talk about how it made its
way over
to
in the 1400s spain and portugal were
competing to explore down the coast of
africa and find a sea route to asia
that way they could have the prized
asian spices they wanted without having
to pay high prices to venetian and
muslim middlemen spanish and portuguese
sailors searching for that sea route
conquered the canary islands and the
azores
soon they began building muslim-style
sugar plantations on the islands some of
them staffed by slaves purchased from
nearby africa
one sailor came to know these islands
particularly well because he traded in
white gold sugar
and then
as he set off on his second voyage
across the sea
to what he thought was asia he carried
sugar cane plants from gomera one of the
canary islands with him on his ship
his name
was christopher
columbus
and i have to tell you
marina and i cannot agree on who wrote
that passage we both like it so much we
each want to feel it i say i wrote it i
say i wrote it
we still don't know who that where the
truth lies okay
so
a lot of you had mentioned
south america the west indies all of you
from the who have backgrounds in the
caribbean right okay so this is now
sugar has been brought across
to this whole area
here we've got
dominica barbados all of these places
that have sugar cane planted on it
hispaniola
okay hispaniola is the the dominican
republic in haiti cuba all of these are
places where sugar sugar is now being
planted
so
what is
this
now
the beginning of in terms of
world history
now to be clear
there has always been slavery everywhere
in the world
slavery is as old as world history it
has existed in every part of the world
however as marina was saying
people are now interes christopher
columbus brings sugar over on his second
voyage
what do you need to have a lot of sugar
you need fertile soil
you need wind or water power to run the
mill
you need to be near water so you can
ship it
you need a lot of wood right because you
need to keep the fires burning because
you're going to be this bubbling bats of
sugar
but you need one more thing to produce
sugar what do you need
hard workers you need hard
cheap workers
you need
people who you can get to work for very
little because the more they work
the cheaper they are what happens to the
price of sugar
uh
it grows higher
or more likely it
it goes lower it goes lower because
you're you're producing cheap sugar the
price goes down let's look at now here
is the
most important
little diagram
can any of you remember
of the approximately
12
to 13 million africans
sold into transatlantic slavery
what percentage
were brought to north america where we
are what percentage
came
to north america i'm trying to look for
someone who hasn't spoken recently just
guess right this is a wild guess this is
not a test it's not on the regents
just
about eighty percent eighty percent to
north america is one gas
91 91 to north america is another guess
75
75 one more guess 52 52 marina is now
going to show you the actual percentage
of enslaved africans who came to the
united states
four
percent
four
percent of the enslaved
africans were brought to north america
96
of the enslaved africans were taken to
the sugar lands if we have 50 of you in
this room that means two of you
came to north america
48 of you
went to work in sugar
if you want to know the history of
enslavement
it's sugar
sugar drove the world economy
it was the labor of the africans
that spun
the world
because
as sugar is getting cheaper
well first of all we're going to talk
about what it was like to work on these
sugar plantations so we've got sugar
plantations brazil french guyana
suriname guyana all along here haiti all
of these areas that 96
are going to those sugar lands
let's talk for a moment
about what
life was like on the sugar plantation
you saw these cane these cane reeds here
okay
you heard that once the harvest started
the sugar cane had to be cut
and processed no later than 48 hours
what we have is we have droves of people
women children they were the ones who
very often did the work of weeding they
were constantly hoeing the plants to get
rid of the weeds you'd stand there all
day long in the broiling sun
getting rid of the weeds that would
spring up around the sugar cane
there were other people who were sent in
to plant and they had to plant in a very
exact way you see this tile here it
would be right in the middle of that one
and then the next one and the next one
then there were
very often the strongest slaves were the
ones who eventually would be sent in and
they would be the cutters and they would
cut the cane
and they'd use they call it either
cutlass or machete and they'd cut it
they'd hold it up taut and they'd cut it
here
let it go down
and they would have to carry this cane
very often on top of their heads
okay
sometimes they would have a cushion they
called a kata that would go on top of
their head and they carried over then
there would be other people wait wait i
want to interrupt for a second i need a
strong person to step up here yeah let's
get a very strong person right here come
on all right i want you to lift these
canes hold up all those canes
together all right lift them all up no
all together
just grab them and lift them
yes now i'm gonna ask tell you guess how
many in an average day women gathered
them and carried them how many do you
think oh now that you've lifted this how
many do you think a woman could carry in
a day
just guess give me a number
women had to gather 1200
stocks a day
1200
stocks a day of the weight of what
robert is just now carrying to keep the
process moving thank you
so you've got the people who are
carrying it taking it over then there's
the people who are feeding it into
rollers into whatever mill system they
have going
that will grind it
then there are people working in what we
call the boiling house and boy that
boiling house is boiling if you think
it's hot right now under the lights
imagine
a house where the furnaces are going all
the time day night and you have to keep
working no matter what as they process
that ground up sugar into the boiling
bats then there are people call pan
boilers and they take these long ladles
and they're testing it and taking the
what we call the scum at the top they
take that off okay
and they are testing it for the moment
when
sugar turns to crystal because there's
an exact moment it's called striking
and that is when it goes from being a
liquid
to a crystal
process down then there's a whole other
group
of slaves who are there to put
the sugar
there's to sift the sugar and then put
them into the hogs head barrels and then
they're shipped across to the sea this
goes on and on relentless cycles of work
on some plantations you might have
several harvests happening in a year
it's not like there's a harvest and
you're off for the rest of the year
they would plant one field over here for
one harvest another field over there for
another harvest so you're put on this
relentless cycle of work
working working and dangerous work
particularly in the boiling house where
people's arms could get caught in the
rollers it's very very hot and dangerous
if you look carefully at the
illustration of the mill
there's a sword that was kept next to
the mill
can anyone guess why you would keep a
sword next to the mill
for protection nope
why would you keep a sword next to the
mill
just in case it stops working nope
[Applause]
to chop up the game uh the reason you
have a sword next to the mill
is if you
people are working 12 hours a day i'm
sorry 14 hours a day
have you ever been really tired and you
close your eyes for a minute
if you're feeding into the mill and you
close your eyes from your hand goes into
the mill
the mill won't stop
the only way to save you
is to cut off your arm
and they talked about how many one-armed
people
they saw on the plantations because that
was it they would never what marina said
is true they will never
stop the process
and that is why
when we talk about the 96 percent and
why it's so unfamiliar for so many of us
in all of the sugar lands the enslaved
people died faster than they had
children
the work was so brutal
that you were constantly bringing over
more people simply to replace the people
who were dying
the work was so
relentless
so here's my question
we now have sugar as this cheap
commodity mark you want to give us the
stats on how much sugar we we go from
in 1700
the average english person ate four
pounds of sugar a year
eighteen hundred
fourteen pounds
nineteen hundred
ninety pounds
two thousand
one hundred forty pounds in america now
in 2010
150 pounds
sugar
transformed how we ate transformed who
we were and this
acceleration
is because you have enslaved people who
are driving the price of sugar so far
down
that everyone can have it it's not a
luxury it's not a spice it's not a
decoration
it's a necessity it's what we call a
staple now let me ask you
who are these people who are eating
all this sugar
90 pounds of sugar 40 cups of tea what's
going on why are people eating so
much sugar
in their day
because it's a sweet
that's because we've always had a sweet
why suddenly so much consumption of this
sugar is going on
because sugar is in everything now and
everything that you eat but why what
made it what why were people craving all
this [ __ ] that's now the price has gone
down so much the price has gone down and
who are the people that are eating the
sugar
because they're more slaves
that's possible that's who's making the
sugar who's consuming those barrels are
going off across the seas where are they
going
what's happening is just at the moment
that the sugar price is going down
there's a huge change taking place first
in england
in how people work
people used to work on farms they would
work in a little shop
starting around 1800
people in england are working in
factories
if you work in a factory you're working
10 hours 12 hours 14 hours can you just
leave your factory and go to the farm
and pick an apple
if you're working how are you going to
get enough energy to get through your
day
when you're working in a factory
sugar and what and there are three
substances that they would take their
sugar with
tea
coffee
and chocolate
so what you have is you
have slaves in the caribbean producing
this cheap sugar
shipping it off in barrels
and it's going to england
where you have workers working in
factories working their own long shifts
they get through the day with that
sweetened tea they drink it they gulp it
they have it with a bit of bread they
put some sugar on that bread before you
know it we have something called a
cookie we have something called a
biscuit all the things that we take for
granted now you know those energy bars
that people like to eat now
all of that dates back to the moment
when people began to work in factories
at that time they would drink something
like 40 cups of tea
to get them through the day and this is
why they're starting to consume
so much sugar
but here's a twist here's the
interesting twist we've just seen
sugar leading to death brutality
enslavement we've just seen how sugar is
fueling the industrial revolution well
on the sugar
islands the planters are getting really
really rich
they're getting so rich they don't even
have to live on the islands anymore
they move off to england the plant you
may own 2 000
uh you know people uh you know acres and
acres in jamaica barbados antigua
but you live in london
and when you live in london
you can go to parliament
and you can become make the laws in
england and you can make laws that say
everybody in the english
empire must eat sugar only from british
islands
and you know who gets mad about that
the americans the americans say
no taxation without representation how
come the sugar island owners are so rich
they can live in london
we can't live in london that's not fair
we want to be independent so the
beginning of the drive for the american
revolution comes when the americans say
i can't stand these sugar laws that you
west
indians are the sugar tax exactly what
you've said
that you're so right
the the beginning of that american
revolution is started as the americans
are angry over the british planters can
we've mentioned the industrial
revolution we've mentioned now the
american revolution anybody remember any
other revolutions that happened around
the you know end of the 1700s the
beginning of the
the world 1800s see what other whatever
the revolutions do we know about
french indian war
in indian war and what about what
revolution
the french revolution french revolution
so the french revolt the french get rid
of their king the french even abolish
slavery
however
the french revolution consumes itself in
violence does any of you ever heard of
the guillotine
the guillotine if you think of the
french revolution you think of this big
knife going
they were consuming themselves in
violence so
a a general was put in charge of france
does anyone remember his name
famous french general famous for being
short
napoleon napoleon napoleon takes over
in france and napoleon says wait a
second wait a second hold on a second
this spring the slaves thing
that's not a good idea
so he decides that he wants to make he's
going to feed his empire he's going to
get a lot of money for france
by
going back to hispaniola
he's going to make this island the sugar
center of the world and in order to do
that he buys the middle of america
to feed
haiti
anybody remember one more revolution
1804 1804 a date you need to know
nope 1804 but near us
the haitian revolution
revolution very good very in 1804 the
haitians have defeated the two most
powerful armies in the world
they have defeated the the british
and the french
when the haitians become independent
napoleon no longer needs the center of
north america he sells it to us and that
is called
the louisiana purchase
great the louisiana purchase is haiti's
gift to america
it is because haiti achieved its freedom
that napoleon didn't need the center of
america all right
haiti is the second country in the world
to fight free of its european masters to
be independent it is our near neighbor
in 1804 haiti becomes free
when does the united states recognize
its sister the only other free republic
in our part of the world
does it
when when
just take a guess yeah
when
they take out more advantage of us no
when what year
18 1893 that's not a horrible guess but
it's not true
1862 yes
1862
it we the united states will not
recognize a republic of freed slaves why
not
why will it take us till 1863
to recognize a republic of freed slaves
that's the time of the civil war exactly
until we're ready to free our own slaves
we cannot accept the principle
that slaves can free themselves
so here you have haiti achieves its
freedom
and we ignore it
we ignore it except there's one thing
that happens
the slave masters from haiti need to go
somewhere
they're not going to stay in a in a
republic of slaves who fought for their
freedom
where might they go some went to oriente
province in cuba
where did the other ones go
uh someone who hasn't spoken oh you
haven't spoken much uh
where's the
the united states where
where in the united states might they go
uh somebody come on where might they go
take a guess
just guess
america no in the united states where
someone who hasn't spoken where might
they go
yeah
i don't know the south somewhere in the
south where
where in the south who won the super
bowl last year
[Applause]
all right
louisiana
in louisiana
friends i have something to tell you
i have something to tell you in i
mentioned that in all the sugar lands
the en
enslaved people died faster than they
had children in every one of the
american slave states with one exception
enslaved people had children faster than
they died there was one exception what
do you think the exception was
so they could have more labor yeah but
what's the ones one slave state that
where people died faster than they had
children so they could work no but where
where
what state
which state
what state did they do probably maryland
nope the answer is louisiana
because
sugar is deadly
sugar is non-stop labor
so the one slave state in which people
died faster than they had children
so we're gonna now switch to the next
act but i want to tell you something
friends this is
the hard part of writing this book is
that we had to write
about this tragedy
about this level of brutality and death
because it's true
you have to tell this story but we also
wanted to give some voice
to the people who've passed away
how could we let them speak
well one way we could is there is a lot
of music and dance
that came out of the enslaved lands the
sugar lands and on our website sugar
change the world we have for example
there is a brazilian
dance called makula
have any of you heard of makula
well here we're going to see a little
makula
and this came directly out of the sugar
plantations
[Applause]
[Music]
it is a fighting style but it was also a
performance
because when the master came by oh we're
just dancing
you know leave us alone with no problem
here we're just having a good time but
you're also practicing your skills
because if you do want to fight
if you do want to rebel you want to know
how to
how to fight
and so we have on our website
at sugar change the world many kinds of
music and dance that is the heritage
that came out of the sugar land so that
we would understand this isn't just
death
there was also life
so what we want to now turn the next act
to
is this idea of how
did slavery in fact end okay
you have all you have sugar is now being
relentlessly
created with slaves
in the west indies it's this very cheap
product that everybody eats that we're
all dependent upon you have
slave owners you have west indian
planters who are getting rich off of
this and they basically own parliament
in england their voice gets heard
how would it be possible to ever
have this idea that a slave could be
free that a slave is not the property
of another person
where does this idea begin
so what we're going to do is we're going
to go back to thinking about
that world of england
where you had people working in
factories where you had people also
having another kind of revolution it's a
revolution in their mind it's a change
of ideas
and what starts to happen is you have
what we call the abolition movement
in england this is not the abolition
movement of the united states
but in england
where they launch a brilliant
brilliant campaign
how many of you know of sometimes you'll
go let's say to a coffee shop or a
starbucks and they'll say this coffee is
free trade coffee
or you might have a cotton shirt that
says this has been made um no children
have worked in this factory have you
ever seen anything like that or nike
sneakers where they tell you no children
have helped make this rug right free
trade coffee
all of that
dates back to the abolition movement
where you had people trying to figure
out
how do i convey
to the average person the fact that the
sugar they eat every day
is produced by someone who's giving
their life for this
so they began to create little purses
that they would carry that showed an
image
of a woman slave weeping under a tree
they would have labels that would say do
not drink this blood sweetened beverage
they would remind people every day
when they were sipping that wonderful
sweetened beverage that blood went into
that beverage they made it close to the
people
and year after year they would show the
manacles and the chains
that the slaves were brought over in the
the whips that were used
so that people would get a feeling
for this practice that took place so
many thousands of miles away all they
knew was the sugar
what they did is they connected the
product
to the person who made it
so every time you took a sweet taste
you thought of the blood price
for your sugar
and they won
in 1838
england for ended slavery england which
was making more money out of sugar
slavery than any other country in the
world
was the first country in the world to
abolish slavery
what you had then imagine this 1838 in
jamaica in trinidad in tobago in all the
british colonies
the bells rang they rang and they rang
and they rang it was emancipation day
in the west in the in the british
colonies in the west indies
all of those slaves were now free
but
there were people who were not happy
with the idea
that the slaves were free
there were people who listened to those
tolling bells and they felt this is the
death knell
of my livelihood
and that was the west indian planters
because they said who's going to cut my
cane for the for the cost that i need it
to be
and we're going to find out soon
how they solve that
but in the meantime
we're gonna take a break we'll take you
on a quick little journey remember that
general the short general with his hand
what was his name again
all right napoleon has this problem he's
lost haiti he sold louisiana the british
control the seas
where is he going to get sugar he can't
get it from the brits they're his enemy
where can napoleon get
sugar
new guinea no that's not a bad idea but
he the the brits control the seas he
can't make use of any seabourn
transportation
europe
europe but but sugarcane doesn't grow in
europe sugarcane in europe so how are
they going to get sugar how are you
going to get sugar
asia but you
sugar over land from asia not not not
very likely
how is poor napoleon
and and the french people going to
sweeten their uh hot chocolate i think
well uh marina is going over there
by using something from the i mean by
using syrup from the maple trees or by
using beans oh you he a substitute
say it again bees
beets
remember where we began
remember where our story began
with my aunt whose grandfather had been
a surf
napoleon learned that a german scientist
had figured out
that beet sugar is chemically identical
to cane sugar
this was the first time in human history
that a tropical product could be
substituted by another product
science is now going to tell us where
our sweetness comes from
not anymore the plantations at least the
british uh slaves have been freed
science is now going to begin to give us
our sugar so what you have in this
period which is exactly what links us
same period that that surf that's
related to his aunt okay
she he's developing beet sugar
and here in the west indies the west
indian planters are saying who's gonna
cut my cane
where can they get someone to cut their
cane no one's coming from africa no one
from south america no one from north
america they did actually try bringing
enslaved people from ireland to barbados
they said to barbados someone was to
take a slave and which by the way shows
slavery wasn't yet racial
you could be enslaved for being catholic
you because it wasn't it was about who
are we going to get to cut the cane
all right
you're not getting anyone from here
you're not getting anyone from here
you're not getting anyone from here
where can you get someone to cut the
cane
your children or family members no the
the the enslaved the formerly enslaved
people are as far away from the
plantations as they can get i'm not too
interested in going back to those
plantations right
canada
no canada
ukraine
no a good question no the answer is
people were brought from the other
country in england controlled
india marina's relatives
were brought people from india any of
you who've ever been
to trinidad
to tobago to jamaica
to the guyanas no there are many people
from india in the caribbean
why are they because they were brought
to cut the cane once those bells told
and the slave said i don't want to work
on these plantations what the slave
owners what the west indian planters did
is they started a system that we call
indenture
where you're not quite a slave
you sign a contract they bring you over
and you have to work for at least five
years on the plantation
you are technically allowed a passage
back if you fulfill the terms of your
contract
very often people did not go back
sometimes because they didn't make
enough money to make it worth it they're
not going back to their village to say
look at all this money i made
or they chose to settle most chose to
settle
in
the caribbean and the other places that
they were taken to
so they are the ones who are now working
the sugarcane plantations which is
precisely how it linked to my family
story we should also mention
that this idea of bringing people over
to work the plantations perhaps not as
slaves but as indentured workers also
affected another part of the world
that's now
part of the united states it is a place
where they grew a lot of sugarcane can
anybody think
what that place might be where there
might be a lot of sugar cane
hawaii you're absolutely right exactly
right
they brought over japanese
chinese
koreans and filipinos at various waves
to work
the
cane plantations which were growing in
hawaii so the indentured system is how
many many many many people still work
these plantations
now
there is another place in the world
where there was sugar plantations other
kinds of plantations too where indians
were sent
anybody have any idea not the caribbean
any idea
and one other place where indians
were sent
from india
madagascar
uh yes um a little bit yes
anywhere else you want to
guess china nope
one more guess
russia nope
they were sent
to the very bottom of africa
south africa
okay one area where there's quite a lot
of sugar
is called nattal
and there were men there was quite a bit
of sugar that was growing there
and one day
a man came into the office
of
a barrister a barrister is a lawyer
in england
and he had broken ribs rags his teeth
were broken and he was weeping he was
weeping because his owner
the plantation owner had treated him so
poorly
and this lawyer thought to himself
what is this system
that would so
mistreat its workers is this not
a form of slavery
now this lawyer is someone who we have
come to know since
does anybody know he was in south africa
he was from india does anybody know
who this man was
mahandas k gandhi yes exactly mohandas
gandhi
who we then came to call mahatma gandhi
you know the great gandhi
why do we consider him mahatma gandhi
why would we call gandhi the great what
is it that he did for us
anybody
he helped people that were
working for those people to get their
rights back and how did he how did he do
that in what way what was his philosophy
um he once said that i for i leave the
whole world blind
wonderful he went on strikes he went on
strikes
he was in favor of peace yes
every one of these things is true an eye
for an eye makes everyone blind
you go on strike
you march
he
preached he developed this idea of
non-violence
he developed the idea that you must be
pure in soul
and this is how we shall fight this
injustice
and
that is what we call sacha graha was the
name of the movement
which means truth force or soul force
and for year after year he fought these
poor people who were working
marched with him and they managed to
abolish the indentured system
through this philosophy and so gandhi
succeeded in south africa
he brought his idea of satyagraha of
nonviolent resistance to india
he brought india to independence
who studied the ideas of mar of mahatma
gandhi
who in america
studied the ideas of mahatma gandhi
um martin luther martin luther king
martin luther king
took
obser
saw that gandhi succeeded
so if we think back to sugar and we
think back to this idea that a product
can link you to the person who produced
it
sugar is responsible again
for the most of atlantic slavery for
millions of deaths
for horrible brutality for an indentured
system that left many many casualties
but sugar also
was used by the abolitionists led to the
ending of slavery the first in the world
and inspired
mohandas gandhi to develop the concept
of non-violent resistance
which would then be used in india
and come back to america so if you go
now when you go and you look at the
label
on the candy bar you eat or the or the
cereal you have in the morning
and it says sugar
you will know that in that one word
is magic
is spice
is slavery is freedom is science that
history is right there
and it's there for you to know
and it's there for you to know when you
think today
what am i using
who's pri what price am i paying who's
paying a price for what i enjoy
what links me to the people of the world
and i will tell you on the cover of our
book these children carrying sugar canes
is now
this is in the dominican republic today
this is not a hundred years ago
this is now
so when we talk about
the price
of the things we enjoy
if we honor
those people who ended slavery and if we
honor
those people who fought for
non-violently for change we can also
think about the products we use
and what choices we can make
to honor those who suffer
to give us pleasure
and that's the you know martin luther
king wrote in his letter from the
birmingham jail that we're all linked in
a web
we are all linked in a web and we see
that in this product
which we eat every day
and that was the story we tried to tell
in sugar change the world so i i hope i
hope it's been useful for you
[Applause]
we have time for a few questions
um
sure
very loud
but we have time for a few questions
three from academy and three from ms 61
perhaps
sure
can you do the mic
yeah go for it
um
miss badass what how did you feel when
you went past where you used to work and
it was a car place
oh where where my family's home once was
he's referring to the story that i had
always heard about my beautiful
beautiful family house that was built
with my family's success
right in these sugar lands
and the house was gone it had been torn
down
and of course i felt very very sad
because there was no house
and yet at the same time there's two
things in the tropics things get things
fall down pretty quickly they don't last
as long as we think we have houses of
brick that last forever right in the
tropic the wood the tropics wouldn't
things come and go
but the other thing i had to accept is
that was history that was another time
my family
did well they had this house and in fact
my father wound up immigrating and
coming to the united states we do move
on and it was time for the next
generation to do something with that
plot of land i should mention if you
come to our website we have a link to
something called google lit trips where
it will take you uh it's on google earth
and you can go to the village
that uh marina letter kenny the village
where marina's ancestral home is in the
burbeast
house right
another question um
how are you able to link your life to
the story of sugar well we started just
with the story of my aunt and marina's
family so that began us on the journey
and then we just started tracing all the
connections from there
what is the most significant thing that
you guys learned from writing the book
you know for me it was that 96 percent
um i did not know
that 96
of the enslaved africans went to the
sugar lands that really
changed my view and i actually felt at
that point that it's criminal
that we don't know that what other part
of our life do we say let's study four
percent
and ignore 96 percent
no other part of our life
so that was true for me
i think what was true for me is i had
always known about the non-violent
movement but i never realized it was
linked to sugar
we know about gandhi we know about
non-violence but i never connected it to
sugar and so that was that was a
revelation for me
um i have a question for both y'all what
inspired you to write sugar change the
world
well i really think it was
learning about our relatives but also
the thing is you know we're husband and
wife
i'm mostly a historian marina is mostly
a novelist we wanted to combine our
talents we wanted to
study something together
when you were researching did you come
to
a dead end
ah good question the one dead end i came
to is i was looking for more information
about joondi shapur
because i think that place sounds so
fascinating and i had trouble getting as
much information about it as i wanted or
the other dead end is
in the 1930s people went to interview
people who were still alive who had been
enslaved in america
so we do have some interviews with
people who worked in sugar slavery in
louisiana
which we mentioned in the book
but we do could not find the same voices
for the sugar lands we couldn't find
people talking about what was it like to
live
on a sugar plantation in
haiti or
brazil it's mind-boggling to think that
12 million came across to work in this
work and we don't have their voices
that is quite a dead end when you think
about it which is what inspired us to do
the website where you can hear the music
and the song and the rituals and the
things that they were able to develop
since of course they could not write
their thoughts down about their
experiences
do you plan to make um this book into a
movie or documentary
if someone wants to do it we'd love to
do it
yes
how was it to write the book together um
with your when's your different ideas
great question well as you know as you
heard we still argue about that one
paragraph and that one sentence i'm sure
i wrote it he sure he wrote it right
um
we we actually really enjoyed it because
when we went into the process we knew
that we're very different writers mark's
training is as an historian i'm very
interested in storytelling and
narratives and texture and setting and
characters that's what i think about but
i do also love history so we went into
it knowing that we each brought
something different
you know it's like having a meal where
you have the sweet part and you have the
sour part we knew that we would bring
different things to the table marina is
a professor in college she teaches
english and she is a a really tough
editor so i would write something and
she would criticize it and i would be
angry i said no this is great what are
you talking about and then uh you know a
day later town man you're right
and so
we would go through it that way
um this story telling um
like this storytelling write this whole
book
uh well there we tried wherever we could
to include
personal stories
because as i said at the beginning this
is so huge
it can be overwhelming but we wanted to
make it personal whenever we could
yes
oh this is being passed around
um as an african-american i know that a
part of my heritage is storytelling is
that what prompted you and is that a
point that you tried to convey in the
book it is in a sense in that we want to
recover all these stories and in
particular when i we keep talking about
the experience of the sugar lands i mean
one thing as you all know that's
happening now is more and more people
are coming to america from the caribbean
more and more people are coming to
america that have a caribbean background
more and more people are coming to
america that are hispanic which means
almost anything but also can mean having
this background and we wanted those
stories to begin to be told we are also
hoping that people who perform these
music bomba and plana who dance makulale
um will bring their arts into the
schools
so that we can all share and experience
this beauty that came out of so much
pain
last question
when does slavery start to be about race
oh that's a great question i happen to
have written a whole other book on that
basically in the initial years when
africans were sold into slavery
the europeans actually used one group of
africans to guard another because the
africans had no sense of race they just
had their old you know i don't like the
next group over just like the europeans
didn't like the next group over it was
only after hundreds of years
that the sense of difference became
attached to skin tone rather than
language religion belief
kingship geography
all the other ways that we divide so
actually race in its modern sense the
way we think about it was only invented
in the late 1700s
it's a very
very late and new idea
let's give mr aronson and miss budos for
another round of applause
[Applause]
thank you
and your teachers for bringing you today
please
[Applause]
for more information about sugar change
the world and the book's authors visit
sugarchangetheworld.com
today on book tv's in depth author and
columnist art we
all of us as individuals have the same
rights and opportunities
so that's what civil rights is to me
thank
you
after leaving new orleans the magic bus
civil rights tour continued on to st
john's plantation in saint martinville
louisiana
there photographers keith calhoun and
chandra mccormick showed some of their
photographs of laborers in the south
their presentation was part of a lecture
series on the civil rights movement in
the south and last about 50 minutes
we're here in louisiana and what's known
as the sugar belt which they we were
informed is what they consider anything
below interstate 10
um although it is changing and it's
going to go all the way up into northern
louisiana sugar in coming years up to
alexandria this is st john's plantation
and mill we spent last evening sleeping
here at the st john's plantation house
and then spent the day touring the mill
which is behind us there in all the
facilities it's uh we've learned a lot
of things about sugar since we're
consumers of it every day such as it's
today it's cost 21 cents a pound for
sugar we went into a warehouse facility
that that stores 60 million pounds of um
sugar during harvest season and we got
does anybody have a bag of the brown
sugars that we
some of this sort of uh we went into
just a heaping mound that looked like a
giant sand dune filled with um sugar so
we we just came back from that so it's
sort of our day in louisiana in saint
martinville in the heart of the sugar
country um talking about sugar and with
us are going to be or two guest
photographers that you've all gotten
used to and i'm going to introduce them
both separately even though they're a
husband and wife team and they're going
to show you guys some of the images
they've taken of sugar cane of the sugar
industry and of the cultural life of
louisiana that they've been documenting
we came upon their work because it was
the 200th anniversary of sugar in
louisiana a year ago and in new orleans
there was a show called raising cane
which traced the history of sugar
industry um in louisiana and we were
just so moved by their images at the
eisenhower center
for american studies that we
thought boy we really must bring them
here to show you guys some of their
images to talk about um
being photographers so the first
the first photographer is a friend and
that's keith calhoun
keith is from new orleans originally and
i asked him a little bit ago how did he
get involved with photography and he
told me when he was 17 years old he was
lucky enough to get an internship at a
public broadcasting
facility in los angeles where he started
learning about documentary film
and um and photography and beyond
documenting which will become a book
that he's working on called raising kane
which louisiana state university press
will be publishing both
you know both mr calhoun and ms
mccormick's photos will be in that book
in addition to that he's now doing a
documentary of allison tutu montana 2 2d
montana allison 2d montana who's 71
years old and is the oldest mardi gras
indian
in left in new orleans and they're doing
a special project with the new orleans
museum of art
documenting his life he's stepping down
now he's been wearing a mask for 50
years of mardi gras and he's stepping
down and handing it over to his son so
we could talk to him about that a little
bit also but i wanted to
start keith with just talking about some
of your images that you've brought with
you okay
mainly what we try to capture
when we go out and document
the workers here in louisiana is the
dignity the strength
of these folk because
no nobody know
until you get to talk to them what life
been like for them and what it is like
in the back rules of louisiana
so
what we tried to do before because right
now we have a problem with machinery
that's coming in that's taking over the
the workforce here in louisiana so you
don't really have a demand for
sugarcane
um
workers or scrappers anymore
so what me and shonda went out
we went out to document
the workers in the fields and this is
some of the images that we did here this
is gail darcy
at a wagga spat plantation
and this is gonna be
this is a shot
of um
a group of sugar cane scrappers in the
field
now what's important about these
photographs is that when you go out and
document a moment you can't go back and
reset up anything you have to capture it
as it happened that's the important
photography capturing the moment and
trying to show things in its best light
but a lot of these photographs a lot of
these folk that we document are no
longer working in uh in the fields
so
here's just
two guys sitting on on the porch passing
time away that was a plantation called
bestik plantation
and a lot of times when we get out here
and meet people like
these guys on best of k
it's so much history
that they have
and that's very important for african
americans to know what what took place
in the field what life was like for them
so we're in the process of documenting
recording people as they work and talk
you know
okay
here's a shot of uh
of the machine now way before the
machine it used to be maybe two or three
hundred people working in the fields you
know before this machine came along
now you have a machine where you don't
even need no no just if if the machine
don't get it it ain't no even since
going back getting it so
this is
yeah
here's a photograph to me it's almost
like a timeless photograph you can't
really put a time on this photograph you
know
i mean
and so a lot of times when me and sean
would go out we might leave our house
some mornings daybreak just to be out
to capture the moments you know and with
the workers
now this is a this is in the sugar mill
which y'all just left this is called bag
ash
and that guy have to get that big ass
out of there you see though
um
so
okay so
should we uh ask any questions anybody
got any questions they want to ask
um how did the two of you meet did you
meet through photography
oh well
we met through a friend of mine
and
um it was kind of like photography uh
well i knew that keith was a
photographer and um that he did a lot of
his own printing and everything and and
she introduced me to him he took me into
the dark room
and i was really excited about it i i
enjoyed it a whole lot and so i actually
started um doing a lot of dark room work
and printing
and and through doing that i uh
developed a knife
yeah it helped me to develop my eye
because i would always critique his work
by printing it you know i would always
see where i thought he could have did
something better and cropping or
or um
why is this person in there why didn't
you crop them out and so he noticed that
every time
i i processed his film and printed his
pictures i would always be critiquing
him and he said well why don't you shoot
you're always telling me what i should
do you sound like you have a really good
eye why don't you try it and and um i
i it took me a while but i i started
shooting and eventually i would say
um 1983 i started shooting maybe in 79
and 1983
i i got real serious and then you know
when you're a documentary photographer
it's not a type of photography like some
commercial photographers you don't make
a lot of money doing this type of
photography you have to have a love for
it you know you have to
have a love for people and to go out and
get into their lives
i was going to ask um i noticed that
most of your pictures are in black and
white do you do that i think it gives i
think it gives it a more dramatic effect
is that is that one of the reasons you
do that
well we shoot color too now i mean i
like black and white that's my
preference for black and white but i
also
especially with the sugar cane i really
have i like to do both mediums we try to
do both
because um
you know
but the black and white is real you know
it's important um if if you're a
documentary photographer just a
photographer if you do a lot of shooting
um and certain subject matter that's
very important
it's important to me to to dub myself i
document
in black and white as well as in color
because even if you're if you're using
something for book form or publication
or something like that then
a lot of times they are interested in
color here's a color shot here
now
also when we out document this is no
longer existing this plantation is torn
all the way down bessie k
but for us to go there and document
these people's lives and know what life
was like there this is probably one of
the most laid document on that
plantation
but this is guys who would work in the
field and get in the evening and they
would play the blues and when you hear
about blues this is how a lot of times
you hear a lot of old blues songs and
stuff this i came about people would
come home in the evening and they would
get together
and they would play
you know they would play blues so
you know
but i love color if you see the color i
mean
so especially with sugar cane when we
decided to do the sugar cane pro uh
can't not do it it was hard not to shoot
color you know
so you know this is some of the stuff we
have here in the color any of you ever
heard of a book called let us now praise
famous men
by james agee
a.j was a tennessee writer who
collaborated with the photographer
walker evans and went to the south in
the great depression and captured just
hundreds of remarkable images of rural
life during the great depression which
uh which we you know are considered some
of the great
social you know documents of the
depression era and he mentioned earlier
keith
keith mentioned his he had a um a hero
named gordon parks i just wanted him to
tell you guys about a photographer named
gordon parks what who is gordon parks
and why did you like him garden parks
was an african american who
left us out who worked as a
porter on a train
he was one of the first black
photographers to work for life magazine
i mean he was trained
during a time
when you didn't have many black
photographers shooting
for life magazine and stuff and he was
able to document a lot of stuff in the
south
during the depression time they had
something called phone security
administration
where they had sent some photographers
to come document us out
the tenant workers
but they came to document mainly the
white working class community but when
they got here and they seen the
conditions of a lot of the poor
conditions of the working-class blacks
then they did some documentation
but actually
you know me and shonda we're just
touching the surface
of
of what's left of history you know on
the plantations
i took that picture
this is 86.
where
this is um
st john parish
mr keith do you feel like a special
sensation when you realize like the
pitch is just right the way you're doing
it the way you're taking it
i'm gonna tell you how it works for me
sometimes the picture that i think is
the great shot always don't be the shot
it might be the one next to it
for a fact it's me and sean to go back
through our files i'm finding new photos
that
that i had taken back then it didn't
move me
because you can't really see the print
till you blow it up you know in your
mind you might have something thinking
that this is the shot but once you
get it it might not be that till you
till you see it you know
how long y'all been taking pictures
of photography doing it for 20 years now
if you were going to say to these young
people um what they need to do what you
do what are some things you tell them
i think first is investing in a nice
camera i mean you don't have to buy
elaborate camera because it's not the
camera it's the person that behind
behind the camera
that makes the photograph
um
you know you have to develop an eye you
know
and
basically
um
if you can buy them like tennis you can
buy a camera you know and i think i i
think i think basically it's if you're
interested in it get a camera and do it
um you can you can read about it and all
that which would help but the best thing
is trial and error so you don't have to
go to college and all that you know
well there i know
you don't really have to go it just
helps to take in college photography is
basically what you put into it you know
exactly what do you mean when you say
develop an act
and i seen things say for instance we're
here
taking pictures and i see
a photograph here i might shoot it from
this perspective but then i might say
let me get closer
you know meaning an eye for composition
yeah to compose a picture
i'm just trying to knowing that knowing
that what's in that frame is what you
want
do you specialize in plantations because
i hear you talking about a lot of
different plantations so do you like
specialize in particularly plantation
work or plantation pictures or something
um
not really
i have interest for workers period
and african american workers because
uh if you look at the machinery now you
look around i mean in new orleans
winston you had to dock workers and
my father was a dock worker
um
you had a lot of working-class
uh people worked the dogs they worked in
the cane
but you never see much talked about
these folks and these are you know these
are these are you know this is a dock
worker you know
and showing these guys they strengthened
dignity it was their labor the same
thing here it was the labor
of these folks that made things better
for a lot of folks so
you know
to take the history of these folks in
film is a very important moment that's
one of the pictures like you took a man
yesterday you know close up when you had
the camera right right i like cloaks
listen you know i like to get close to
the subject i don't care too much for
telephoto lens i like to get in close
and see that person face you know
[Music]
y'all putting your work into shows and
exhibits all the time yeah
right now
um we're working on a photographic uh we
constantly always working on
photographic exhibitions we're doing a
book with leela with uno
uh lsu press and uh we're also working
on another book with 2d montana who's
the indian chief in new orleans
i noticed that in the movement um a lot
of the information that we get about the
movement is through pictures and i was
wondering if either of you were you know
very active photographers during that
time period
well fortunately i came in right but you
know i was a product of the movement i
was part of um
workshops they had going on and um but i
wasn't actually documented i didn't
start documenting to 1970.
yes we all go around to different
schools when you're on tour to talk to
kids about photography yeah well fact we
have a kid program where we teach in
photography to kids in in the city
we also took some kids from the covenant
house and worked with them and they did
some exceptional work it was some
homeless kids and it was writing every
day i mean so
as close as you are on the pictures you
tell them you think they tell a better
story not not necessarily all the time
it depends on if you just want that one
photograph to say something
and that's all you're going to use or if
you if you're doing an essay
where we'll involve several photographs
you can tell a story with with all of
them using a close-up but using general
view you know
to make things with photography is
trying to see things in the best light
now
you know i like portraits you know i
like to get in close and sometimes it's
just good when you can see the lines of
a person face the texture
of that person face it kind of tells the
story of that person's life what is you
know
i've seen your work before and you like
to move around and really get into the
picture do you think that you would um
prefer never prefer but do you think
that you would take a job like maybe as
serious in the full story or something
like that
i don't think so
um
i think my work is more creative
that that would be strictly portraits
and and i love portraits but uh that
that kind is not the livelihood and the
work that i like to do
she was saying would would you take a
job in a photo studio like at sears or
something
it's not the type of work that we do
is your work exhibited anywhere in new
orleans
um yeah um coming up soon it'll be
exhibited at new orleans jazz and
heritage festival but we have an
upcoming
an upcoming exhibit also a major exhibit
at new orleans museum of art
um in july which is going to open july
3rd
and that's the exhibit of tutee montana
um we'll also have something uh at
stella jones gallery which is downtown
new orleans
so i'm
how do you feel that photography or your
photography photography in particular
has helped the movement
i think that um
that the work that we document um is
related to
the movement because of what it is it's
um
it's
it's uh the labor force which which
african americans had a large hand in
the labor force and building this
country and so
that is why we document that type of
thing because we think it's important
and
[Music]
i think the way that it is carried out
to answer your question is by us being
able to present it and show it to the
public
you know um
well to show to be able to show
what was the contributions to
what the african americans have made to
the sugar mill for instance
you know if you look around here you see
a lot of the folks who worked in the
fields you never hear much stories about
the folks who work what it was like for
instance sometimes we would go to a
plantation and we would talk to some of
the older folks and they would tell us
about how they used to have to be up at
sun up
on the road
to cut the cane
you know so that means they went to work
in the dark and they would and if it was
a high moon they would still be working
in the fields
so you know and especially sugarcane it
was hard work you know if you look
around this old plantation it was a lot
of work that went on
so that's the contribution and being
able to document that and having it you
know
maybe one of y'all can continue on the
documentation of what what life is you
know
on some of the sugar meals
that that answer
do you ever worry that it's a a way of
life that's that's disappearing we heard
earlier about the highly mechanized way
of cutting down cain on the one hand
that saves workers
then the modernization saves all the
hard labor we're sweating out here just
sitting in the sun talking imagine
picking cane on the other hand you're in
something in your photographs captures a
america that's lost in a way and you
there's it also feels almost nostalgic
how does one
make a decision about the modern
technology versus an older more
traditional way of life and the values
that were
being lost from that way of life
well i think a lot of the um
technology have heard it i know in the
african american community have heard it
i mean we it's been hit pretty hard
because for instance in new orleans
a dock worker
worked on a docks made just as much as
money as any school teacher maybe some
professors but they was able to raise
their family and send them to school
i mean if
it was a job where you didn't have to
have no masters even now you can't
guarantee if you have an
education that you're gonna have a job
uh
everybody can't get doctors and masters
so a lot of these guys for instance here
we've just been talking to some of the
workers here
you know they have made a large
contribution
and i don't know you know
our situation here at st john but a lot
of folks are forced to leave the bad
country now to go to the inner cities to
try to survive because there's no work
in these back towns no more you know
since the the cane
you don't i don't need you to cut the
cane with the uh
with the knife no more so
you know you have a tractor for instance
on one plantation where they might have
had
a hundred people right now one machine
can take the place of all them full so
all these folks you know is like fish
out of water you know where you're gonna
go you know because they have no no
other skills
and even having skill don't guarantee
you nothing you
aspect of know and then working but i
was looking like they ought to be tired
of doing that all this time
you know that's the way i felt about it
well
like i was saying this
i mean work is work if you can work take
care of your family it's work and i
think a lot of people have to do things
a lot of our my parents had my father i
know he didn't like going to the docks
every day but he did it but he was able
to take care of his family
a lot of guys now if you look around in
the inner city
especially for the young guys i mean
they had guys walking with carpenters
plasters
you know the labor force is down all the
way you had a lot of guys for instance
in new orleans with some of your best
carpentry but you that's a trade that's
thought of fading away in new orleans
you don't have a lot of work for that
i was still looking at like the form of
slavery and sharecropping i'm not out
there picking you know cane that just
didn't sound like something you know but
now you have a lot of african
african-americans have forms now i mean
you got people that you know
i mean
um
and i don't i don't think that i look at
it as
something that people
want to continue doing it's it's their
means of support
and
if they don't really have another skill
or a high level of education that will
guarantee them something like that
that's what they have to do and whatever
you have to do to me to make it in life
is if it's an honest living
then
i you know i'm all for it let me explain
one thing
somebody sacrificed for you
and with the work
a lot of people have to do a lot of work
that they don't like doing but they have
to get out and do it you know
so
uh what's important about this here is
the culture though you know a lot of the
folk out here no matter whatever the
situation uh you is
you know
the beauty and their lifestyle you know
just like the people who's on the
plantation playing the blues how they
get together and [ __ ] in town you don't
see that much anymore you know
as you were speaking i heard um more of
the answer to on the young lady who
asked what is your um contribution in
photography to the movement and as you
were explaining what use what we see in
the pictures
helps hopefully young people to see the
dignity exactly and to see the
contribution of the cane worker whose uh
product you know
took care of um its family and then that
family in turn was able to prosper and
so on and so on and i i heard
more of an answer as you were speaking
and the other thing that i was that i'm
excited about as i look at you all and
and we've had a chance to interact and
i've watched you
um
working in an inner city school is
sometimes difficult because we because
our kids do have the perception that
hard work is demeaning
but as you have shown in your
photography there is again that word
dignity and you remind us that we have
survived and we do continue to survive
um because we still have the will and
your work even as the two of you work
together also says to me as a teacher
that i can say to my students that there
may be those who may not decide to go to
college and to get the higher degrees
and to write the books but your
creativeness
and your ability to use it and share it
freely with others is just as important
as um those who will write the books and
those who will hold the mics and operate
the cameras and who will edit what is
being said and that that is kind of what
gets me high on my work because i i like
to get feedback
from people about my work i like to see
the expressions on the faces as people
look at my work
to me if um
if if i'm showing
a picture i want it to say something you
know it's got to speak to me so if it
speaks to me then i can feel that
it will speak to you
too
yeah i have to show them some of you
have yours
this is um this is also on betsy k which
is uh
um
it's inactive right now um all of the
quarters is torn down uh so there's
nothing really there but kane now
and these are the workers in the field
this is a lady who i became
good friends with her name is daisy may
and she
she also lived in um
on bessie k
she
and her mother both
worked in the fields but her mother was
deceased when i had taken this picture
but she always wore this hat which
represented her mother this is the hat
her mother um
war when she worked in the field
and this is a young man his name is mark
gale he's one of 10 children
um
he's on an active plantation in
saint john parish
and
he his mother and his father works in
the field he was 16
when i took this picture you see the
dignity in this young man though the
strength even though he a cane worker
he's a strong young brother that's
willing to work
and to me i respect this brother than
getting out there trying to sell rocks
you know so this is what we're talking
about everybody can't get out there and
do certain things but if you're working
honestly and making a dollar you're
doing good you know
and um
and believe me on some of these cat you
got people um i just talked to the lady
work here and she was telling me she got
kids in college and stuff like that so
you know
what the little bit with some of these
folks have to take you'd be surprised
how many kids that went got education
you know of
working
and this is um
this is in port allen
um it's
it's what the quarters looks like um and
you've probably seen that around here
too but it's the houses where a lot of
the um people who work in the fields
live
this is a friend of mine it's a little
girl her name is lashonda morgan
she also lives in port allen and i just
thought it would be interesting
to show the condition
you know
the interior of the house that they live
in
but um
why do you think it is that people are
so um so willing to let you take these
pictures of them i noticed in church
today um usually people want most people
like to have their pictures taken but
they want to pose for the picture and i
know this in church today when you are
taking pictures of the ladies in the
front the elderly ladies it was as if
they never looked at you it was almost
as if you were not there but they felt
very comfortable with you and your
camera why do you think that is because
when you what you try to do is
is to be there but not to be there
you know and it
you know to have the folk
relax enough to be able to get in there
and document without
you know getting anybody away because
that's the type of moment i don't like
so much pose pictures we like to capture
that moment
and sometimes
you know when you go to sp places and
you talk to folk and you let them know
where you're coming from they're more
relaxed you know
uh here at this place miss just meet
miss dotting them and
the folk we didn't met this little short
time we've been here been a very special
moment for us because you have folk here
that been at the saint john in the
history that they have i would
any of the kids y'all need to talk to mr
doc there because she's been around here
a long time she know a lot
about the workers the guy who took us to
the showed us the hulk
you know i mean
so
you try to get the subject as relaxed
and people
to be relaxed around you that's that's
the art of photography trying to you
know be there not to be there
you know like when they don't want you
to take the picture i want to do do
y'all still get a chance to take the
picture on tape
i i respect people in that in that
fashion because
um like he was saying it's your approach
if you approach someone and you let them
know what you're doing which is what we
did with the church this morning we
talked to the minister and let them know
who we were and what we wanted to do and
so he was very receptive to that and
naturally his congregation followed but
when we work that's how we work with our
subject we will get out we talk to them
let them know who we are what we do
and once you start shooting i mean at
first they may be conscious of the
camera but you know you're continuously
working it'll be like you're really not
there
you know and if you establish a good
rapport with your subject then you know
most of the time your images will work
on anyone that had an attitude about you
all taking pictures somewhere yeah yeah
people have let me explain when you doc
going into somebody's like for instant
um
we was documenting um
um
on the docks one time
and you might have a guy might have
haven't paid his child support or
something right i mean you never know or
you might go in the ballroom right
you're taking pictures this guy might be
uh with somebody else that he don't
supposed to be with so you have to be
conscious
like at the i mean you know you have to
be very cautious who when you document
somebody but
we try to find out who you are
information about you you know it's not
just good to take a picture and don't
have no information about it so you need
to get in there and talk to folk because
somebody might be hiding from the law
you never know so you have to be yeah i
think that's a good approach anyway
because
if you're a person that want wants to
become a photographer and you may be a
little camera shy or a little shy to get
in people's faces
you know
in front of a lot of people then that
helps break it when you when you start
communicating with people you have to be
able to
you know be
sharp and clear on getting people to you
know relax that's the key with
documenting because
you know you can't when i went to angola
for instance stay penetrated the guys
was real tough and stuff but after i
talked to them i would actually
would want you from from new orleans
they might when i would mention the
night ward it was like almost a school
reviewing you so the guys listen up
everybody wanted pictures but at first
you know i don't want my picture taken
you know but you know so you have to
know how to
get to people and talk to people he was
telling me isn't angle one of the only
places where you can still pick they're
still picking cotton by hand in the
united states at angola prison in
louisiana 14 000 acres yeah that's the
only place where they still pick cotton
by hand
and um
he means a lot of young men
good good is that um is that something
wait
is that something like uh perfect timing
in photography because i noticed the
photographer
whoever took the picture when um dr king
was shot it was like perfect timing
because you had the people pointing at
the window and it's like what he was
saying about moments
um there are certain events in new
orleans that we document um street
culture
um second lines jazz funerals
um
mardi gras indians that type of thing
there are certain moments in each one of
those different subjects that we
photograph that things happen
and if you follow that culture
you kind of become adjusted to knowing
what's going to happen like in the case
of mardi gras indians they meet each
other and when they meet each other they
have confrontation so if you want to get
that then you kind of know that moment
you know you
i mean sometimes who took the picture
i'm sure he didn't know that no he
didn't know that but you know what it
was he was he was ready he had his
finger on the trigger and he wasn't
missing anything he made sure that
whatever was happening at that event he
wanted to cover it and he just happened
to be lucky enough to get that
but also like the guy who had the
kennedy footage i mean that was just he
wasn't even a photographer he was just
there with his little camera you know
his little eight camera and that was
very important footage so just being
able to document a moment is very
important it gets important in our trip
and people i've heard a couple people
say geez i wish i had my camera with me
we've been doing some events i'll try to
bring camera journal with you so you can
capture those moments when there because
some a lot of things gonna happen the
next two weeks when you're not ready for
it it's just gonna happen somebody's
going to be here you want to meet or
some event's going to occur so if you're
into their photography keep it carrying
it with you i want to add that they are
capturing another moment
coming up soon um they're going to be
coming with us to document our journey
for the next weeks they they weren't
planning on this originally but they
kind of been been captivated by all you
guys
[Applause]
they're gonna be with us straight
through till the the end of the program
both of them
capturing this sort of historic journey
you're all on
i have two questions one is how do you
handle
photographing minors
um
with the possibility that your works may
be published
how do you handle that i should try to
get a release from the parent
i don't care to take pictures of miners
without having consent because you never
know you know you don't know the person
want their kids seen they might you know
you just don't know so it's very
important to talk to people and know
you know who they are when they come to
them and do you all sell um prints or
copies of your work some of our work
yeah we do sell yeah okay
yes
so the picture of the the the little
girl the little girl on there with the
smile reminds us of rochelle that's why
you're asking
she does look like her
in st john parish no no no
right there she looks like [ __ ]
[Music]
but you know a lot of times
you know
me and shonda would just get together on
a weekend and we would just drive and
meet folk you know we would just ride
along the river road and just stop and
talk like for instance uh one plantation
um
you know we got to talking to folks and
find out they had family in new orleans
and we knew some of the same folk you
know
and ever i i i know from experience
a lot of times here in louisiana people
are very friendly you know i mean
so it's not like in new york where
people are so tight i mean if i probably
have to go to harlem i might have to
talk to a few guys there and let them
ask them
you know can i go around and have
somebody bring me around
but pretty much
in the back country like this morning we
went to the church and people wasn't um
you know it was they didn't mind us
photographing them
he was also last night at a juke joint
capturing a really
awesome rhythm and blues band surveyed
like a jackie wilson singing it was all
over just capturing the line dancing and
and the interior and all the faces of
the people while they were enjoying
their saturday night whooping it up he
captured that and then this morning he
was up bright and early in church
capturing uh that moment you see what
you have to do when you approaching
something like here we are in saint john
and saint martinville
just through talking to uh miss dottie
and a few people work here they let us
know where the music was at last night i
like zeity i mean i like the music of
the blues and stuff in new orleans you
don't get to see
live music too much
so through that we was able to go to the
community and see the folk you know meet
some of the folk in the community
you know the adults
the same way with the church again ms
dottie i actually last night what was
the oldest church around and she told me
about baptist church was 127 years ago
so i just found out about that just
yesterday
so
it's real you know like you have to make
pictures you know you don't take you
make the pictures you know
yeah you make the pictures you know
captions under your pictures sometimes
you know after you've done them and you
go back and you you know record what you
remember seeing or you know do you just
kind of make up a caption based on what
the feeling was why you were taking it
or something like that all of all of
all of my photographs aren't really
titled some of them are though and some
of them are based on what the subject is
or what i might have felt at that time
or what the picture says to me but um
as far as captions
when when you um
have your work published
then a lot of times you may have to do
an essay or you may have to do captions
so that's also another part of being a
photographer
like i said the communication that comes
in handy because you have to write
something very important about your
pictures to identify a picture i have a
old picture here
i want to show you guys that
i just picked up in the saint john when
miss dottie showed it to me but here's
an old picture of a man that's 113 years
old
okay he was a slave in half ending
african-american slave but this picture
here been around this place a long time
if the photographer would have never
took this we wouldn't never have this
history so that's how important a
photograph is you understand just to see
this guy
and more than sure if we go to doing
some research he have a lot of root rot
you know
you know might be to no daddy there
but i'm just telling you you know every
moment is important you know on this
trip you know try to document and record
write as much about a photograph as you
can because
10 years from now your kids are 15.
you're going to have kids looking back
and saying well this is what you
took you know and
you know
so
cut up your own pictures yeah
i kind of [ __ ] excuse me because a lot
of times nobody know
what you want when you print in a
photograph you know you have to kind of
do that you can also make your borders
how wide and how small you want to yeah
you have full control when you do your
own printing
yeah i think i find that um
with printing in my black and white a
lot of
a lot of the labs
don't always give me what i can give
myself
because
and and if you're if you're not a
photographer who has printed or knows
printing you don't always know so if you
go to a lab and you get
some pictures printed
then they might look fine to you but if
you've been in the dark room and you
know how to get detail out of a negative
and how much contrast it has and
density and all that then you can see
the difference and taking you you're
negative somewhere else that's a moment
to me is a great moment when you can go
in somewhere you take a photo and you're
going to lab and you come back with a
prank you know that's a great moment to
be able to do that so it's
we could have set up a lab as we go
along
you know they're teasing me because i'm
just getting so excited because i hear i
hear you uh here on gentile saying you
have control of that and again as an
inner city teacher i want my kids to
know that they can have control of their
lives they can make their own choices
they can decide what they want to do and
then they can learn how to do it so that
you know how many of us we go to work
every day
but how many of us can just take our
work with us
still work still teach and still enjoy
joy exactly and you know that's it's
just you know i'm just you know
overwhelmed so i'm so excited about you
know how to work monetarily with
photographers most especially the
documented photographers they struggle
like they don't really make a lot of
money but being able to get out and meet
folks in documents some of the days i
spent documenting some of the plan i
money could never buy that
i enjoy that's what we have to get away
from you know it's all not about how
much money you're going to make it's
just finding something
a dark room you can set up
you can actually
go into business as a photographer for
500 the money you might spend on two or
three pair tennis
nowadays you can set up a lab buy your
camera
and
when i was 17 years old 18 years old i
was shooting weddings and going
you know if you go to a church and find
out what's going on they need people to
document that they need you know so you
can create your own
you know market like chandra she never
went to school for photography she's
just been working with me but it's
i mean school helps and i don't don't
don't understand me the more you have
about your business is better you know
but i'm just saying you can do it now
you can start
you know
yeah
yeah
i want to thank you very much for this
a bag of sugar from us
i thought we'd end before we we're gonna
have a brunch here in a minute but to
have um have our our friend here play us
say um tj plays a um a song that he did
in church maybe today
he did a blind well some of the people
didn't go to the church he played blind
willie um johnson song
it was wonderful
[Music]
like i told the preacher this morning i
had to tune my guitar before i played
because i had to get it out of that
saturday night tune in and do the sunday
morning
i was fortunate enough to uh
study with a lot of the early
african-american uh news players people
like book of white furry lewis sleepy
john este so when i see these
photographs of who they're documenting
the laborers it really uh strikes home
because i went to uh live with them and
i got to know a lot of their friends and
and uh
they taught me not only the music but
they taught me that the the power of
entertaining yourself speaking of
moments they would never let a moment go
by a moment where they could
make a joke or reach somehow and connect
with somebody in a real humanity human
way
because they couldn't didn't have the
money to be entertained they had to
entertain themselves and i think they if
there's one thing they taught me that's
probably most important they taught me
how to entertain myself and make
connections with the with people and at
least that's what i try
blind willie johnson
you're going to need somebody on your
bond
[Music]
you're gonna need
[Music]
won't you
wait till midnight when that's gone
[Music]
god
[Music]
[Applause]
you're gonna
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
somebody
[Music]
[Music]
one more time everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
won't you wait
until midnight
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you can continue to ride along with the
magic bus on its recent civil rights
tour for more information on the author
visit bioethics.nih
david kessler a former commissioner of
the u.s food and drug administration
explains how american bodies and minds
have been reprogrammed by too much sugar
salt and junk
politics and prose bookstore in
washington d.c hosted this event it
lasts about an hour
it is
very special
to be here at politics and prose
uh to carla and to barbara the owners uh
the fact is
this is without a doubt my favorite
bookstore in the whole world
there's another reason why
this is so special um and for those of
you
who are not part of the food and drug
administration who are here indulge me
uh if you would
this is
this is very a very special week and
there's some very special people here
that i've had the privilege over my life
to be able to work with
and on a week
as you just heard
where the united states congress
voted
79 senators in the affirmative
and
307 members of the house of
representatives in favor
of fda regulation of tobacco there are
people here
i can't name all of you who spent your
your much of your
adult lives working on this and my hat
is off
to all of you and thank you for what you
have done
[Applause]
let me tell you the journey
tobacco
took
15 years
since since the day
we started it took 15 years to get to
where we are and along that
path
you know
that's a long time
but if you're you're willing
one of you in the audience i still
remember to this moment we went around
the table and i asked people what what
they thought and
you heard what you would expect to hear
it's a fool's errand
it's the big money it's political
suicide yes it's the right thing to do
but you know if you do it it's going to
take all the energy and everything you
have
and then one of you
looked at me and said
if you're willing
to take on tobacco i'm willing to spend
the rest of my career working on this
that taught me more than anything
else one could ever imagine
and along along the way because of 15
years
you know you'll excuse me but there
had the opportunity to do a couple of
other things
while tobacco was cooking and many of
you continue to work on it very hard
i was sitting in my office about seven
years ago
and it was up at yale with a group of
residents and and fellows
and having learned from tobacco and
having lived that i asked a very basic
question
what
what do we know what's the evidence if
you want to stay alive
what are the things you can do really to
prevent
um dying
from the major killers and the major
killers three quarters of us are going
to die from cancer
heart disease or stroke
and tobacco
is easy the number one preventable cause
certainly when we started a number
prevent the number one preventable cause
today
but what are the other things you could
do when you look at cardiovascular
disease stroke
and certainly many forms of of cancer
and i noticed something that was
happening we were pulling all the
articles i had this librarian a
wonderful librarian at yale was helping
me pull all the articles
and i noticed that along the way
as she was doing this over a three month
period she lost 30 pounds
because all the articles on prevention
you know we know that excess weight is
not good for us
but it was striking the contribution
um to health
just one
you know
very basic numbers ten years ago there
were four cases per thousand
of type two diabetes in this country
four cases per thousand today
there are nine
cases per thousand
we spent
in two thousand seven billion dollars
on drugs for type two diabetes today we
spend 13 billion dollars
on drugs type 2 diabetes i could just as
well write
you know excess weight in the medical
chart because that is the mechanism that
contributes mightily
to that disease we all want health
reform
it's no one in this town is not talking
about health care reform
but how are we going
to be able to get a handle on these
costs
when we can't get a handle on something
as basic
as excess weight and what's going on
i asked my friend catherine flagel
at the centers for disease control
how has weight changed over the decades
you know what adult weight
you know tell me you know if you go back
into the 60s what was going on and
what's going on today and what's
different and what was striking when she
sent me those graphs
what you saw what i saw what she plotted
was back in the 60s you entered your 20s
you may gain a few pounds
till your 40s and 50s but you'll
relatively stable a few pounds till 40
50 you then you plateaued and then you
lost a few pounds in your 60s and 70s
and in your senior years and in your 80s
but weight was relatively stable over an
adult lifetime
today
you enter your adult years
and the weight keeps on
rising
certainly until your fifties it doesn't
plateau but what is most striking
is when you enter your twenties
back in the sixties if you were here
today you're entering your twenties
here
so
as with tobacco
excess weight really does begin in
childhood in adolescence at least for a
significant part of the population but
what to do about this if diet and
exercise
you know worked everybody would be doing
it
so i started trying to understand
what why was this so difficult why
couldn't we get a handle on it what was
going on in this country and that's been
the journey
for the last seven years so one night i
am i'm watching the daily rerun of oprah
and i
i'm listening to this woman
very well educated
very well dressed
very successful in all aspects of her
life
and
she was being interviewed by dr phil
don't get me started on dr phil please
but i was listening to this woman
and what she said was
i eat when my husband leaves for work in
the morning i eat before he comes home
at night i eat when i'm happy i eat when
i'm sad i eat when i'm hungry
i eat when i'm not hungry
and then that moment she said
i don't like myself
so i was trying i was sitting there
listening and trying to listen as a
clinician as a doctor
because i don't think we as a as a
profession certainly as a medical
profession
have really been thinking or doing the
research to really understand why was
this woman successful in all aspects of
her life doing things that she didn't
want to be doing
and doing them anyway knowing that it
wasn't good for her
what was going on what was going on
clinically what was going on
scientifically and that was the journey
for the last
seven years that i wanted to understand
so with colleagues in a number of great
institutions let me give you
let me just give you four pieces of the
science
and then try to put together
this puzzle
this mystery why does that chocolate
chip cookie have such power over me
that really is is the question i mean i
could real i could relate to that woman
on oprah
right i have suits in every size
and i probably gained and lost my body
weight
over my lifetime several times
over
what was going on with that woman let me
give you the pieces of the science with
colleagues at the university of
washington we published an article
recently not the typical scientific
title for a scientific journal it was
called deconstructing the vanilla
milkshake
what do you think it is about a vanilla
milkshake that drives intake
you think it's the sugar you think it's
the fat
you think it's the flavor how many of
you think it's the sugar raise your
hands
how many think it's the fat
how many think it's the flavor
well let me tell you how we we we
actually did the experiments very simple
experiment because we wanted to know
what drives intake so how do you measure
that how do you measure that in animals
how can you measure that in humans well
in animals
you know what we were looking for was
how hard an animal would work
to to get the food now that test some of
you shaking your heads because you you
understand that's that test that's
called self-administration that's the
test that nida fda dea used to decide to
control substance i mean a drug but the
real question is how hard the motivation
how hard will an animal work so what you
do is you make an animal first press the
lever once you give them the food then
you make them press twice and then you
give them the food then you wait for it
they have to press four times then they
have to press 16 times before they get
it then 32 times then 64 times and then
you got to press it 128 times before
they get the food so you have a sense of
what the break point is
right what do you think they'll work
hardest for
answer was it was sugar
sugar was the main driver
but when you add to that sugar you add
fat
it's synergistic
it's small
second piece of science
with my colleagues in italy jatana di
chieri
one of the great pharmacologists
jatano has dedicated his career to
understanding how drugs
hijacked the brain
he studies amphetamines he studies
cocaine and what we know is when you
administer
drugs like amphetamine and cocaine what
you see is bump
in the brain circuitry involving
dopamine
every time you give amphetamine or
cocaine you see this elevation in the
brain's dopamine
and
dopamine is the chemical responsible not
for pleasure
dopamine is responsible
for locking in our attention that
preoccupation
it gates the neural circuits
of what enters working memory what you
end up thinking about
and
what chitano found in working with him
we were working together
i said let's let's test food
it was always assumed the drugs
elevate dopamine levels food you get a
little bump the first time but then on
repeat time you have bitter you don't
get that bump
i said let's make food
you know let's not just take sugar but
let's take sugar and fat let's make food
highly palatable
this multi-sensory mixture
and what happens to dopamine
and
chitano
i remember the email it was the subject
line was important results
dopamine
continues to be elevated
every time if you make food
multi-sensory take sugar and fat
together rather than just sugar
you can get you get elevations in brain
dopamine on a repeated basis
it doesn't habituate
third piece of the science i want to
know how many people
yeah i wanted to understand
this woman on oprah what i what was i
hearing
and how common was that
in the population
so let me give you three characteristics
let me describe them to you
first one is loss of control in the face
of highly palatable foods a hard time
resisting your favorite foods
two a lack of satiation
a lack of feeling full
when you're when you're eating a hard
time stopping
third one a preoccupation a thinking
about foods
between meals and not sometimes thinking
about foods you know when you're
eating
as you're eating you're thinking about
what you're going to be eating next
sort of bizarre
right but those three characteristics
right loss of control in the face of
highly palatable foods lack of satiation
a preoccupation uh thinking about foods
those three characteristics
sometimes i say that to people
and there's a small percentage of the
population who have no idea what i'm
talking about
they look at me with absolute blank
stares those are the people i think we
really should be studying those are the
ones
that are the most interesting
scientifically
okay
but we we looked at the epidemiology and
with
my colleague alyssa applet at ucsf what
we did was we looked at
how many people self-report
those three characteristics and we found
that 50 percent of obese individuals 30
of overweight individuals and 20 of
healthy weight individuals score very
high
on all three characteristics
right so certainly more people
who are bigger have those
characteristics but a significant
percentage of people
who are lean have those characteristics
and if you extrapolate and there's risks
of extrapolation
right that turns out to be some 70
million
americans
who self-report loss of control lack of
satiation or preoccupation with thinking
about foods
last piece of science and this is the
most interesting we took those
individuals
who have that constellation of
what we call conditioned hyper eating
because those are the characteristics of
a conditioned and driven
behavior
and we study them we study the neural
imaging
now we designed the experiment really in
two phases
the first is the anticipation of food
not actually eating the food the power
of food
comes from what
from the taste
yes but it's also the anticipation of
food
it's that cue
every time i land
at san francisco airport as soon as the
plane hits the taxiway i start thinking
about these
chinese dumplings
right just a plane has to just land in
the taxiway right
and i start thinking about it because
there's pl this place in the food court
i mean
that that has these if i can only make
it to baggage claim
it's out of my working memory right so i
i another you know i'm walking down
powell street
in san francisco and i start thinking
about chocolate-covered pretzels
right why because six months earlier i
had been on
um that street on powell street and i
went in a place i took a pretzel
and i'd forgotten all about it but just
the location
right that thought entered my mind
and that thoughts those thoughts of
wanting so what we did in this
experiment with dr small is we took
people who had loss of control lack of
satiation preoccupation
with with food and we scanned their
brain just first just we cued them
we just gave them
um the the smell you can give them the
smell you can give them the sight you
sometimes just location just getting in
your car can be a cue
right you know the car just drives i
mean automatic because you've driven
past and once the you get in the car you
start thinking about what you're going
to eat because you've been there there's
always a past experience that drives
that anticipation but the first part of
the experiment was we
we cued people
and what we saw in people who had these
three characteristics this conditioned
hyper eating
phenotype this conditioned hyper eating
syndrome it's not a disease mind you but
this is very much a normal part of
our makeup
what we saw was the people who had this
conditioned hyper eating had hyper
activation
during the anticipation phase
in the amygdala and the reward pathways
of their brains compared to controls
and it was pronounced
and what we further saw
right was that when they actually
consumed the food when they tasted the
food
that
elevation in the amygdala which we
always thought would habituate which was
just the cue
remained elevated
so the neural pathways remain
activated and hyper-activated
until all the food is gone
so for the first time we have evidence
certainly evidence is emerging
that
you know lack of control hard time
resisting
it's not a matter of willpower
literally the brains of
you know millions of people
are being hijacked
by these cues
by this highly palatable
food let me let me
put it together
for the washington post um
the washington post outed me
um because i wanted to know i really i
wanted to understand the science but i
also wanted to go inside the industry
and
we worked when we were at fda
a number of you
together we work you know that nutrition
facts panel
right um
that we worked on
someone
in the food industry
said to me looked at me and said kessler
the obesity epidemic
is all your fault
and i looked at him and i said what are
you talking about
he said
you folks at the fda were so successful
with that nutrition facts panel
that you kept some check
on what was being put on in food in the
supermarket what happened
was it exploded in restaurants
and that's where the real problem
lies
they know the food industry knows what
the inputs are
they understand the outputs fat and
sugar fat and salt fat sugar and salt
[Music]
they call it three points of the compass
but they they stimulate
they stimulate intake i thought i used i
was eating to fill me up
to satiate me
fat and sugar fat and
uh soil fat sugar and salt stimulate
intake they make you work harder it's
not just condition behavior it's
conditioned and driven behavior so i
wanted to know what was you know what
wasn't you can tell what's on processed
foods i mean in supermarkets you can see
that label but go into a restaurant and
try to understand what's in there
and so i went dumpster diving
for about six months because it's not
easy to find out when you just ask the
major chains what's what's in the food
and even for me
as a physician someone who was i mean i
was i was in charge of regulating food i
mean it was eye opening
the grilled marinated chicken
you think it's healthy
it's bathed in this sugar and fat syrup
our foods are injected
with with needles
pick any
pick any american you know
favorite american
dish
right i mean pick an appetizer right
pick buffalo wings
what are they
when you think about it right but
so
it's the fatty part of the chicken
fried usually in the manufacturing plant
refried
in
um the restaurant
the red sauce what is it fat and sugar
that white creamy sauce
fat and salt
sure it tastes good what is it
it's fat on fat on fat
sugar and fat
and salt
i could go through
you know an entire basket
food industry has said all we're doing
is giving consumers what
they want that's the argument
we now know
that what's going on is that our brains
are being hijacked let's just put this
together clinically so everyone
understands the cycle of consumption
how does it work
past memory past experiences
right that learning
right those learning circuits of the
brain get activated so you get cued
that cue
activates the brain circuitry it arouses
you it grabs your attention it locks you
in
there's arousal
and then you consume
the food
and then the next time you get cued what
do you do you do it again
and every time you engage in that
cycle
you strengthen the neural circuits
and come back for more
so you all remember pavlov you
understand the condition behaviors
right but this is more than conditioned
behaviors and this is really the science
of the last decades it's conditioned and
driven behavior
right because it's not just learning
circuits it's the learning and
motivational circuits
try to stop that cycle
in the middle
right you know that in a dialogue once
you've been cued
and that your brain is activated that
inner dialogue yes i would
love it no it's not good for me yeah
that would be that would be good no i
shouldn't have it
those that inner dialogue what does it
do it only increases the reward value of
the food you try to stop it
and this is the difference between
conditioned behavior and conditioned and
driven behavior you try to stop it you
try to suppress that thought right
and you increase the reward value of the
food you end up wanting it more and
that's the stuff of obsessions and
cravings
what's been the business plan
what's been the business plan of the
modern american food company
it's to take fat sugar and salt
put it on every corner make it available
24 7
and make it socially acceptable
to eat any time
of day how did the french
how did the french control their intake
they always had highly palatable foods
what's the difference
the culture right i've lived there
eight years
luxembourg closes down to this day
during uh outside of made males there's
external control on human nature where
here it's
as sigmund freud said the insatiable
appetite more this is our this is the
running epidemic so what we've done is
we've taken down any barriers
because you can eat anytime because it's
socially acceptable
the french destroyed the canadians too
they only hated meals certainly when i
was growing up we we tended to eat at
meals we didn't snack all day long
but what's happening now is fat sugar
and salt on every corner available 24 7
and
um it's acceptable that social norm to
eat any time you could be sitting here
eating no one would think any different
of it
but i i was invited to talk to a major
food manufacturer and and i put it
i said let me give you a comparison
and we have to be careful with
comparisons with tobacco but let me see
if i can explain how this works
nicotine
nicotine is a moderately reinforcing
chemical
animals will self-administer nicotine
but if you look at humans
and how it works nicotine is moderately
reinforcing add to that nicotine the
smoke
the throat scratch
the cellophane crinkling of the pack the
color of the pack the imagery that the
industry created 30 40 years that it was
sexy glamorous
to smoke the image of the cowboy that
you needed it the time of day what did
we end up we took a reinforcing chemical
and we made it into a significantly
addictive
and deadly product
i give you a package of sugar and i say
go have a good time
you're going to look at me what are you
talking about
now add to that sugar
add fat add texture add temperature add
color
put it on every corner
say you're going to do it with your
friend say it's entertainment
right add the emotional gloss of
advertising you'll love it you'll want
it
walk into the any of the food courts
walk into the food court at union
station
watch the the kids if it's a food
carnival
what did we end up with we started with
a reinforcing substance
and
we've made it in to one of the great
public health crises of our time
we now know
we have the evidence that the brains of
millions of americans are being hijacked
by
sugar fat and salt
the industry understands the inputs they
understand that
sugar fat and salt stimulate they
understand the outputs they understand
that people come back for more they
understood neuroscience
probably not but they have understood
what works once we have that the
evidence
that we now have what are we going to do
about it does the food industry need to
change
absolutely does government have an
increased role
absolutely the implications
school lunch programs
the subsidies
advertising
but just
because our brains are being hijacked
now we can explain to that woman on
oprah
we can explain to millions of people
it's not your fault but just because
your brain is being hijacked doesn't
mean you can't take responsibility that
you can't fight back
that you can't
to put the tools together
right to protect yourself
let me give you one other
fact
two-year-olds
two-year-olds compensate for their
eating
what do i mean by that if you give a
two-year-old
excess calories at lunch they're gonna
eat fewer calories later in the day
by four or five after having sugar fat
and salt
throughout their you know toddlerhood
four or five-year-olds you measure the
ability to compensate and you see
they've lost the ability to compensate
they no longer regulate their intake
you have children who are four and five
who've never been hungry and they'll
have any sense of being hungry anytime
during the day they eat constantly it's
it's as if the reward circuits of the
brain
are being hijacked and override the
body's homeostatic mechanisms
what's the
task
tobacco a great great great week
a great 15 years of effort
tobacco is easy
why
because you can live without tobacco you
don't
you don't need tobacco
food
food we need to live so how are we going
to handle it
the problem
problem is in dog food
we have taken food and we've
processed it to such an extent
we've processed it to such an extent
that it's pre-digested we're eating in
essence baby food if you don't believe
me just adult baby food just count the
number of chews
right the average
bite 20 years ago it was about you know
20 you choose about 20 times today food
goes down in a wash it's so pre-digested
and so processed and what happens when
food is so pre-digested and it's made
out of fat sugar and salt it stimulates
intake it hijacks the brain it goes that
wash and it's it's
in essence oral sensory self stimulation
is is what's going on
what is key
right
how did we how did we succeed
how did this country succeed over the
last 50 years with tobacco
sure we finally finally
you know in the next couple of days
matt when's the president going to sign
it
right finally there's going to be
legislation
but it wasn't legislation or regulation
that's done it what's been the success
so far what's been the key
ingredient
right that it's accounted for the
success to date over the last 50 years
we didn't change the product the product
is the same
education
what
what what did the what was the one thing
that philip morris and the other
companies cared more about than anything
else
money no
image but what about image what they
cared about was the socially
the social acceptability of their
product
right back 30 40 years ago they had it
was
tobacco was a reinforcing substance
right
and it was positively viewed
right they made it as something you
wanted they made it as something you it
was your friend
right that was the key what was the real
change
what was the real success
what did we collectively do as a country
we changed the reinforcing substance
from something that was positively
valenced
to something that was negatively
valenced
so social norm social acceptability
we didn't change the product
right
social norms have a great deal to do
with how whether we're going to approach
something that's my friend i want it
or that's my enemy i'm going to avoid it
where do we have to focus
the problem
i think the problem
is very much
not only sugar fat and salt
but it is big food
and i don't just mean the industry i'm
talking literally
about big food the challenge
it's as hard a public health challenge
as
we can imagine
it's not just about us it's not just
about that woman on oprah i mean it's
about our kids
because once you lay down that neural
circuitry once you lay down that old
learning the only way to deal with this
is to lay down new learning
and new circuitry and the fact is and we
have to be upfront
that old circuitry never goes away the
greatest gift you can give somebody
is to not have
that
circuitry that responds constantly to
sugar fat and salt that has really been
laid down
in the brains of millions of americans
once you recognize that our behavior as
a nation is becoming conditioned and
driven
it's not just the learning circuits the
learning motivational habit circuits
because of putting sugar fat and salt
that is the result of
that's happening to us
in our society that has profound
implications
for for policy
but as many of you know
in this audience you've not shied away
from big tasks before
and i will tell you
15 years ago
a number of us when we started
had serious doubts
um whether tobacco was possible
and changing
in getting regulation for the fda
sometimes just sometimes things that you
think are impossible can really happen
thank you very much
[Applause]
should we
take some we have time for some
questions
first of all thank you doctor uh and
bravo to everyone in this room who
helped uh walk that journey on all of
our behalfs with respect to tobacco
thank you
um a specific question and uh for the
future the next steps and kind of
timelines concept
about you know when the behavior is
individuated
now the behavior we know uh given the
diabetes type two statistics and the
percent of our population already
contaminated for one of a better word
um
what about the the breaking of the
individuation the neural networks you
mentioned uh and and the developing
literature around relapse behavior uh
and learning that can be taken from some
of that related to the various
addictions that are being studied now so
a wonderful wonderful question and we
could spend an
hour
several hours i mean talking about that
question it's one of the reasons i i
wrote the book but the the
the question has a degree of
sophistication when you raise it you
recognize
right by asking that question that the
only way
to overcome that past learning that um
that's laying down of that neural
circuitry is to lay down new learning on
top of that
you know i joke
a little bit but it's true what's the
definition of rehab
rehab is really laying down new learning
new circuitry i mean just let's just
let's just agree on something diets are
not going to work
yes they'll work in the in the short
term but short-term diets can't work
and you know with great admiration for
carla and barbara and this bookstore all
those books on
on diet i mean i don't think there are
many in this bookstore but some
right diets by their very nature
i
can't work why not
once that neural circuitry is laid down
can you lose 30 you know can you take 30
days 60 days 90 days
and
um
and you know just white knuckle it right
and lose weight of course
but what's going to happen when you
finish doing that
right and you still have the old neural
circuitry that old learning you've not
laid down new learning on top of that
old learning and you go back into your
environment
and you constantly get bombarded with
the old cues
it's a fatal complete you're going to
gain it back the only way to um
to deal with this is to add new learning
new
circuitry how do you do that
you know i mean i mean how do you what
is the rehab what's that process
because it's not a it's it's not
something that you do in a day or even a
week
and again people don't want to hear this
because people always what's the magic
pill that i'm that's going to work
it's not going to work why not
because you're involving the learning
memory and a bit and habit circuits to
the brain
and if you start
mucking around in those circuits with
any pharmacological agent you're not
going to be selective just to food
you're going to have significant adverse
reactions because let me assure you we
need the learning memory and habit
circuits of the brain to be able to be
so
to survive to function
let me understand this is not
this is not about some
disorder or disease
i thought when i started writing this
book that i'd end up in the world of
endocrinology and physiology and
nutrition this is what makes us human
because we are wired to focus on the
most salient stimuli as human beings i
mean if a bear walked in here right
you'd stop listening to me i promise you
if you're a child if your child is sick
right
if your child is sick you're thinking
about your child for some people the
most cellular stimuli may be alcohol
other is nicotine some gambling some
sex some illegal drugs but for many of
us one of the most salient stimuli in
the environment
is
is food
at the core of that food is
sugar fat and salt so how do you cool
down the stimulus right and the answer
is
you have to change how you view that
stimulus if you look at that stimulus
and say i want that that's my friend
that's going to make me feel better
there's nothing i can do there really is
a critical perceptual shift that you
have to undergo
to
the point where you say you look at that
stimulus and you say that's not my
friend but how do you get there because
you look at that food and say boy that's
going to taste good i want that and it
is going to taste good in the short run
but you have to want something more and
you have to substitute things that you
want more please
i'm a general internist and i've been
waiting to ask this question for a long
time i face this every day
diet and exercise
and i figured that we're hardwired to
like sugar fat and salt sugar in the in
the forest when we evolved there wasn't
very much food we had to live in a
situation of semi-starvation sugar was
the fastest form of energy fat was the
most efficient form of energy and salt
was essential to life
and that's where it comes from and
that's why it's those things
they're very salient stimuli they
trigger receptors in the oral sensory in
the mouth
right and they're linked
directly through the thalamus to the
reward centers of the brain that's why
they're so powerful i mean you know
drugs the kind of drugs we talk about
they go through the bloodstream through
inhalation through the bloodstream i
mean and they they go to the specific
receptors
but the the real pathways that we're
talking about the learning memory uh uh
motivation and habit circuits of the
brain sugar fat and salt they're wired
in
that's why i mean it was from an
evolutionary uh perspective and that's
why they're so powerful
we're hardwired we we are we are
hardwired to focus on the most salient
stimuli and fat sugar and salt i mean
because of the receptors and because of
the learning
but i understand it's learning and
conditioning
that occurs that two-year-old regulates
you expose them it's their past if you
expose them to sugar fat and salt
they'll lose the ability to compensate
right
because sugar fat and salt become
especially when you put it on every
every corner we had barriers in this
country four or five decades ago that
protected us we only ated meals right we
ate real food i mean my hat is off to
michael poland to alice waters i mean we
really we used to eat real food now all
we're eating we're eating to stimulate
ourselves and we're stimulating those
reward circuits but we also used to do
manual labor and have women at home who
cooked food we didn't need to eat fast
food i i um
i i won't get in the last one i'll i'll
stay away from
right
but but look there was no doubt that my
grandmother there was you know dessert
was fat and sugar but that was
occasional there were certain barriers
there's social norms i didn't have it
for breakfast lunch and dinner i didn't
have it throughout the day that's what's
the change for the last and but
understand making that available and
socially acceptable and adding the
emotional gloss of advertising look at
an ad
look at an ad tonight on tv it's not
about the nutritional value of food yes
it may be the the economic value but
look at what the the ad does it's adding
the emotional gloss you'll want it
you'll love it it's the social
acceptability to want this product and
once you add that social acceptability
you're only amplifying the reinforcing
uh circuits and amplifying the brain's
response thanks for being here
hi good afternoon dr kessler thank you
for coming um i have a follow-up to your
answer to the first question
um
how do you
change
the things you tell yourself in the food
rehab like
i don't want to eat this because i'll
feel bad later on
or you know something similar to
something down here
where that's the first thing you think
of where you're looking at a
picture of chili cheese fries on a menu
and you're not thinking
i should eat something else because the
chili cheese fries will make me feel bad
later
and
something like this which is faster
which we all know that kids say
that
gross i don't want that you know that's
more down here and it's fast
you know and this saying this which is
good the rehab is good up here
but if you want something fast and
saying not just
okay i don't want to eat the chili
cheese fries because it'll make me feel
bad but i'd rather eat you know a baked
potato because
i want that i want that better i want
that better here not just i want that
more up here
so
what's what you need the goal
scientifically
and i know this doesn't it's not an
intellectual it's not kind of is to
avoid that circuitry from being
activated right and that i mean that if
you don't that's the only way
you're going to
you're going to stop eating excessive
eating is is just not to have your brain
constantly activated right so there are
a lot of triggers
there are all the cues that sight smell
location time of day that will set off
that cue but
it what's key
what what is key for that brain to be
activated
is
the
the fact is past experience that past
wanting those thoughts of wanting
i mean the what we what we did with
tobacco
by
making it viewed as a deadly addictive
product that people didn't want it cools
down the stimulus
right now
the the what's so hard
right what stimulates those pathways if
you have any inner dialogue any
ambivalence yeah it's not good for me
would taste good that only increases
that
that activation why does
why if you look in alcohol
right and you look at aaa why it's been
why has it been so successful
because
i'm not gonna get into the religious
aspects of it right but the fact is it
has absolute rules and sometimes that
sounds anti-intellectual but rules work
i know if you put that huge plate of
fries in me in front of me and i'm gonna
start have the first one i'm gonna eat
the whole thing
so it is just easier for me to have a
rule that i'm not going to do it and
it'd be black and white if you know
something's impossible
and there's no ambivalence about that
your brain is not going to get activated
we can i can show you the science if you
look at smokers and you say to a smoker
you can it is impossible for you to
smoke for the next four hours
and you cue that smoker their brain
doesn't get activated because they know
it's impossible
watch a smoker i mean no smoker i've
ever seen a smoker open the emergency
exit on a plane and jump out
right
because because they know it's
impossible for the period of time that
they're on the plane but watch them
toward the end of the flight right
that's when the brain becomes activated
so if you if you can develop rules for
yourselves and one of the reasons why
planned eating or structure as we talked
about helps if you know what you're
going to be eating and when you're going
to be eating then and you're not going
to allow yourself to eat all the time
then over time all those cues
are going to extinguish then you'll
never get rid of them entirely i mean i
mean if you're stressed if you're
fatigued if you're deprived that old
circuitry will show its head right but
but you have in order to cool down the
stimulus you're really going to have to
not want it but it can't be a
you know it can't be an ambivalent i
don't want it it has to be
i really don't want that and the only
way you're going to say i don't want it
is to want something more
okay thank you
just a general note and then a specific
question about your time at the fda if
you would if you wouldn't mind
um i think a lot of the i i appreciate
you're talking about the symptoms and
not just the problems but i if i can
make just a caveat i think a lot of this
is about loneliness and foreigners who
have come and done uh
written books about america simone de
beauvoir frank
robert frank referenced the the
the loneliness in america
and i'm wondering it also i just thought
this out as a rhetorical not for you to
necessarily answer but in a society no
other society in human history has been
founded just on the individual and i
think it's the pressure that the average
american is put on to self-regulate is
unheard of in human history
including comparing a modern-day other
societies and having lived outside this
country a lot
over and over again you hear as other
societies pick up the
fourth and fifth gears lifestyle
that the fast food the the the value of
efficiency versus
nurturing human relationships which is
usually food brought us together but in
this
land efficiency is valued you know in
other words it's a basic primal
biological thing called food as opposed
to nurturing hearts minds
kindredness and a lot of this is simone
de beauvoir pointed out in some of her
lectures is it's the loneliness of the
society because the individual just ups
all other values of the collective um
but i just throw that out for something
for folks to think about but um you
can't underestimate the indoctrination
that's going on as far as the industry
and they started this with advertising
uh
with promoting smoking that was very
calculated but i wanted to ask in your
quest your time your tenure at
food and drug administration
um
the the the kissing cousin to this whole
issue of obesity etc etc
i'm surprised you never mentioned the
other profiteers in this drug and it is
a drug pushing industry let's call it
what it is is the real the other drugs
that as much as you see food being
advertised on television is
the kissing cousin called big pharma at
works products and i'm thinking
specifically about
fin fin which killed tens of thousands
primarily women in this country no one
went off to jail but if it was you know
an inner city or
some person
hillbilly out there shooting thousands
of people
as this
american home products did
no one was held accountable and people
are still dying as a consequence of that
primarily due to primary pulmonary
hypertension
you were at the fda at the time of this
whole
fallout of the f of uh finfen and i'd
like to see hear what you have to say
very eloquently said
a lot of different points
just on the first point
um on loneliness
and
why we
you know what are the things that the
trigger
understand with food
food is a very powerful stimulant
it is a reward and let me how we use the
word reward jerome kagan the great
developmental psychologist
defines reward as something that will
change how you feel
so food has because it's wired into the
reward pathways of our brain the
learning memory motivational circuits it
can change how we feel so it's a very
powerful stimulus and there is no doubt
that millions of us i think the vast
majority of us are using food to
self-medicate
right because
when you're in this cycle
what happens
food you have the the thoughts of
wanting the thoughts of this will taste
good it captures your attention
right
it and it occupies working memory and
when that happens
you're not thinking about all the other
thoughts of the day i mean why do you
eat at the end of the day
i mean why do people eat at 10 11
o'clock at night
a few of you are shaking your heads
right i mean it's to calm down
right it's to change
i mean in in essence it's to regulate
emotional level and and when you use it
like that that's part
i mean that's because you're you're
stimulating the the this this reward
pathway and doing it over and over again
the the the comments about fenfen i
think are are especially
important there's a chapter in the book
and i put the chapter in in in the book
look fenfen worked directly on the
reward circus
it's in essence i mean uh both
phantaramine is an amphetamine-like
compound it's been around for 30 years
uh phenphloramine
affects serotonin levels understand
that these drugs
are affecting the circuits that make us
human
and i think as we have this evidence
that this overeating
is
you know the result of excessive
stimulation of these circuits drugs that
mess around in those circuits are going
to by their very nature affect very
important human circuits
and they're going to in fact affect
intelligence they can affect memory
they're going to affect
psychiatric symptoms and i think we're
learning that and i think we're we're
smarter today
than
we were i think it is going to be very
hard
if not impossible once you understand
that eating is the result of stimulation
of those circuits and we need those
circuits for other things to find
something that is selective for just
food
and i think that is you know i i don't
think it's going to work and i think the
agency is becoming much more much
smarter um and much more
skeptical
certainly when
these are these are circuits that
involve
our
what makes us human we need these
circuits and these circuits are being
hijacked by put by what we're doing in
society by putting fat sugar and salt on
every corner and to think that you're
going to have a drug that's going to
decrease the stimulation of those
circuits and and cool that down we got
to find a better way
thank you uh both sides this week
just make it very short we have time for
my two or three questions
both sides this week on the menu
labeling question made some big
concessions that mean that the
the regulation might actually pass this
time but what i hear you saying is that
you could have menu labeling up the
wazoo and unless the basic food is not
changed that it's not going to change
the problem i i think i'm a very big fan
of menu labeling okay i i i strongly
strongly support uh congresswoman rosa
dolores uh bill senator tom harkins bill
we need to get that because it will
change how we respond to the stimulus we
need a range of tools i was giving a
talk at
google and i went into the cafeteria and
it was striking
in front of foods each i mean each food
there's either a red yellow or green
sign and it's right in your face and i
will tell you it has a real effect right
the red means
eat it small amount for taste yellow eat
a moderate amount green you can have as
much as you want boy i mean i was in
charge of regulating food and it and so
i'll tell you still it had a major
effect on me i'm
we have to change how we
um perceive the stimulus we have to have
greater disclosure
we have to change i mean we don't stop
with just menu labeling what's served in
the schools
what um the vending machines i mean
parents i mean it's so hard you try as
hard as you can and you send your kids
to school and they're being stimulated
with fat sugar and so they said farm
subsidies
they have to change how we regulate
advertising i mean we have to make
progress but menu labeling is a key key
step
in changing how we perceive you know the
product thank you very much thank you
good afternoon
quick question despite your comments on
rules we can't just tell coke burger
king mcdonald's just to stop serving
food at least we can try but it's not
gonna work what would you suggest
um since you're no longer an official
and can actually talk about these things
uh general practices that the government
could take
to uh push us in the right direction
short of just banning stuff
the freedom of uh being a former uh
official i mean it's great
i think there needs to be further work
on the label
i think there needs to be front of the
pack labeling i think added sugars and
fat need greater disclosure i think
restaurants certainly the chain
restaurants
the information you shouldn't have to go
dumpster diving to get the information
what we subsidize uh with tax dollars
needs to change our school lunch
programs need to change and allowing and
this is this is i think one of the key
areas
right allowing the industry to amplify
the reward value of a reinforcer whether
it's nicotine or as fat sugar and salt
by advertising and adding the emotional
gloss
i think we have to really rethink how we
look um at those things that enhance and
amplify the stimulus i think there's a
lot of work now that we know that the
brains of millions of americans are
literally being hijacked thanks for the
question let's take one more one more
request
one or two if you flip over
the suggestion you spend so much time
talking about fat sugar and salt is it
possible to wire people to want protein
and carbs which is the you know the
where the bulk of the calories are going
to come from
uh
non-sugar carbs i guess is the way you'd
put it yeah so so it's very interesting
i mean there are
each of us this is highly personal what
we view as the most salient stimuli and
what we want
right so
take vegetarians for example and i'm not
endorsing any one of these but it's i
mean if you could be a vegetarian for
example and you look at animal fat and
you know and you say i don't want that
this is what i want
then it's it's much easier to cool the
stimulus on everything else
and you what you want is vegetarian
foods the the they're increasingly
people are looking at food and saying
this is just highly processed i don't
even see any food here right
and i i want to eat something that's
going to sustain me that's going to
nurture me
it's going to give me sustenance and i
don't see any food there that helps you
you know look at the rest of the that's
out there and say i don't want that i
have finally gotten to the point i went
to i went to a food coach
because she didn't understand the
neuroscience
but but i want to know how you know give
me advice on how she spends her life
helping people control their eating and
she said what did you have for dinner
and i told her and i thought i had eaten
relatively healthy i told her about this
appetizer i told her about this entree
she looked at me and she said
do you know you just say
two meals
at that one sitting
you know i mean that that really for me
right
how much do you do we need i mean think
about it how much food do you need
to sustain you for the next three hours
right
you need about a well you're shaking
your head you need you need about 100
calories an hour to sustain yourself i
mean on average
right
i mean i now eat half
of what i used to eat because i now know
i mean i didn't even know this she said
you ate 12 ounces of protein in that one
sitting i didn't even know what 12
ounces of protein looked like
right i knew something about a pound
being three
ounces
right so so what it involves is changing
how you perceive what you want right in
the the you know an earlier
questionnaire talked about loneliness
right
i mean if you want to eat because it's
going to make you feel better you're
going to eat because you you feel better
if and if you think that that's what you
want if you look at that huge plate of
fried and say that's my friend that's
going to make me feel better there's
nothing i can do we got you got to
change it where you look at that that
plate of rice that's not my friend
that's not going to make me feel better
but you have to want something else and
once you want something else it's easier
to cool down the stingless that's the
way our brains work thank you very much
thanks for being here
[Applause]
david kessler has been the dean of the
medical schools of yale university and
the university of california san
francisco he served as commissioner of
the u.s food and drug administration
under presidents george h.w bush and
bill clinton from 1990 to 1997. dr
kessler is a graduate of amherst college
harvard medical school and the
university of chicago law school
rodale books is the publisher to find
out more visit rodale.com
the democratic national convention live
from charlotte north carolina starting
monday september 3rd
now a conference on obesity in the
african-american community
panelists discuss cultural and
environmental factors that contribute to
the problem and a second panel looks at
policies that schools can adopt to
address the problem
the conference was hosted in washington
by the online magazine the root
well thank you for participating in our
black fit and healthy series and for
attending this health disparities panel
for the next hour we will discuss
solutions for eliminating some of the
health issues caused by obesity that
have a disproportionate effect on our
community and our esteemed experts are
sherry krute who is an award-winning
writer and editor who covers a broad
range of health topics and specializes
in consumer multicultural health a
veteran journalist and a contributor to
the root
she was the founding health editor for
heart and soul magazine the nation's
first publication focused solely on the
health needs of african-american women
and she has literally written the book
on how to cover health disparities in
the media
next we have eleanor hinton-hoyt
she has been president and ceo of the
black women's health imperative since
2007.
as president hinton hoyt has been
committed to advancing the core values
of social justice in reducing health
inequities
engaging black women to become advocates
in the fight against hiv aids and breast
cancer and advancing black women's
well-being by promoting reproductive
justice
expanding contraceptive access and
encouraging healthy sexual behavior
finally we have dr michelle gordin
she is the ceo of michelle gordin and
associates a consulting firm that
creates policy solutions and improves
the health of underserved communities
she is the author of reclaiming our
health a guide to african american
wellness a graduate of the johns hopkins
school of medicine dr gerdin is a
clinical assistant professor of the
university at the university of maryland
school of medicine and senior associate
faculty at the johns hopkins school of
public health and she's also the former
deputy secretary of health for the state
of maryland
so thank you all so much for joining the
panel we really appreciate it
um so first and foremost all three of
you cover a wide range of health issues
in the work that you do
can you explain a bit about how you're
addressing the obesity epidemic in your
work eleanor do you want to
start
certainly it's my pleasure and i'd like
to congratulate the group for bringing
this uh
obesity to the attention of so many
this is
certainly an issue that we have dealt
with
in our almost 30 years of being in
existence
making sure that we be the voice
for black women's health and dealing
with uh the real
experiences that black women have and
being overweight on obesity is part of
our cultural heritage and so what we try
to do is we
hear the stories we sort of be the boys
at the kitchen table everybody's kitchen
table
from congress and the administration
policy makers and other organizations
so that we can
move this issue beyond
the individual woman
to take it into consideration uh the
social health determinants but also the
environmental and and food industries so
one we're the voice and two we
we hear and share the stories you'd be
surprised of the many stories we have we
get from black women who can't get care
who are refused care and certainly can't
get quality care
and thirdly we worked very hard on the
affirmative care act making sure that
there were provisions that took in
account some of the preventive measures
that you now find in the affordable care
act and aca
that will
provide
at either no cost or low cost on no
costs begin in 2014 but low cost now and
certainly no pay for many of the
essential benefit preventive services
benefit
we also deal with obesity through our
uh through our self-help sister circles
and and and and i'll pause there because
i know other people do much more but one
of the things that we understand is that
weight is not weight
in itself
uh that you have to deal with some of
the social psychological barriers that
exist as well as the environmental and
we deal with some of the environmental
and and and systems change such as
working with nma to get doctors to be
more sensitive and we talked about that
in our uh briefing and so
we have something called a self-help
sister circle so women can share their
pains and their shame
and the trauma of being either refused
care by some physicians or not getting
the kind of care by some physicians
and also the shame of being
black and female as well as big
just to add on to that
underlying all the things that i've done
in my career i'm a doctor and so
initially
my job was to diagnose and treat some of
the um
outcomes if you will of of carrying
extra weight you know the high blood
pressure the diabetes etc and what was
so unfortunate is i'm a pediatrician
and so i was treating those conditions
in my patients in fact more and more we
began to see
children with adult medical problems a
disease that we used to call when i was
in medical school adult onset diabetes
we no longer call it that because we're
seeing it in children
and so i got to the point where i was
frankly tired of of
trying to patch up sort of what was
happening the after effects
of
of obesity and and related conditions
and really wanted to do something to be
able to help people live healthier lives
and not get sick in the first place not
have to come to the doctor in the first
place to be treated
and so my goal in writing reclaiming our
health the guide to african-american
wellness and in the the policy work that
i do
is is twofold one to provide education
we talked a lot about that this morning
about the need for all of us to
understand
what it means to live healthier but it
goes beyond just the education because
you also have to have what i call the
resources that you need to be healthy
you know you have to have the access to
the healthy foods you have to have the
ability for your children to be able to
go outside and play and get adequate
exercise
you have to be able to have
health insurance so that you can see the
doctor in the unfortunate event that you
do need to see the doctor i mean life
happens and sometimes we do need to do
that but we also need to understand some
of the underlying issues like what
eleanor touched on briefly stress stress
is a huge huge issue in our society and
we don't talk enough about that and i'm
sure we'll get into more of that as we
go on through this panel but
understanding those issues and then
translating what's happening on the
ground in our communities
into
language and into policy options and
solutions that our policymakers and
elected officials can understand and
develop into policies that transform our
communities and transform our societies
into environments that heal
rather than environments that sicken and
so that is is what i try to do every day
[Music]
i would say my approach is a little bit
different
as a communicator and someone who works
through the media i guess my personal
mission in recent years has become to
try to find a way to communicate about
all of the health care disparities that
affect african americans but in
particular african-american women who
i've written about most of my career
in a way that is fair and balanced
respectful
and does not stigmatize us or
perpetuate stereotypes that are
unhelpful and a struggle to try to
address the health problems we face
i've attempted it through books i've
attempted it through my own work but
also through
uh talks with much larger groups of
reporters through organizations like the
association of healthcare journalists to
try to help them understand ways to
cover some of the unique issues that
both dr gordin and
eleanor touched on just now which is
that many of the people who write about
our health issues
in national magazines and on the news
don't know us
don't know those issues don't know our
community don't know our culture
um and so they often create things that
are not uh constructive
positive inspiring and may even add to
the stress that you just mentioned
add to the self-esteem issues that have
also been mentioned and also limit our
access to resources so i make an effort
to try to make sure that the work i do
and the work that
maybe younger people that i come into
contact with
doesn't make those mistakes
thank you
so you touched on it a little bit
that you were
as a pediatrician
treating children for adult diseases
but that leads to the question is are
healthcare providers
adequately trained to help their black
patients fight some of these diseases
and
and
as a result fight obesity
no
i was trying to think of a nicer way to
put it but no
and and i can say that because i'm a
doctor and i know how we are trained
doctors are essentially trained to
diagnose and treat disease which
basically means that for most people
when you encounter a doctor you're
already sick
we're not necessarily trained in how to
keep people well
that's something that i had to learn
along the way of my career
and it's something that i think that our
medical schools are sort of evolving and
attempting to teach that but we have a
long way to go so that's one issue
teaching people how to
be well dealing with the individual
issues that
impact an individual's behavior because
when when it boils down to it when we're
talking about
eating in a particular way or getting a
particular amount of exercise it
requires a level of motivation and
desire on the part of the individual in
order to do that and that's not
something you can give somebody but
that's certainly something you can
facilitate and that's not something that
we have learned how to coach people
through
so if there were something that i would
say is lacking and that needs to be
nurtured in terms of training of our
health care professionals it is
teaching people coaching people you know
the root of the word doctor in latin is
teacher
we're supposed to teach
and we have not been doing a very good
job of doing that and so i think that
that's a really really important aspect
of what we do is to to begin to teach
and to coach not to
um
be paternalistic sometimes we tend to be
a bit too paternalistic where we're
looking sort of almost theoretically
down at the patient and saying you
should do this and you should do that
and then i've heard colleagues of mine
say well you know these patients are
those patients sort of very gen in very
stereotypical ways they won't do what i
tell them to do well you know who are
you to tell anybody to do anything
and so you know that's one issue the
other important issue and i talk a lot
about this in my book are is that we
don't have a good understanding of the
cultural and the environmental factors
that play into individuals making
decisions about their health
um as sherry was saying you know
individuals who don't know us who don't
know our culture
may not be able to relate in such a way
that would encourage people to to want
to eat better or to understand you know
how people eat i will give you one
example and then i'll be quiet i'm a
southern girl i'm from jackson
mississippi and i remember when i was
practicing um peeds and one of the
nutritionists
who was not black was giving a sample
diet plan to
one of the patients
and i took a look at it and i chuckled
because you know the mother took it and
just kind of threw it in a bag but i
knew she wasn't going to pay attention
to it again and i said you know what i
wouldn't follow this either when i grew
up in mississippi right wrong or
indifferent when i ate vegetables like
string beans they were cooked in
meat they were
and so we used the wrong kind of meat we
used ham hocks which we now know are not
healthy
but an understanding of that culture
from which i came and perhaps from which
the patient came might have allowed the
nutritionist to provide a more
culturally appropriate healthier option
for that individual we need to be able
to understand the culture within which
people live which influences how people
live and then we can be more effective
as healthcare providers and helping
people to live better
and so michelle is coming at this from
from the doctor's perspective and i
would assume eleanor you sort of have
know about this from the patient's
perspective yeah from the consumer
perspective which is very important
and and i do
appreciate doctors i love doctors and
yet i also recognize their limitation
and and that's what we have to do
because doctors are not doing so well
themselves
particularly black women doctors so we
shouldn't
depend on them
always to guide us in this but we should
enter i believe into a partnership
that it has to be a partnership and the
other thing in addition to doctors not
being
good self-care givers
and i have friends who are not good
self-care givers
and who are overweight and obese
they also need to be good learners
because they
have many of them
have
forgotten you know where they came from
and many of them internalize some of the
stereotypical images and and are very
judgmental and this is not anecdotal or
what i i'm telling you
what the black women's the 160 000
people in our database of the black
women's health imperative we have the
stories uh and if we don't have them
written they tell us whenever we have
gatherings but in addition to that i
think the the
the one thing that i'm hoping
um that the affordable care act and you
can see i'm a big proponent of it
because i think this is our one chance
if we can ever figure out
what it does what it has and what it
will mean for our community and for our
population that this is the one
opportunity that we will be able to
shift the dialogue from disparities to
equity because it has obesity obesity
counseling it has diabetes screening
even for kids and that's the good news
it has uh mental health counseling uh in
it it has all of the preventive health
services screening for uh gestational
diabetes
uh and so that catches it soon and
that's one of the things that we try to
do is to relate
uh diet obesity to
the diseases uh
of of weight if you know what i mean
diabetes and heart disease and and and
cancer
all related directly and indirectly
related to obesity doctors don't do a
good job at relating it making it you
know sure that we understand that
interrelationship
so that's why i'm pleased uh to work
with a lot of the medical profession uh
professional groups
so that we can
help
them understand some of the cultural
dynamics as well as some of the gender
specific issues that are going with
black women who struggle daily
uh in maintaining a certain lifestyle
including healthy weight management
well i'm glad you mentioned the
affordable care act it's the big story
it was actually it was mentioned earlier
today on our earlier panel
um
the big story is
kind of the battle around it and not so
much what's in it and you sort of
mention that once we find out what's in
it we can we can use it but what
what are you mentioned a few of them but
what are some of the things in the
affordable care act that could help to
combat obesity sherry
well there is a significant uh
prevention and obesity fund which i
probably could not find the numbers on
my lap it's it's um
i believe in the range of 74 million
dollars that's targeted specifically to
obesity and fitness
and includes i believe michelle obama's
initiative there is also a significant
prevention fund that is larger than that
that has an obesity component
obviously coming at it from a media
perspective and looking at the coverage
that i've seen most of the coverage is
very political right now what it doesn't
talk about is how grassroots
organizations and i know there are many
grassroots organization people here in
the room i've talked to some of them
today it doesn't really talk the media
coverage hasn't really talked about how
you can get to that money how that money
can be brought to low in income african
american women and other communities so
that it can be put to good use but it's
there um so i any of you who have say
legislative departments or connections
in local government i would say get on
the phone because it's a big pot of
money it's a very complex pot of money
um but it's there and and so it's there
to be had
let me just speak to that um this is so
very important because in many ways
community-based organizations will not
be able to get to the money it's 16
million for obesity and hypertension and
and and we decided as a national
organization
not to go for it because guess what
the american heart association and all
of the other big boys are going for it
and i know it in fact i was talking to
one community organization whose husband
is
chair of one of the forums and she said
well no i can't
agree i may not be able to agree to
partner with you because my husband's 51
megabytes organizations are going for
that so we're competing
with the big boys so that's 16 million
for obesity and hypertension
specifically
then there is the 74 million
prevention fund which includes obesity
as it relates to heart disease and
diabetes and we're going for those we
have a good chance for the diabetes
because we've had it before and it's
limited to
non-profit organizations
we have less of a chance of getting the
cbd the
cardiovascular because it's open to
everybody and that's 20 million
3 million dollars
per grant up to 10
8 to 10 grand and so to answer your
question sherry of how does it get
we're writing the proposal i mean i have
somebody in my office writing as we
speak
and so we are partnering with uh the
range the requirement is from 10 to 15
organizations we're trying to partner
with 15 community-based organizations
and about five
media and national organizations so we
will be given sub-grants from 100
000 to 200 000 depending on their reach
and most of them and so
that is the only way that
community-based organizations can get
that money unfortunately the good news
however
is that all we have to if we get the
grant as a national organization and
only national faith-based
uh for-profit um
and of an academic institutions and
research institutions qualify so we
compete every grant we compete with
johns hopkins they get it we don't even
though the black women in baltimore ask
us to come in and partner with them so
that's the politics of it
uh and so i will be calling you and
cheryl
and all of them when we don't get it
because if only white organizations get
these grants they can't focus on black
women they can't focus on the black
community we need to raise hell and i
know i'm on tv
well speaking of
being on tv and raising hell i mean
sherry we talked a little earlier about
how maybe cultural differences are
affecting coverage of
black obesity and black health in the
media
you are obviously
very well equipped to talk about this as
a health writer
what do you think of how black obesity
is covered
um i i have to say obviously i'm here
today because i'm not at all happy with
how it's covered i think
there are many people in this room who
have spoken to already who are familiar
with a very famous piece now that was in
the new york times in may by
an academic and professor named alice
randall
who wrote an article about how black
women like to be or were happy to be fat
to please our men
and to be larger for the sake of our to
honor our large grandmothers
the new york times has quite a bully
pulpit it has quite a reach i realize
i'm saying that in a citadel of american
journalism but it's you know it's pretty
significant
and i think it was a it was an
interesting choice to choose to put that
piece out there that way another piece
followed in three weeks from a
university in england which dr gordin
had mentioned it was a study that said
that adolescent black girls could not
benefit from exercise
in the fight against obesity
the analysis of this research if it was
accurate is important but there were
critical questions that none of the
coverage asked they did not mention that
the data on diet and exercise was
self-reported by the teenage girls
they did not discuss the fact that they
were basing their analysis on race for
which there is no genetic basis
and they did not talk about the other
benefits that these young ladies might
have gotten from exercise but these two
articles
along with one on child abuse
childhood sexual abuse
being higher in black women and being
linked to obesity they forgot to mention
that that's the same relationship for
white women and women of other races
received coverage and
abc news nbc news the huffington post
the la times medline
u.s news and world report but let me
tell you what came out at the same time
during that week that didn't make any of
those publications i have the study
title on my lap
descriptive study of educated
african-american women successful at
weight loss maintenance through
lifestyle changes
this study was done at baylor college of
medicine and it was also released in
june
it was mentioned in the last paragraph
in a single sentence of a huffington
post article on the cardiff study it got
no independent coverage it was covered
mostly on small blogs
and i guess we have to ask ourselves why
and how we can change this conversation
there are obviously people here in this
room and the root is holding this
wonderful conference because they want
to have this conversation but in my
opinion this is not the way our story
should be told it is not a helpful and
respectful way for our story to be told
um so
you raised some very very critical
issues i don't even know where to start
as you all know in our pre-call the
the article about
the black girl is not benefiting from
exercise is one that just really raised
my blood pressure tremendously um i had
major problems with it and and let me
let me give you one of the the punch
line first we have to learn how to be
critical thinkers we need to learn to
think for ourselves be careful where you
get your information from question the
motives behind the people who are
providing that information so having
said that this particular article was
brought to my attention by my husband he
sniffed it out of a newspaper and
brought it home and threw it in front of
me i hadn't seen it but the headline
stood out black girls don't benefit as
much from exercise as white girls i'm
like what
and the article was very general in what
it said it didn't provide a lot of
detail so i went to my computer and i
pulled up the research paper because i
wanted to see exactly what was going on
with this particular article and as
sherry pointed out there are so many
issues
with this article that were inaccurate
that i don't even know where to begin
but they tend to point to a number of
stereotypes and probably contribute to
either
covert or overt bias that we experience
as african americans when we encounter
the health care system the first issue
has to do with the fact that the
information the data that was reviewed
and evaluated in the study is what we
call secondary data which means this
data that was not even collected for the
purpose of this study was collected for
some other reason and they pulled it up
and they analyzed it and came to certain
conclusions
secondly as sherry stated it was
self-reported data about physical
activity the the bottom line conclusion
of the study which i don't agree with is
that they looked at black girls and
white girls who
got the same level of physical activity
over a year's time and found that at the
end of that year black girls were more
likely to be obese than white girls
most of the data except for three days
three days out of a year was
self-reported data
how accurate would your data be if you
self-reported every day i don't remember
what i had for breakfast this morning
[Music]
so self-report in and of itself
lends to
the possibility for inaccuracy
the issue of benefiting from exercise
was limited in this study to weight loss
we know that exercise helps lower blood
pressure it helps lower blood sugar it
helps with mental health issues it
lowers your bad cholesterol it raises
your good cholesterol the list goes on
and on and on and on and on there's more
than one benefit
as a doctor what am i supposed to do
with that that conclusion
am i supposed to look at patients and
pick out the ones who i think i'm black
and by the way race is not genetic
that's another issue
that tends to play into people's
thoughts about race and i'll get back to
that but am i supposed to look at people
and pick out the ones who i think i'm
black and if they're black females say
well honey don't worry about exercising
because it's not going to do you any
good anyway what am i supposed to do
with that
but finally the whole issue of race
being genetic and the implication that
there is a genetic inferiority among
african-american girls
really irritates me because first of all
race is social
race is based on fiscal characteristics
race has no genetic basis whatsoever if
you all don't leave with anything else
out of this conference today please
understand that because if you look back
in the days of jim crow
there were a lot of so-called research
papers being written
and scientists making proclamations
about the genetic inferiority and the
proclivity towards disease of african
americans which is not true but some of
us have internalized that
some of our providers have internalized
that and this paper tends to feed upon
that and for those who might be inclined
to think that way
then this paper and this conclusion
tends to support that erroneous train of
thought
and so again we need to be very very
careful about the coverage
that we pay attention to
as journalists
i would hope that everyone will be as
conscientious as the journalists in this
room in providing coverage that is
accurate
and information that is accurate because
people will walk away with that
information and it can cause a great
deal of harm and that's the last thing
we need when we're trying to fight this
this major health crisis called obesity
in our community
um
so
yeah
uh so
i
the the point of this whole day is to be
solution oriented and figure out you
know how to move forward we've
identified some of the problems on this
panel but
can can any of you share any examples of
organizations or healthcare providers
who are
winning or who have found a way
um an innovative way to
break through some of these barriers
anyone sure
um
well the first thing i want to say is
yeah there is a national movement
of smart young black women who are
fighting obesity in black communities
and among black women in america
i just want to acknowledge one of those
young ladies is sitting right there in
the second row
she is from an organization called girl
trek
um her organization is i believe 10 000
strong
okay
this is a national organization that
brings black women together to walk they
have to make an initial commitment to
walk five days a week for 30 minutes i
believe for 10 weeks to get started
they also have a serve division where
they ask black women to go into their
communities and talk about healthy
living
they also have a discover division which
is my favorite part which
sends young fellows out into the world
to discover adventure and fitness
vacations i think vanessa told me they
now have a young
african-american girl who is hiking in
alaska and her girl trek commitment is
to come back and to tell other young
black girls in her community what that
experience is like
um that's incredible yeah
there is another organization called
black women do work out this was started
by a trainer called crystal adele she is
on black women do workout has its own
website she has 16 000 members
of women who share their workout tips
their success stories their pictures
their dietary stories on her website
her facebook page has
268 000 plus likes
she's been in business for three years
and you have to ask yourself how come
she didn't get the page in the times
right
and the mission of her organization
is for black women to commit to not
being part of the obesity epidemic
another is black girls walk which is
also centered here i believe in dc 44
000 members around the country who meet
up to do walkathons in different cities
and black girls walks founder said to me
um she was i believe she said a size 22
in junior high school
she's now at 12 i think maybe
and she says she goes into communities
and she meets black women who have very
low self-esteem and are very
uncomfortable about being out with their
bodies and she said their motivation is
to get black women together
publicly
to support each other in this effort to
be fit and to be strong and to be
accepted in any way and to move towards
a positive goal those are just three of
the solutions oriented organizations
that are out there you can find them all
on the web and three of the stories that
i hope people will start to tell and
start to share
we we have had
a program walking for wellness for
i guess about 20
some years
and it and it
sort of
web and flow you know and but
one of the things we just supplied to
get a good great non-profit award uh
about a month ago
and we asked people we sent out to our
database and asked people to
to tell us what you think is good about
our organization and one woman wrote me
and said
it saved walking for wellness saved my
life
20 years ago i was 300 pounds and i'm
now
160 and proud of it and so that's an
example of some of the things that are
going on all over the country we have
one program
in boston with the boston women's health
institute
a slimmed down sister
that just in boston uh over a thousand
women
meet and give support to each other and
it's not just about
weight
it is about supporting each other in a
healthy
lifestyle so this we're talking about
lifestyle changes and these are the
stories that we need to get out and i
encourage those of you to we have a
website an incredible website we would
like to feature you on our website so
that our members can know that you're
out there doing that but i'd like to
just take a moment to switch from the
individual
and and and sort of center this
discussion
where i think it ought to be
which is at the societal level i know
that cheryl mentioned earlier in her
introduction about the healthy cities
initiative and that's where we need to
go
talking about and being involved in
healthy communities making sure we have
more farmers markets in urban
and the food desert communities making
sure we can walk to grocery stores which
means that you got to come to the table
and demand a grocery store making sure
that our our policy makers can put
street lights and walking paths and and
bike paths uh in your communities so
that people
can
feel safe and comfortable to go out with
others or alone in order to ha be fit to
have that healthy lifestyle uh to reduce
secondary uh
smoking that which which kills and has a
direct impact on cardiovascular disease
and and diabetes and most of all i think
is that we have to move it from the
individual
and and and and with all of these clubs
and walk-in groups and running groups
to to bring you together so that you can
figure out how you can transform your
community into a thriving healthy and
safe community and then
take on the the food industry uh we're
not fat because we want to be fat
the corporations have supersized us
i have one other suggestion too this is
if i was some
guru of the world and had a magic wand
and had one wish that i could
could command and it would happen
it would be for us to slow down
and here's why i say that
the obesity epidemic in our community
is not limited although it is definitely
concentrated it's not limited to
any particular
income or socioeconomic class
it it transcends all of that we're all
impacted by that in one way or another
and one of the things that sort of
complicates all of that is our our
complicated lives you know we're running
24 7 all the time
constantly
and that creates
within us an environment where we are
under a chronic level of stress
and i cannot begin to
emphasize to you
how damaging
having that chronic level of stress and
that chronic elevation of stress
hormones in our bodies
is to us
and it does contribute to obesity
you know it's it's not only if you're
living in a community where there's a
lot of violence and where you're
concerned about your safety
but it's also if you are in a
white-collar job and you've got a
blackberry and it's going off 24 hours a
day and you're expected to jump and to
respond every time it goes off or you're
in a community where you have to drive
you know one or two hours round trip in
traffic and you're stuck in traffic jams
and you know the road rage and
everything else begins to build up or
you've got
multiple obligations where you're taking
care of your children and you're taking
care of your elderly parents and you've
got um church obligations and you've got
civic civic obligations and all of this
stuff going on contributes to chronic
stress i once told my kids this and they
didn't believe me i said you know when i
was growing up
around midnight when you were watching
tv
you would hear the national anthem play
and you see the flag waving back and
forth
and then the tv would go off
and they were amazed really
and
now it doesn't
it's on 24 7 and that's almost like a
metaphor for our lives and it really is
creating problems and then compounding
this when we're talking about
african-american women who are the most
impacted group when we're when when it
comes to obesity african-american women
are impacted by this issue more than any
other group in this country
then we look at
how in general and again i know that not
all people fit into this category we're
acculturated and acclimated
you know we tend to take on this this
persona where we've got this big red s
on our chest
and we tend to be very independent
and we tend to be caretakers to
everybody
except ourselves
and so creating an environment however
we do that be it in the workplace or at
home or in the community
where we allow
and say it's okay
for us to take some time out for
ourselves
to refill our tanks because you really
can't give what you don't have right
and to allow us to begin to realize that
we
deserve to be healthier than we are i
really think that that has
a significant role to play
in the whole obesity epidemic especially
is that it pertains to black women
and so
yes the policy issues are extremely
important that's what i work on every
single day we have to do that
but we also need to look at what we need
to do to be able to support and nurture
ourselves
and create a space in which we
can slow down and which we can actually
begin to think about how we're going to
take care of ourselves and actually
believe that it's okay for us to think
about it you know self-care is not
selfish
yet many of us have grown up in
atmospheres where
you're either implicitly or explicitly
told that
and so if we could just
slow it down a notch and if we could
allow each other to slow it down a notch
if you're a boss
at a job you know allow
an opportunity for your employees to
kind of don't don't text them and email
them at three o'clock in the morning
like some people i know
and expect him to answer so that would
be my my wish if i were able to to have
one wish well thank you so much we um
can open it up to questions in the
audience now if anyone has any questions
yes can you hear me i just addressed to
the doctor can you speak a little bit
more about the role of say insurance
reimbursement in the diagnosis and the
treatment
of obesity issues are the the providers
incentivized
properly
to you know in a conducive manner
to prevent this issue
no they're not as a matter of fact
reimbursement is a huge issue that at
some point we need to begin to to
address
in this whole dialogue what we're
talking about is how doctors get paid
and what doctors get paid for and to be
very simplistic about it
you either get paid for procedures if
you are a doctor a specialist who does
some type of procedure like an operation
or something along those lines or you
get paid for volume which is why when
you go and see your primary care doctor
you've only got 15 minutes get in and
get out
because that is how doctors are
reimbursed and so it's a fundamental
flaw within that system that you don't
necessarily get reimbursed for providing
the ongoing counseling
that's needed in order to help people
through
whatever lifestyle changes they need to
make and we actually know from research
that's been done that one of the most
effective ways to help people lose
weight and to keep it off
is multiple opportunities to
be engaged in counseling that sort of
walks them through that process
not going to the doctor doctor saying
you need to lose weight come back and
see me in six months and i'll weigh you
but
checking in on you providing
that counseling first of all figuring
out where you are at the moment you got
to meet people where they are
so you may have an individual who needs
to lose weight and of course they need
to eat better and they need to exercise
but what they know that they are capable
of doing right now perhaps
is getting 10 minutes in of walking a
day so start there and you walk them
through that but to answer your question
currently the reimbursement system does
not support nor does it reward
uh our ability to to do that and that's
something from a policy standpoint that
we need to begin to work on
over here
[Music]
okay
what do we have first
i think you can go oh okay
you know i i just want to take the
opportunity and just you know tip my
head off to
you incredible women thank you
miss eleanor
for
talking about the silent conspiracy
that
black women black people period
walk around in
and um and and creating those sacred
circles
to address
the issues
because obesity
a lot of times has a lot to do with what
you're holding
and and and what you feel what you're
feeling that you don't have
and thank you for being very vigilant
dr gordon i mean
i definitely um would like to ask you
many questions but i know this is not
the format and thank you for being a
revolutionary you know in the medical
field because we need more
physicians like you
uh that
is actually transitioning into
teaching
you know because that's what doctors
that's what it means so thank you very
much and thank you very much and thank
you very much
back here my name is michelle booth cole
i'm with safe shores the dc children's
advocacy center we work with child
victims of physical and sexual abuse and
i'd like to hear a little bit about the
relationship between obesity and
unresolved sexual abuse in the black
community we know that people
self-medicate in lots of different ways
particularly in terms of food and black
women and so i wonder if there's
research that you've seen
anecdotal
but we we think that there is a
relationship
um i'll let dr cordian pick this up but
i just want to give you the reference
the black women's health study which
you're familiar with they are the people
behind the current research on
childhood sexual abuse and the obesity
link in black women
i think it's on their website
and just in very general terms related
to that you're absolutely correct um we
we do know about the link between abuse
and obesity um which honestly is not
surprising
given the fact that that other stressors
even though it sounds really diminutive
to call this a stressor this is a major
issue in individuals lives cause people
to
deal with the pain that results from
that
in in in ways that that might not be
healthy
we know that there are many many
different causes abuse being one of them
um of pain in individuals lives that
they choose to self-medicate through
what we call emotional eating
emotional eating is a major major issue
in our community
and basically people are eating food to
try to stuff the feelings back down
again as opposed to bringing them up and
dealing with them i think another issue
that might be related to that is
cultural you know many of us grew up i
did where you don't put your business
out in the street and you don't go and
talk to just anybody and so that perhaps
leads to a reluctance to seek the
attention and the counseling and the
conversations that need to be had to be
able to bring all this stuff up and
bring it out so in in short
absolutely
that that's a major major issue
especially among black women that we
have just barely scratched the surface
on
[Music]
hi my name is sarayan lee and
also known as anacostia yogi i'm really
interested in looking at how we can fuel
businesses
behind health because a lot of black
women have a lot of disposable income we
buy mac we buy weaves we buy clothes we
buy shoes but we won't take 10 bucks and
go to a yoga class or 20 bucks to get a
therap therapist so the issue i'm
curious about is how can we fuse the
business world for example you can go to
georgetown and hit 900 yoga studios
pilates studios health healthy foods but
if you go to
anacostia you can go to beauty supply
stores and chicken wing shacks how can
we shift the way people think about
money because it's not a money issue
it's more of what are you doing with
your money
well i can repeat myself in terms of
i think we're just beginning to do that
i'm not sure that it's going to be easy
to change the behavior
um
in terms of how we spend our money
i think that's deeply rooted that our
hair or lack thereof or
our nails uh mean
uh something to us because the media
also plays into how we think of
ourselves they control uh that whole
beauty the notion of beauty and color
and so i think that's one thing and we
talk about it a lot i would suggest also
that you go on our website
www.org
and go into some of our podcasts we've
had major uh many many discussions on
black hair and and
emotional eating and finding a good
black woman therapist and counseling and
mental health uh in the past over the
past three years but i think i really
truly believe if we're going to achieve
equity because i am so tired of talking
about
disparities which means
differences between
blacks and whites and when i'm talking
to women's groups i always encourage us
to
help white women understand that they
shouldn't be the gold standard by which
we're compared because they're not doing
that good either
and so what we and so if we shift that
dialogue and talk about building healthy
families and healthy communities and
healthy cities as the root is doing then
we can play a different and better part
in solving some of these problems
because in my neighborhood you don't
have the chicken chat you don't have the
you know you don't have the liquor
stores and so i'm looking forward to
moving into dc uh
during my
later years my mature years moving into
the district and i want to be part of
the solution of getting the billboards
and getting the
liquor stores
out of
georgia avenue
so that people can feel safe i really
truly believe
that the standard ought to be
healthy cities
healthy communities healthy families and
health equal healthy women who then have
healthy babies
um so my question i'm danielle moody
mills with the national wildlife
federation and a lot of the work that i
do has to focus focuses on the outdoors
and getting people outside and so you're
talking about healthy cities and
communities and i just wanted to ask all
of you in terms of when we we tell
people to exercise and tell people take
the stairs and there are a lot of
different ways that we tell people to
get fit but we never really talk about
the outdoors as a free
solution to to get fit so i just wanted
to know your thoughts as as you know as
a doctor and a health writer um and
and and being a part of the
the black women's health uh institute
like what you what you think about
utilizing the outdoors and how to get
more um african-american women and
people outside and active
i think the outdoors
presents a wonderful opportunity to get
fit we need to make sure that
everybody's outdoors is equally safe
and that's really one of the major
problems you know we've got we need to
pay much more attention to uh community
design
than we do
so that people don't have to get into a
car to be able to drive somewhere to get
to a safe part of the outdoors or drive
somewhere to find
sidewalks that they can walk on or
adequate street lighting or all of those
amenities that that make it more
attractive for people to come outside so
i think we have a bit of a ways to go in
terms of equalizing that and especially
when you're talking about the lower
income communities trying to get them
outside we really do have to work on
making sure that that safety issue is
addressed because right now we we've got
some issues and you know
i used to work in um east baltimore and
my patients parents were reluctant to
let their kids go outside and play and i
can't say that i blame them at all it
was not safe
so once we work on those issues i think
it is important for us to emphasize that
you should not have to pay
in order to be able to be physically
active
what we've resorted to doing in
communities where it's not necessarily
feasible or safe to go outside is offer
indoor options but you know wouldn't it
be great if we were able to offer those
outdoor options everywhere
there is also in san francisco i believe
an organization called outdoor afro have
you ever heard of them yeah black people
living in nature and i guess
um letting people know more somebody's
smiling over there
but
it's a people know more about
organizations like that and i think
that's also part of not writing
stereotypes when you write about us is
talking about the fact that we do enjoy
nature it can be part of our lives and
it is a natural thing to do for us to
trek and hike and rock climb and all
those things
anyone else i think we can take one more
we don't have one more well oh we do
we do over here
i brought up the issue earlier but i
didn't recall
if i got a response to the earlier panel
because i got a little bit emotional
but i'm calmed down now i'm tambra and i
live in anacostia and my goal is to
become a registered dietitian and i you
made a great point on being from
oklahoma and what motivated me to become
an rd was the need to have more
culturally competent
nutritionists out there who are serving
their community
and so i'm just curious about do you all
incorporate nutritionists and the work
that you all do as a partnership because
the reality is i have good friends that
are bariatric surgeons and they're not
doing self-care and i'm actually having
to provide personal shifting for them
because they can't get it right
and so we all need to work in
partnership and and i just
i know that there's nobody in is one
group within the academy
that is a group of black nutritionists
that i just recently joined but i know
that they haven't been a part of the
conversation and i even questioned the
the leadership where are you on this why
are you not on capitol hill like do i
need to be your rep in dc or something
so i'm just curious about how can we
create these partnerships with groups
beyond nma nda and all the other groups
out there or should we create another
group that targets black nutritionists
and get them involved
well i i must say uh that we do partner
with nutritionists and and all of our
chronic disease programs uh and we have
um our health experts um in fact in uh
our previous diabetes program i think
i'm right valerie uh most of our experts
were the nutritionists uh who and the
dietitians and who can uh be an expert
but also pharmacists
uh we partner with them and so don't
assume that uh community and national
organizations are not partnering and
building that team in order to bring
about change because they are there and
we do work with them
but having said that there's room for
improvement definitely um there is a
great need for
nutritionists and i think that as a
medical profession we have not relied on
you enough honestly
and again that gets back to the
attention being paid to helping people
change their behaviors one of the things
that mayor dellums brought up which
really hit home with me because i've
seen it is when he was talking about how
we've lost three generations to crack
and we've got kids who are parentless in
essence and have not learned from their
parents and one of the things they have
not learned is how to cook that is
absolutely true that's absolutely true i
was speaking to an audience several
months ago and um one of the persons in
the audience was saying well you know
it's so expensive to eat healthy and so
i was given giving an example the whale
doesn't necessarily have to be i said
look you can go and buy a bag of beans
for 1.29 and make a soup or soup that
will last you two three or more days
depending on how many people you're
feeding
and you could see the quizzical look on
that person's face like beans how do you
cook beans
and you know it's true we've got a
generation of individuals who are now
parents who have lost the cooking skills
that you know we learned from our
parents back in the day back in the day
in mississippi i used to hate it when my
mother would bring home a bushel of
peace because we used to have to sit in
the middle of the floor and shell them
and you know snap the beans and all that
stuff and that drove me crazy but you
know i learned from watching her how to
prepare those meals and that's almost
sort of a lost
art now and being able to cook for
yourself is so essential to eating
healthy because you control what you're
eating you're not at the mercy of others
who are preparing your food so yeah we
need to definitely talk more
well thank you
oh i heard i just found out we have time
for more questions
over here
hi my name is leticia stills and i write
for jack and joe politics and a little
shout out for outdoor afro because we
featured outdoor afro on our block so
and that's how i found out about
glamping i guess
glamorous camping yes
but um i guess one of the things that
i'm just going to throw through the
entire panel
uh there was some discussion about uh
being culturally sensitive doctors being
culturally sensitive and one of the
things that i did out when i lived in
san francisco and worked for department
of health
we had to develop a cultural and
linguistic competency program for our
healthcare provider contractors
and one of the things that we really had
to emphasize was how to culturally deal
with the diverse community that we
served and is there any type of
initiative that's being done
here in dc especially with regard to
how medical professionals should talk to
black women make them feel comfortable
because a lot of them don't like going
to the doctors unless they absolutely
have to because one of the things that
we had to do we had a large arab
community arab muslim community out in
san francisco and it was right on the
heels of 9 11 and a lot of people didn't
want to go to the doctor and so we had
to tell doctors you can't just tell a
muslim woman to take her clothes off so
she can be examined because
in their culture being asked to disrobe
like that is a you know you're shaming
them innocence so we had to do that type
of education and i just want to know if
that type of initiative is being done
here
you know
i can't speak specifically to dc because
i'm baltimore based but i can tell you
that in general there have been
initiatives of that type that have
attempted to teach
medical professionals about
different cultures
um and i think that there is some value
to that i think that's limited though
because i think what it causes people to
do is to assume that everyone who
identifies with a particular group is
sort of monolithic they're all the same
and that's not true
what i try to emphasize when i'm talking
to people about this are a couple of
things number one
um
mutual respect
is what is the foundation
of relating to anyone of any culture and
in that being able to communicate with
them and and listen
more than talk
to hear what's important to them but the
other thing that i i try to point out to
everyone and all of us are guilty of
this in some way or another is that we
tend to have underlying thoughts and
assumptions about particular cultures
and
if we hear
about a particular practice or belief
that we don't agree with we tend to be
judgmental about that case in point um
i guess this may be a year and a half to
two years ago now this gets back to the
black women's hair and exercise thing
um the surgeon general
was down in atlanta at the big broader
brothers hair convention big old hair
shoulders down in atlanta every year
and she spoke i think i just lost my
life and she spoke um
to the group
about
the importance of not letting your
hairstyle get in the way of your health
essentially
and
there was
a strong reaction from some individuals
in the public health community namely
one individual who was a white male who
basically said that there are much more
important issues and that the surgeon
general should not tarnish the statue of
the the status of her position by
commenting on something as unimportant
as this
that's what happens when you
tend to make
judgments
and value statements
about an individual's belief
rather than
accepting
what an individual values understanding
how that might create a barrier to
adopting a healthy lifestyle and helping
them get beyond that
we've got to learn i think this is core
to cultural competency in my view we've
got to learn to be able to accept the
cultural values and beliefs of other
people without judgment and beyond
learning all the important things about
how to treat people of certain cultures
when they come
and encounter you
that
being able to accept their cultural
values and beliefs without judgment and
help them to get beyond whatever
whatever barriers might be blocking them
from attaining
ultimate maximal health is what's really
really important in my view
one of the things that we do
particularly as it relates to relates to
reproductive justice issues
primarily contraceptives
and working with diverse populations
particularly non
english speaking populations and those
with those cultural values of disrobing
uh uh openly with people that you don't
know and so what we try to do is to
integrate uh the standards that
uh hhs i think it was the office of
minority health health or cdc class
clasp as an acronym uh uh instituted uh
trying to make sure that we acknowledge
without judgment the cultural and
linguistic differences and once again
because we're part of the women of color
reproductive justice network once again
we integrated into the affordable care
act
those
are measures that would help with the
language
also when we do focus groups and
roundtables and we want to know about
issues our latest said it was on
contraceptive
use and compliance and non-compliance we
had
we
translated it into spanish but we also
had latina and black young girls from 18
to 29
so you will find pockets of it all over
but particularly i think you where you
find your best practices and best
examples practice space rather than
evidence-based uh practices would be in
as it relates to reproductive health
well thank you so much dr michelle
gordin eleanor hinton hoyt and sherry
and
everyone there will be a short break
before our school-based solutions panel
and there are some snacks and
refreshments in the corner thank you
awkward
on america by the numbers we look at the
foods and beverages americans consume
how it's changed and what it means in
terms of our diet and problems like
obesity we're joined this morning by
cynthia ogden she's a nutritional
epidemiologist with the cdc national
center for health statistics thanks for
being here and also from national public
radio npr's allison aubry food and
health correspondent thanks to you as
well thanks for having me cynthia ogden
let's just start with the basics what
are the major changes we're seeing in
terms of americans diets right now over
the last decades
um over the last decades we've saw an
increase in
calories available
and
particularly in the 80s and 90s at the
same time we saw this increase in
obesity and more recently we've seen a
decrease in the calories consumed by
americans we've seen a lot of other
things though there have been changes in
diet in terms of how we eat and what
we're what we're eating
we're dividing the phone lines up
regionally for this segment we'd like to
hear your perspective on what you eat
and drink how it's changed and how it's
affecting your health here are the
numbers to call if you're in the eastern
and central time zones it's 202
585-3880 if you're in mountain pacific
or farther west it's 202-585-3881
is the big takeaway obesity is is that
the major change you started out by by
with that one
well really that that's a significant
public health concern right now is um
obesity and we saw large increases in
the prevalence of obesity in the in the
70s and the 80s and the 90s 80s and 90s
primarily it's been slowing down a
little bit more recently but
that's a big issue related to our diet
we can see here from the cdc obesity
increased in the 1980s and 90s in adults
and more recently the levels have
plateaued allison aubry what's the
plateau about
um well you're starting to see
what happens when
programs that have focused on better
eating in school more
as much as message has been out now for
over a decade and
you don't see the numbers heading down
but the trend is definitely a plateau
just last summer we saw some numbers
from places like new york city and
philadelphia
places where they've really focused on
getting kids active on changing
lifestyle and patterns of eating and
you can really start to see there in
those cities that the numbers are
plateauing
what are the health and policy
implications when we look at the rise of
obesity
um when you look at the rise of obesity
you start to see that it costs a lot of
money to treat obesity it's been said
that about 70 percent of spending of
healthcare dollars
comes treating people that have chronic
diseases and many of these chronic
diseases are the lifestyle diseases so
we're talking about heart disease we're
talking about type 2 diabetes and those
are all
the diseases that can be
prevented or treated better with better
lifestyle
we see here from the cdc americans are
heavier today than they were in the
1960s
today nearly 36 percent of adults and 17
of youth
are obese how are these studies
conducted
well that's a great question we have a
wonderful resource in the united states
called the national health and nutrition
examination survey and it's unique
because it combines an interview with a
physical exam and it's representative of
the us population actually mobile exam
trailers travel around the country
and during the exam things like your
weight and height are taken among many
many other things including blood draw
dental exam a variety of other things
but so these these measurements these
data are for based on measurements of
weight and height and which which is
important because
if you ask people their weight and
height they you can get
misreports men tend to over report
height and women tend to under wait
and and so as you actually look at the
look at the cold hard numbers uh
what is the take away uh in terms of
regional reporting do you have a sense
of areas of the country be it urban or
rural or parts of the country
geographically that are having a harder
time with health and weight
well there are different sources of
information on on regional differences
in obesity and we do see regional
differences in obesity so in the south
the prevalence of obesity is higher than
in other parts
one other chart here we have from the
cdc and the nchs looks at calories
consumed from fast food and the age
range of where people are getting those
calories depending on how old they are
we can see here the change in the real
difference between those who are in the
20 year old or 39 year old age bracket
they're consuming the most calories from
fast food the lowest come from those who
are 60 and over allison aubry what do we
know about the sort of the culture of
eating and how that plays
into fast food and diet well the culture
of eating is interesting because as
cynthia started out saying americans are
eating a lot differently than they were
a generation ago not just in terms of
what we're eating but how we're eating
people tend to snack a lot more
their studies showing that children
snack two to three times a day
and also if you look back to say you
know 1950 that typical american was
eating 2.8 pounds of meat a week
by 19 by 2006 that number had increased
about 50 percent
we eat a lot more cheese the typical
american eats about 31 pounds of cheese
a year and we drink a lot less milk um
so these kinds of things the way they
play out is that um you know these
things tend to have more you know if
you're eating more cheese or eating more
meat that's more saturated fat
as cynthia mentioned the trend line just
in the last few years has started to
show a downward trend we're starting to
see that red meat consumption is is down
after years and decades really of
increasing so i think that while it's
important to note that americans eating
eating habits have changed a lot if you
look over a generation it's also
important to note that americans seem to
be getting the message the message that
people need to be watching what they're
eating eating and balancing that with um
with with exercise all snobbery we see
the the my plate this is the new version
of the food pyramid who creates this and
and who works on policies uh
in terms of recommending to americans
what they eat sure um well what you see
in front of you is really the work of
the us department of agriculture and
health and human health and human
services get together every five years
and they create a panel a panel of
scientists and these panel scientists
sort of sift through the body of
evidence that's been emerging
the last time this happened was in 2010
and what you see in this my plate is you
might remember from the past it was a
pyramid and at the bottom it said eat
six to 11 servings of grain at the top
it said eat you know
just a few servings of oils or fats a
day
and the last time around the researchers
and the policy makers sort of said you
know instead of being so prescriptive or
qualitative we're going to focus on
patterns of eating we want this to be
simple for people so they change the
icon from the pyramid to this plate and
the idea here is sort of directional we
want to encourage people to eat or the
policy makers were sort of saying we
want to encourage people to eat more
fruits more vegetables if you look at
the plate there that's half the plate we
want to encourage people to me eat more
whole grains that's another quarter of
the plate there and eat proteins at the
same time be eating less sugar less
saturated fat and less sodium
alison aubry is with npr food and health
correspondent we're also joined this
morning by cynthia ogden she's a
nutritional epidemiologist at the cdc
national center for health statistics
let's go to the phones and hear from
joyce in woodbridge virginia hi joyce
hi i'm calling to find out about the
fact that for many many years
the doctors have told us that it is not
necessary for us to take vitamins uh we
can just get all the vitamins we need
from our foods
and um
i'm concerned about uh the chemtrails
that are in the sky that are all of
those toxic chemicals that are being
placed on the food now even the organic
food is in trouble because of all of
these chemicals
so if we don't take vitamins how how are
we going to survive or this onslaught
and why have the doctors changed their
views now about vitamins why are they
telling us now that yes we can take
vitamins that they prescribe
also
um i wouldn't say necessarily that
doctors have
changed the view i mean it's certainly
true
that perhaps your doctor has given you
different advice but what's happened is
that
as researchers have looked at the body
of evidence on on
taking vitamin and supplements they tend
to see
that
there aren't great benefits now before i
um you know make a lot of people mad
here i should say that it's case by case
for instance if you think back to the
1980s and 90s vitamin e was prescribed a
lot recommended by doctors and then
studies started to show
you know we don't really see a benefit
if we follow a group of people over time
who are taking a vitamin e supplement
and then 10 or 20 years later check in
with them to see if they've prevented
some kind of disease or cancer we don't
see we can't measure a benefit and so
that's where you start to see changing
guidelines is when researchers and
policy makers look at a body of evidence
and start to see
maybe not so much of a benefit here
but certainly the studies have gone both
ways so i wouldn't say that vitamins
have been ruled out altogether for
instance folic acid is critical when a
woman is pregnant that's why it's in a
prenatal vitamin so you can't
sort of paint with a broad brush here
but in general when you hear that
vitamins are not recommended anymore
sometimes it's because the results of
these studies that suggest a
multivitamin isn't as beneficial as once
believed cynthia ogden one of our
followers on twitter rick has written in
and asks how is overweight defined today
versus how we defined it 30 years ago
the definition of overweight or obesity
is different in children and in adults
but it's based on the body mass index
that i think most people are familiar
with which is weight over height squared
in metric units and for adults obesity
is a bmi above 30 and overweight is
actually a bmi between 25 and 30. for
children it's a little bit different
because it's in comparison to the growth
charts that most parents are familiar
with that obesity is above the 95th
percentile on the growth charts for bmi
and overweight is between the 85th and
the 95th percentile and i i just want to
point out that those growth charts are
also based on the national health and
nutrition examination survey that we're
talking about where these data come from
speaking of the differences between
adults and children we see here
children's diets and the calories that
are coming from carbohydrates you can
see here fat protein carbs and then how
that breaks down
sugars 30 percent alice and aubry what
do you read from this
there is a big push right now in public
health to limit added sugars in the diet
so we're not talking about fruits that
naturally contain sugar we're really
talking about sugar sweetened beverages
candies that kind of thing
it's been estimated that the typical
american gets
about 350 calories a day from added
sugar and the american heart association
has said that needs to come way down
they're recommending something in the
range of 100 to 150 calories of added
sugar per day so that's why you're
hearing a lot more about this in the
grocery store you're starting to see you
know on yogurts lower sugar there's a
lot of awareness about lowering the
amount of added sugar in your diet we
saw a recent poll looking at mayor
michael bloomberg in new york city his
plan to limit the size of sugary soft
drinks this of course is on hold right
now because of the courts but 70 in a
recent poll said they oppose it 28
in support have you reported on the
reaction to that proposal yes well we
have talked a lot on there about the the
sugar ban and the judge striking it down
and i think the question is well sort of
what next is there a different sort of
public policy is a different lever you
can use um you know states are trying
different things for instance right now
the governor of massachusetts has
proposed a sort of if you will soda tax
or sugar tax and basically making candy
and sugar sweetened beverages more
expensive now the legislature in
massachusetts
let that die
last year it went nowhere this year i
don't know that its prospects are any
better uh because of polls that you you
just mentioned it doesn't seem to sort
of hit people right people don't want to
be told what they can and and can't eat
um but i will say that there's a lot of
other ways to nudge people researchers
are sort of experimenting with ways that
we nudge people towards healthier
decisions just one example is
people who get their health insurance
through humana can enroll in a program
called humana vitality and when they
shop at walmart for instance if they buy
some broccoli or something that's
considered to be a fresh or good for you
food they get a discount and the idea is
that if you sort of give cash back for
broccoli or rebates for healthy things
you might nudge people to put more of
the healthy stuff in their cart and less
of the unhealthy stuff let's hear from
denver colorado gabe joins us now good
morning
gabe are you with us
all right let's go on to mike in
shippensburg pennsylvania hello
pennsylvania yes ma'am i appreciate you
taking my call thank you all right um
i have a comment and a question um
my comment is
obviously it's a very complex problem uh
there's not going to be any simple
solution to this problem it is a big
problem i realize that um and
my question is um
as far as uh food stamps are concerned
because this is a social problem and a
health problem but as has anybody looked
at the the fact that so many people are
on uh food stamps
and maybe there's a
a relationship between that and and
obesity going up and uh i have three
daughters i just want to put a plug in
for vitamins i i make sure they take
their vitamins every day i love taking
vitamins
um calcium too
michael thanks mike before we let you go
how conscious are you when you go
shopping for your family how much do you
think about the kinds of food your gut
you guys are buying for your kids very
i mean it
very conscious about i think it is a lot
of it has to do with family values and
just
individual family responsibilities how
have you learned how have you learned
about nutrition
uh just over the years and i try to
instill the values of my children too as
well
and uh
reading books online i mean all kinds of
information labels
you know food labels and such so all
kinds of different ways
let's go to cynthia ogden and have you
talk about this graph we're seeing now
in terms of
low income middle income and higher
income individuals and what kinds of
calories they're consuming
um well i i think i want to follow up a
little bit on his question as well
because i think the
relationship between obesity in
particular and income is actually very
complex and it's not always
what people think that it's just
low-income the low-income population
that's obese and so it varies by sex and
by age and on that relationship but this
graph in particular is related to sugar
sweetened beverages and
the percent of total calories in the
diet that are from sugar sweetened
beverages by income by the two different
ages by children and in children and
adults and you can see that in both
cases it's the higher income folks um in
this in this case it's about a third of
the population the the top third consume
a smaller percent of calories from sugar
drinks
allison aubrey reflect on that for us
and also what the caller was talking
about in terms of purchasing and food
stamps um actually studies suggest that
in fact food stamp recipients or
recipients of snap dollars as the
program is now called
don't actually distribute their dollars
too much differently than the typical
american so there's a bit of
stereotyping that goes on that people on
food stamps go and buy lots of unhealthy
things well the bottom line is lots of
americans buy a range of not so healthy
things and some healthy things also the
reality is is that when food stamp
dollars or snap dollars get low at the
end of the month it's often all someone
can afford is to just buy some you know
with crackers and lots of refined
starches because those things are a lot
cheaper
so um i think it's interesting that this
the focus on um on low-income americans
um
is an interesting one the state
legislature in florida last year tried
to pass a bill that would have uh
restricted the use of snap dollars or
food stamp dollars for junky food um and
that was not very successful um
and one of the reasons is is at the end
of the day you know if you say you can't
buy a candy bar with your food with snap
dollars does that also mean you can't go
buy the ingredients to save a cake if
it's your child's birthday you can't buy
the sugar or the flour it becomes a very
hard thing
to regulate that way
let's hear from john in oceanside
california good morning good morning
thank you for taking my call i wanted to
illustrate uh another aspect to
what has just been stated in
nethercaller i think that what one of
the things that really uh
strikes at the heart of the matter is
that we as consumers
are
paying
to undermine our own health through the
big subsidies that we give to big agra
and it used to be that those subsidies
were for the small farmers uh uh you
know think local
think organic or think healthy and uh as
it stands now most of the dollars are
going for these uh the big agro which
ends up invariably in a lot of processed
food which again goes back to
affordability so i think we have to
shift the gears
and and and americans are starting to
wake up thanks to people like dr oz who
who comes on um and enlighten people
that
uh you see more uh people wanted to do
their own organic gardens or community
gardens
and and get away from this processed
food but i think again
we have to somehow
uh get more money
to in sustainability and less
and less money going towards uh the
processed food industry that basically
undermines our health increases our
health care costs and just you know
lines the pockets of uh uh the the junk
makers and uh and the pharmaceuticals on
the end of it so john do you do you
practice what you preach do you yeah i
do
values are they reflected in your
shopping habits
uh well quite frankly it is i have a
community garden that i participate in
we grow our own vegetables we don't use
any chemicals which again affects the
environment
um so um there's a whole dynamic about
that one okay so let's get a response
let's get a response from our guest
allison aubry
um i think he raised a whole bunch of
interesting answers or questions and
points of view um i think it's really
interesting um what you say i i would
just point out one thing that's um when
you talk about big big ag
one thing that many americans don't
realize is that we're going to be
needing to get
more calories or more productivity out
of each acre of land in production just
because of the sheer number of people on
this planet so um i think that while you
raise really interesting and fascinating
points about community gardens and local
ag which is obviously
really big right now there's a huge food
food movement that's really exciting to
people that focuses on local food and um
but i think at the end of the day
most policy makers um and experts would
say that we need both that we need sort
of big farms and and we need this these
these local food movements as well a
couple of tweets that have come in
people reflecting on their own diets
gary says i was raised on no sugar for
morning cereals fried food only a couple
times a month and make sure your you eat
your vegetables that simple he writes
and then anti-victoria says i rarely
touch frozen foods of any kind the salt
content is off the charts likewise with
processed foods in the middle aisles dr
cynthia ogden is
research is conducted on what americans
are eating and how it's impacting their
diet how do you get uh analysis of
where the calories are coming from and
how americans are making choices about
where they shop or what they grow
well as part of this national health and
nutrition examination survey there is a
an interview about people's diet and
this is a typical way that diet is
information is obtained from people it's
you ask people in the last 24 hours what
did you eat and you spend time probing
and you know did you miss any snacks or
any any did you add sugar to that that
um particular food item and you and it
spent you take time to go through it
showing models of the food that um and
to get serving sizes because you want to
know how much it's not enough to know
well i had i had a hamburger did you
have a hamburger this big or this big
and so you really want to
drill down and get the specific
information about exactly how much of
which foods people consume so it takes
some time to do that all right let's go
to our next call rt is in burton
michigan hi t
hi
um yeah i have a question
kind of um along with a statement and
want to thank you for taking my call
with the
additive of aspartame that is put in our
food which is a chemical that we really
do not know
our bodies don't know what to do with it
so if it can excrete this chemical
then it's going to store it in our fat
cells it's going to store it in our
organs we are going to be
um
ill because of it but yet
it's an absolutely everything we eat
there's hardly nothing on the shelves
that doesn't have a form of aspartate
all right let's get a response from
allison aubry
um well i would say that um because of
labeling laws you you do know if you're
trying to avoid aspartame um it does
need to be
labeled and
um you know you're i understand your
frustration that you think too many
things contain this um i will say
aspartame has been widely studied over
many years and
if you look on the national cancer
institute's website you will see
sort of a statement of of
what the thinking is about aspartame and
the thinking is that at the levels that
people get it that doesn't seem to add
to the risks of of diseases in any
quantifiable way so that they've
basically come out and said that from
what we know so far aspartame is safe i
know lots of people don't agree with
that
and that's why we have labeling laws so
if you want to
to avoid it you can
sandra daly city california welcome
yes
i am going to
give some opinions uh as opposed to
um questions but
uh
i'm in my early 70s and so what i am
observing uh
young
parents um
feeding their toddlers
or their you know just younger children
that
they're giving them
the sugary drinks i see them giving
sodas ice cream cakes before the age of
three
and that um
when
when i was uh
feeding my
children
before the age of three they didn't even
know what a
a cookie was a cake was uh sodas that
sort of thing and
we had these little grinders that we
could buy
back in the 70s where i would cook my
own food and grind it for my you know uh
child to eat as opposed to buying
gerber
prepared baby foods and and that sort of
thing
um so uh
if you also you you mentioned uh
obesity not so much before the 80s
i was just making the comment the other
day
looking at some of the movies um made
before the 80s
we were all
thin
not obese
and why um also
in the last decade
i have had such gastric
disturbances
that even my
gastroenterologist could not figure what
was wrong
you know
going on with me
uh
he mentioned that he did test for celiac
disease and i was negative what it turns
out to be thanks to a friend of mine who
does have a child with
celiac disease she said
try don't eat anything with wheat for
four to six weeks see how you feel and i
did that just to see what would happen
and then as soon as i started eating
anything with wheat again i had the same
terrible symptoms
so um i i
basically become
uh
gluten intolerant
and i let my doctor know so that he
could learn from me what happened with
me and then you know help uh other
patients but besides okay sandra thanks
she brought up a lot we'll get responses
from both of our guests let's go to
cynthia ogden first so we can talk about
her observations about americans prior
to the 1980s at least what she's
observed in film and and photographs and
then also
the aspect of of children's diets
well um obesity was about 15 percent um
in adults and it doubled uh during that
period that um was discussed in the 80s
and 90s and you know one of the things i
think is really interesting about
obesity is that actually the prevalence
of obesity um was higher in women than
it was in men but essentially men have
caught up to women now and so that the
prevalence is the same in both in both
genders um this pattern you're looking
at in adults looks very similar in
children um however it's tripled in
children over the same time period here
it's doubled but in children it's
tripled and there's really very little
difference
by sex and then we're also seeing
children's diet added sugars from food
and beverages you can see here
food beverages added sugars what does
this tell you cynthia ogden well one of
the things that when allison was talking
about
how what how many calories people are
getting from added sugars another way to
think about it is what percent of your
total calories you're getting from added
sugars and among youth it's about 16
which is pretty high and in fact in the
dietary guidelines that you've also
referred to
the kind of range of for added sugars
and fats is five to fifteen percent and
we're seeing in youth that the added
sugars alone is 16
but what this what this graph shows is
that the majority of added sugars are
actually from food and that would be
from grain-based desserts and things
like that
however if you look at individual items
it's actually sugar drinks or sugar
sweetened beverages that provide the
greatest
amount of added sugars alison aubry our
caller also talked about her uh aversion
to wheat she's gone gluten free wheat
free what are you reporting on that
these days um what i've reported
recently on this issue is that
there has been a bit of a change
mainstream medicine has sort of
acknowledged this category of people uh
for whom we might refer to as wheaton
and wheat intolerant um so as the caller
suggested um she was tested for celiac
and tested positive
negative does not have celiac disease
but did better when she took weed out of
her diet and
she's certainly not alone a lot of other
people are reporting this and um and
there is more of a recognition for
instance the last week i did about this
issue i talked to a gastroenterologist
at harvard who who said you know 10
years ago we would have said
not so sure this is related to wheat now
there is much more sort of agreement
among gastroenterologists that for some
people uh wheat intolerance or wheat
sensitivity if if you will uh is real
she also talked about as a mother
creating her baby food for her for her
kids and making them baby food from
scratch i wish i had time to do that
right
if you have time to do that more power
to you that's great allison aubry
reports for npr national public radio
she's a food and health correspondent
you can hear her stories on radio
stations across the country and also
find them online at npr.org she
contributes to the salt npr's food
eating and health blog also npr has a
blog shots which reports on health
issues our other guest is cynthia ogden
she's a nutritional epidemiologist at
the cdc national center for health
statistics and she oversees the analysis
group within the national health and
nutrition examination survey what does
that mean synthia ogden
well epidemiology is really
the study of health on the population
level and it's a really great applied
mathematics it's statistics but i'm
really looking at the relationships
between behaviors for example
and disease and
it's
um uh the the group that we
we i'm involved in is a group of a
variety of different epidemiologists i
work on issues related to nutrition and
obesity primarily but other people in
the group look at other kinds of health
issues
using the same survey data our next
caller is in nashville brandt joins us
now hi
yes thank you for c-span uh please um
i'm no uh
i'm not a statistician but doesn't the
numbers seem to be greater than polio is
it why is there no policy statement that
this is a national emergency or a crisis
and and why can't we mobilize like a
march of dimes towards obesity
a couple other questions
mayor bloomberg's
statement it's not about adults it's the
children they can't defend themselves
much like tobacco or alcohol the
underlying issue is addiction we're a
nation of addicts
and it needs to be addressed
two suggestions
nationalize agriculture there are more
people with top secret security
clearance than there are farmers
something like the kibbutz in israel a
volunteer six months 10 months 12 months
reintroduce home economics and civics
the other one is uh you know
card carrying
for children protect the children card
caring for children i don't quite get
that one brand um it
may i see your id if you want your sugar
beverage may i see your id please okay
well brent bringing up his concerns
about obesity as an epidemic
and the health concerns do we officially
call it an epidemic right now cynthia
ogden and what do the numbers show us
well our numbers do show that um more
than a third of adults are obese and 17
of children and that we've seen this
large increase that i i've mentioned
before
um
you know that sometimes people do call
it an epidemic and and um but epidemio
epidemics are often related to
infectious diseases so it's not always
called that but but it is sometimes
called that allison aubry
um i would say one of the things you
touched on was you know
children other vulnerable ones i there
is quite a bit of focus on children um
in the in the public health realm i mean
if you if you look at for instance
regulations from the us department of
agriculture on new school lunches as
well as what schools are allowed to
serve and their competitive foods
programs these are things that children
might be getting
at the end of the meal or from vending
machines or just being served in the
school
you'll see that you know several years
back the state of california was an
early player and that they greatly
limited kids access to
sugar sweetened beverages and snacks
time they were at school
and researchers at the university of
illinois recently published a study and
found the result of that is that kids
are eating about 100
school kids in california are eating
about 160 calories less than kids in
other states where they don't limit
these kinds of sugary
junky things in school and so you know
you raise a good point that the children
are the vulnerable ones and i think that
a lot of the focus on energy energy
right now is on on teaching kids about
nutrition and limiting their access lynn
is in bishop california hi lynn
good morning good morning
yes that's uh my biggest concern too is
um the children that are growing up
because of um
you know they're just gonna add to
our already unhealthy nation
and i've been involved in health and
fitness for over 30 years and
you know for some reason you have the
information out there everybody knows
what they should be doing what they
should be eating what they shouldn't be
eating and it just comes down to
behavior and personal choice
and i'm not really sure
i would like to be able to to change
that more i'm not really sure how to go
about it
but
i know the millions of dollars that flow
into the cdc for
their research in the national
institutes of health and the world
health organization studying all of
these
yet the you know we see the people with
the ebt cards they can go into a liquor
store and buy a candy and a soda with
that or they can go into
you know caesar's pizza and buy greasy
pizzas and you know people don't cook
anymore all right lynn let's leave it
there uh cynthia ogden any thoughts
um well i think that that when you think
about obesity it's a very complex
problem and it is related to what you
eat and how physically active you are
but there are a lot of other
contributing factors as well and and um
thinking about
the changes that that have occurred
related to snacking as you brought up
eating out more often we're eating out
more than we used to eat and we're
spending more of our food dollars on
restaurants and fast foods and things
like that our food portion sizes have
increased what we've eaten has changed
beverages as you've mentioned milk has
decreased and sugar sweetened beverages
has increased we've seen a lot of these
changes
but it's a very complex problem related
to obesity related to both the intake
and and how much you expend and how
physically active you are which we're
not talking about today laura writes in
on twitter and says it's a sad state of
affairs when the government needs a
campaign to tell kids to go out and play
so allison aubry can you explain a
little bit about what's happening at the
federal level and then also what the
first lady is doing and how official
that is
um so the first lady through the let's
move um uh
through her let's move campaign has done
a variety of different things
one of the ways is to you know really
bring a spotlight to the kinds of things
that the kinds of programs that the usda
has and and
under to some extent these programs have
been sort of beefed up under the obama
administration for instance you know
schools can apply for grants to serve
apples at lunchtime for instance and and
all kinds of ways that schools can use
grant programs to try to nudge kids
towards healthier choices
at the same time the uh the first lady
is the honorary chair of the partnership
for healthier america and it's through
this relationship where um you can only
do so much in schools the first lady has
made it clear she thinks it's important
that corporate america steps out so
through the partnership for healthier
america they they've cut deals with uh
darden restaurants so olive garden and
red lobster um walmart hyatt hotels
where the idea is that they the idea is
that they're trying to make the healthy
choice the easy choice so instead of
serving you know a coca-cola with a
kid's meal at a at a restaurant or at a
hotel you serve milk with that becomes
the standard for kids meals little
initiatives like this there's no one
magic bullet here as cynthia said it's
really complicated so there's just
hundreds
of little things happening and if you
look at them as a whole we might might
start to see
you know
more of a leveling out of obesity levels
alison aubry food and health
correspondent for national public radio
thanks for joining us this morning thank
you and cynthia ogden nutritional
epidemiologist at the cdc national
center for health statistics thanks to
you as well welcome that's all for
washington journal this morning thank
you for joining us we'll be back
tomorrow morning at seven o'clock
eastern time we now take you to the
export import bank and you'll see eddie
hartenstein is the publisher of the la
times gentlemen thanks for being on book
tv
[Music]
and our live coverage from the la times
festival of books continues from the
campus of the university of southern
california and now another opportunity
for you to call in and interact with an
author and this is the pulitzer prize
winning michael moss and his new book
salt sugar fat
how the food giants hooked us mr moss
what happened in minneapolis in april of
1999. you know i start the book with
that meeting because it's so informative
of the industry's attitude and
strategies
1999 the obesity epidemic was just
beginning to emerge and raise concern
not only among consumer activists and
nutritionists but among people inside
the process food industry
they gathered together
for a very rare meeting ceos of some of
the top manufacturers in north america
who got together at the old minneapolis
headquarters the old pillsbury
headquarters in minneapolis
to talk about none other than this
emerging crisis really for the industry
and up in front of them got none other
than one of their own his name was
michael mudd he was a vice president of
craft he was armed with 114
slides and laid at the feet of these
ceos and presidents of these largest
food companies
responsibility for the not only the
obesity crisis but he cited the rising
cases of diabetes high blood pressure
heart disease he even linked their foods
with several
cancers and he pleaded with them to
collectively start doing something on
behalf of consumers because michael mudd
knew
that the competition
inside the food industry and you know
it's funny because you walk into the
grocery store and it seems so tranquil
and soft music playing doing everything
they can to encourage you to shop and
buy but behind the scenes the food
industry is intensely comp competitive
and he understood that the only way to
sort of move the industry budge them
toward a healthier profile of their
products would be to get them
collectively to do something from his
vantage point the meeting was an utter
failure the ceos reacted defensively
they said look we're already offering
people choices we have low fat this low
sugar fat that if they really want that
they can buy those alternative products
we are beholden to both the consumers
and our own shareholders they left the
meeting basically going back to what
they've been doing and continue to do
which is having a deep reliance on salt
sugar and fat
so what are processed foods how do you
define them you know processed foods and
i'm mostly looking at what people like
to call ultra processed foods because
look even a baby carrot can be defined
as a processed food because it doesn't
grow that way in the ground it's a
regular carrot that gets shaved into the
the baby form but typically i mean for
my sense processed foods are those
things that take sort of natural
ingredients and highly refine them
highly process them and the formulas two
of the products that i'm writing about
in the book are incredibly dependent on
salt sugar fat and it's not it's not a
mystery you can pick up the label and
you can see
thanks to some government regulation
that we have and labeling requirements
you can see the amounts of salt sugar
fat in these items and it's rather
extraordinary across the board of the
grocery store just how reliant the
industry is on these three ingredients
not just for flavor but for convenience
because they can act as preservatives
and also for low cost because they they
can help the industry avoid using more
costly ingredients like fresh herbs and
spices
so
michael moss what do you mean when you
talk about mouth feel and bliss point
you know i'm trained as an investigative
reporter to follow the money and in the
processed food industry i had a trillion
dollars worth of monies to follow and
explore
and there was certainly ample amounts of
that i was lucky enough to come across a
trove of internal documents that put me
at the table
as these largest companies are planning
plotting formulating their way to
creating new products but i have to say
the most fun for me was hearing the
language that they use in talking about
their own foods i mean these are not
english majors these are scientists and
marketers and ceos and mouthfeel is the
term that they use to describe
the warm gooey sensation when you bite
into a toasted cheese sandwich it's
actually not one of the basic fat it's
not one of the basic tastes
that aristotle wrote about many many
many years ago
fat is a sensation that's picked up by a
nerve ending that reaches to the top of
your mouth when you bite into a fatty
substance like cheese it sends a signal
just like salt and sugar to the pleasure
center of your brain but they describe
the fatty sensation taste as mouth feel
and boy is it an allure it's a powerful
ingredient for them in part because of
its allure as sugar and salt
you write the blood gets especially
besieged when processed food is ingested
flooding the system with its heavy loads
of salt sugar and fat
but where the links between eating and
drugs get really interesting is in the
brain
there narcotics and food especially food
that is high in salt sugar and fat
act much alike once ingested they race
along the same pathways using the same
neurological circuitry to reach the
brain's pleasure zones those areas that
reward us with enjoyable feelings for
doing the right thing by our bodies
boy there is there is no word the
processed food industry hates more than
the a word addiction and i do try to use
it sparingly because
they can rather convincingly argue that
there are some differences between food
cravings and narcotic cravings certain
technical thresholds however when they
talk about the allure of their foods
again their language can be so revealing
they use words like craveable snackable
moreishness
and i was rather skeptical about about
even using the term addiction at all
when it comes to food until i spent time
with nora volkow the head of the
national institute on drug abuse outside
of washington
she is a neuroscientist who has studied
how the brain reacts
both to narcotics and the most highly
palatable the sweetest the fattest foods
and she's found that for many of us
the fattest sweetest foods will will
create compulsive pat in patterns rather
of compulsive intake much along the
lines of some narcotics and she even
goes further to empathize with people
who have food cravings and can't control
them because it's harder to it's harder
to deal with those than narcotics
because you just can't go
cold turkey on food we are bombarded you
know every waking moment of our lives
with advertising marketing
people eating food and drinking as
they're walking down the street so it's
really really difficult for many of us
to deal with food cravings
in your book for obvious reasons the
word addiction is a particularly touchy
subject among food manufacturers they
prefer saying a product is cravable
likable snackable are almost anything
other than saying it is addictive for
them the term addiction conjures images
of strung out junkies who hold up
7-elevens at gunpoint for the money they
need for another fix addiction also
raises barbed legal issues that industry
is loathe to engage is there
you talk about the fact that
perhaps the food industry is scared of a
tobacco-like settlement when it comes to
processed foods i think increasingly
today they're even more scared i'm told
by people inside the industry and people
that in washington as well who've been
looking at the looming possibility
of the attorneys who went after big
tobacco going after big food and look
there are some differences between the
two as there are with narcotics but i
think especially the soda industry is
really worried about litigation and the
food industry is worried about what
might happen to the soda industry in
that same litigation because look i mean
there's a number associated with obesity
and it's 300 billion dollars that's the
estimate for how much
obesity is costing us in north america
every year from added medical expenses
and lost productivity and the last time
i heard a number like that was in the
90s when the state's attorney's general
sued big tobacco over their uh the
medical expenses they were incurring
over over treating people who were
sickened by tobacco and that was a much
smaller number back then so i i think
the industry is rightly concerned about
litigation perhaps even along those same
lines we're going to put the numbers up
on the screen if you'd like to
participate in a conversation with
michael moss of the new york times salt
sugar fat is the name of his most recent
book 202 is area code
585-3885 if you live in the east and
central time zones
585-3886 for those of you in the
mountain and pacific time zones if you
can't get through on the phone lines you
can send us a tweet twitter.com booktv
is our twitter address and you can make
a comment as well on facebook
facebook.com
booktv now michael moss you spend quite
a bit of time in your book talking about
lunchables what are lunchables and why
do you use that as an example lunchable
is a tv dinner type tray
um that's marketed to children on one
level it was the solution to a problem
at oscar meyer the meat company back in
the 80s people were eating less red meat
being concerned about saturated fat
which is the type of fat that's
associated with heart disease if you get
too much of it and salt people began
eating less red meat lunchables was
worried about revenue
jobs it assigned some of its smartest
marketing people to
figure out a way to repackage its
products um and i spent time with bob
drane a genius marketing official who
worked for oscar mayer and then craft
when oscar meyer emerged and he walked
me through the incredible effort they
put into coming up with the a product
that would sell red meat and not put
people off like the packaged bologna
that they were selling and after months
and months of research and study his
team came up with the lunchables this
little tray and in the original version
it was a little you know slices of ham
or bologna
a little bit of cheese crackers because
they couldn't use bread they needed
something that would stay on the shelf
he did make an effort to make it more
nutritionally balanced by adding fresh
carrots and apple slices and immediately
realized they would not last more than a
week much less the months that the
lunchables needs to stay either in the
either in the warehouse or the or the
supermarket waiting for someone to buy
it
and after i mean it became a huge hit
the first year it exceeded i think it
hit
218 million dollars in sales it was
astounding nobody had expected it to
take off like that they came up with
other lunchables including
pizza lunchables hamburger lunchables
hot dog lunchables all eaten cold by
kids and when they stopped to think
about they realized that it wasn't the
food that the kids were attracted to it
was the badge value the status symbol of
bringing this cute adorable lunchables
to the lunchroom opening it up and all
your friends gathering around and seeing
you
put it together and and eat it so they
and they came up with this incredible
marketing slogan hitting on that which
is for kids all day you got to do what
they say but lunchtime is all yours the
marketing power as much as using salt
sugar fat as ingredients is is is
phenomenal in the industry did they
super size the salt sugar fat oh my gosh
so one of the items that they came up
with was the maxed out lunchables
which had so much salt sugar fat that
for children especially it was basically
maxing out their daily recommended loads
for many of those things i mean hats off
to craft for recently
dialing back the nutritional loads of
the lunchables and making them healthier
but one thing to remember about the
lunchables is that
they introduced fast food into the
grocery store which really is a
phenomenon that nutritionists now are
sort of very worried about because even
to this day when we walk into the
grocery store i think we're inherently
thinking look okay there's soda there
and there's chips and candy and crackers
but i'm basically going in there to get
food that's going to make me healthy and
strong and to have the
grocery manufacturers start mimicking
fast food and introducing it into the
grocery store
was
is something of a grave concern to to
nutritionists all right before we go to
calls a couple of examples here that we
have from the crew
here at book tv and for myself little
healthy snacks to get get across country
et cetera et cetera
and uh
here's two to start this is a protein
bar okay what could possibly be wrong
with this well we'd have to turn to the
back and look at the fine print and this
is certainly one of the phenoms that you
see in the industry protein is a big
buzzword so now you'll see that on the
front and in the back when you're
reading the you're reading the fine
print there saturated fat 3.5 grams 18
18
daily uh allowance it's actually a low
ball figure it's actually if you follow
the usda guidelines that 3.5
grams is actually more than 18 of your
daily especially for children so what
should we be looking for here
high maltose corn syrup you know it's
sweeteners and i actually found out from
top nutritionist that sugar
is sugar is sugar i know that's
disappointing for people like to blame
high corn for
high
high fructose corn syrup um and there is
certainly an issue of how it helped
perpetuate the soda uh consumption in
this country but basically that's
another type of sugar that you have to
be concerned about not to eat too much
sodium 170 milligrams that's a hefty
amount the usda recommendation is that
we move to eating no more than 1500
milligrams of sodium a day so you know
with that you're looking upwards of uh
of a sixth of the whole daily allotment
fruit snacks these are fat free gluten
free and no preservatives yes again
fruit is one of those healthy buzz words
that the industry is putting on items
throughout the grocery store especially
to
pull you in um you know as presenting
these to kids who don't like fresh fruit
but what have we got for sugar on that
uh sugar sugar's 11 grams in this little
pack so that's quite a bit that's more
than two um two tablespoons and that
teaspoons and that's um that's
significant
now these were somebody else's but these
are some chips
you know one of the fascinating things
about chips
and and i i i really took this to heart
because i love potato chips and and
as and i couldn't figure out why they
really induce such incredible cravings
in people and we all know that they're
salty and the salt is right there on the
surface of the chips providing what the
industry calls the flavor burst your
saliva comes into contact with it first
races to the pleasure center of the
brain which sends those signals hey
that's great let's eat more of that
we know they're soaked with fat um and
that also gives the pleasurable feeling
that they call the mouth feel also
raises to the brain but what i didn't
know is that chips are also loaded with
sugar and it's in the potato starch
itself which begins converting to sugar
the instant it hits your tongue so
you've got the holy trinity there for
the processed food industry of salt
sugar fat all interacting not just to
make you like the product but to make
you want more and more and one last
thing about chips the noise
they did research showing that the more
noise the chip makes when you bite into
it the more you're gonna want the more
you're gonna eat and so that's why that
crunch
is essential to sales now a lot of
athletes drink this
so it's good for you right well you know
look all of this stuff salt sugar fat
you know my diet at home you can be
largely looking at it as salt sugar fat
although we're doing our best to eat
more of what everyone says to eat more
which is you know fresh fruits and
vegetables it's a matter of degree and
the interesting thing about the power
aids the sports drinks the chocolate
milk the ice the sweetened iced tea is
that while our soda consumption has
declined over the past decade our
consumption of these alternative
products that don't immediately signal
to us hey wait a minute this is loaded
with sugar too has increased almost
taking up the slack of the soda so
that's another example of something to
be wary of that's pitched as a healthy
as a healthy food or drink but you've
really got to look at the nutritional
label to figure out just how much sugar
is really in there salt sugar fat here's
the name of the book michael moss is the
author first call comes from derek in
emporia virginia derek you're on book tv
oh good afternoon
please go ahead sir oh my question is
um i've noticed that a lot of processed
foods and uh basically foods are
terrible for you
um they definitely
affect inner city kids a lot more
because it's cheaper for
families and industries to buy food of
that nature
and i was wondering
and fresh foods are so expensive what is
being done is there a sense of urgency
out there to really push the fact that
these foods are terrible for you in
these neighborhoods where they may not
have that knowledge of information
and what is being done to maybe
somewhere lower the price of fresh
fruits so that people in these
neighborhoods could be able to afford to
buy this and be healthier
thank you derek
yeah derek you make a really really good
point and i spent time in a rather poor
neighborhood of northern north
philadelphia to sort of understand that
too people talk about food deserts where
people have very limited access to full
grocery stores where they can buy fruits
and vegetables there it's really more of
a food swamp because they're surrounded
by corner stores that sell almost
nothing but salt sugar fat soda
snack cakes chips and kids can run in
there for a dollar and come out with 350
empty calories that they're often eat on
the way to school
i happen to know that the white house is
looking at ways to increase or rather
lower the cost make them more affordable
lower the cost of fruits and vegetables
and it's a really difficult undertaking
that they're still grappling with but
that's one thing that they're looking at
in order to lay lay
in order to level the playing field of
the grocery store because when you walk
in as you point out the highly processed
foods are more affordable so even if you
want to do the right thing by yourself
and your family and eat more fruits and
vegetables you're going to pay for it
through the pocketbook and yes i think
people are looking at strategies to try
to try to level that out
mike tweets in to you mr moss is the
food industry pushing bad food on us or
being compelled by popular tastes to
make food taste a certain way it's a bit
of a chicken and egg thing and i should
point out that i don't view the
processed food industry as this evil
empire that intentionally set out to
make us obese or otherwise ill
they are doing what companies do which
is make more money by selling more
product and i think that they would be
happy selling healthy nutritional
products if they could do so at sort of
the same low prices and to satisfy wall
street and that's one of the issues
that's looming on them is that they're
under severe pressure from wall street
to keep profits up i mean that said
they have shaped our pallets our liking
for salt sugar fat in really incredible
ways and i'm struck especially by sugar
sugar used to be something you'd find in
the grocery store in the ice cream aisle
candy aisle cookies now you see so many
products in the store that are sweet
bread
pasta sauce can have as much sugar in a
tiny little serving the equivalent of a
couple of oreo cookies yogurt low-fat
yogurt can have as much sugar as ice
cream and we've seen sweetness migrate
across the store as the company's target
our liking we are hardwired for sugar
our bliss points as they call it for
sugar and they're especially targeting
kids one scientist explained to me um
how they are exploiting the biology of
the child by by making children expect
sweetness in almost everything they now
eat and their parents buy in the store
and i think that's the issue
have they changed the formula for
ketchup i saw
i read a ketchup bottle last night right
and i saw high fructose corn syrup is
one of the main ingredients yeah yeah i
mean i i'm not sure the year when they
started adding sugar but it's certainly
hugely sweet these days and as one of
the food scientists explained to me it
allows them to actually avoid using more
tomatoes if the sugar replaces tomatoes
and is left less expensive
by adding sugar to tomato products pasta
sauces ketchup etc they can also use
tomatoes that are not naturally as sweet
and wholesome
as some tomatoes are and that cost less
so typically that is a move to reduce
the cost of the product and so much of
the processed food industry is driven by
cost
they call it the least cost formulation
and that's what they're looking for in
their manipulation and their and their
their formula strategies and formulation
rob abilene texas we're talking with
michael moss the author of this book
salt sugar fat please go ahead
yes uh how do you balance our freedom of
choice in america you know the great
experiment can man rule over himself
with
those who think they know best for us
like bloomberg is he right by saying
i basically know better than you because
you are addicted with this mouth feel
this flavor burst do you do you um have
do you think the government should step
in
i'm i'm i'm empathetic with people who
criticize bloomberg and call him the
nanny we heard that decades ago when
washington tried to
regulate um sugar and salt as as well
but you but i think we have to remember
that the playing field is not level in
the absence of government intervention
what we have are incredibly big
incredibly smart companies spending tens
of millions of dollars every year not
just to get us to like their products
but to get us to want more and more and
so much of that targeting is aimed at
children and these are children who no
longer get home economics in school
girls and boys used to be taught how to
shop how to cook how to be nutritionally
aware and that fell by the wayside and
so kids are exposed to advertising to
marketing to corner stores not knowing
any better and i think that's i mean
that's the picture i think you have to
grapple with when you're weighing um
sort of you know independence and and
govern and big government intervention
do you eat any processed foods today oh
my gosh look i mean i have two boys will
is eight aaron is 13. my wife eve works
outside of the home i mean not a week
goes by when we come home and have to
and and have to go in the freezer and
pull out something because it's 7 p.m
and we haven't thought about what we're
having for dinner um you know that said
we're trying and so with our boys for
example
i make them pancakes in the morning and
i slip in whole wheat flour in the
pancakes and they don't notice it i also
have a bag of frozen blueberries in the
freezer because they're much cheaper
actually than fresh blueberries and i
slipped those into their pancakes or
waffles as well eve the other day said
to them interestingly hey guys why do we
limit our cold cereal consumption to
brands with five grams of sugar or less
and now when we go shopping with them
it's a bit of a hunt they'll look in the
in the cereal aisle and they pull the
boxes off the label and look at the fine
print
and they'll find brands that in fact
have five grams or less they're there
you can find healthy products in the
grocery store if you look for them with
cereal typically they have to look low
near the ground or i have to reach high
up on the top shelf
because the industry strategically
places the most sugary brands at eye
level so you gravitate to those when you
walk down that aisle but another really
interesting thing happens too is that
we find that when we engage our kids in
the discussion about nutrition just on a
very elemental level level and not you
know you can't eat this you can't eat
that but let's try to limit this for
these reasons
i find that they're really smart and
they get it and so when they bring those
cheerios home that have just one gram of
sugar or special k or total they've been
eating that lately they actually like it
better than they would otherwise i mean
hey if they had their druthers they
would probably pull the tricks off the
shelf and go the froot loops and go for
that
but again education of the children i
think is totally key uh moving forward
next call from michael moss comes from
fred in tacoma park maryland hi fred hi
i just wanted to
say that i got stopped eating flour and
sugar in 1990
and lost 67.5 pounds
i weigh in measure
but when i go to the store and we shop
in supermarkets we read the labels we
avoid anything with ose glucose sucrose
fructose
and
you know there's a
it's doable it's not hard we're not
suffering we eat very well
thank you
thank you yeah no that's good that's
good that's good to hear the one thing i
one thing that i do hear from
nutritionists that they caution people
is is to
try to avoid sort of focus on one of
these elements salt sugar fat too much
because it really is about a balanced
diet and and on and in some ways that
sometimes plays into the hands of the
processed food industry the 80s were
especially big for concerns about sugar
and so they would come up with low sugar
products that would still be loaded with
fats and salt and the 90s were sort of
more about trans fats and they got rid
of trans fats and replace them with
saturated fats which are a concern now
and again low fat products can be super
high in sugar and sodium and now kind of
one of the biggest concerns is about
salt too
i did some research looking at efforts
by other countries to cut back on sodium
and places like britain and finland have
really dramatically cut back on their
sodium levels but interestingly the
obesity rates are still starting to
climb are still climbing in those
countries because those snacks that are
lower in salt are still high in sugar
and fat so you do really have to be
careful as as a consumer to to to
understand the big picture of what
you're getting right you write in salt
sugar fat that if something may say low
fat they might the
food manufacturer may bump up the sugar
content bottom line they have to keep
their they feel they have to keep their
products tasting utterly irresistibly
tasty as before
no matter how they might fiddle with the
formula that is the bottom line for the
industry and so yes on occasion they
will bump up some of the other two
elements if they reduce one of them
michael moss how strong is or tell us
about the lobby the
processed food industry you know there
were efforts back in the late 70s 80s to
go after the marketing of sugary
products to children especially the old
the federal trade commission was
severely concerned about the inability
of kids to distinguish between
advertising and reality and so huge a
percentage of the ads they were getting
and still are to some extent on saturday
morning were for highly processed foods
high in sugar especially and they came
up with a proposal to try to limit that
advertising it was going along fine and
the lobby of the food industry along
with marketing industry just put the
kibosh on that it's an incredible power
incredibly powerful force that people
are going to have to deal with now as
consumers are becoming more concerned
about what we're putting in our bodies
you can't understand the ability of the
processed food energy to sort of hold on
to
the marketing position that it has and
our next call comes from walter in
washington north carolina hi walter hi
this is about uh
recently the british and europeans found
out they've been eating horse meat
served by these processed food companies
i was wondering could that happen here
or is it happening here or uh
those sort of yeah
follow up with that please
i think it absolutely could before i was
writing about salt sugar fat i was
actually writing about
pathogens and food i started with an
outbreak of salmonella and peanuts being
processed down in southern georgia on
the alabama border they had an outbreak
of deadly salmonella in
2008 and i began looking at that and the
issue was that the food industry losing
control over its vendors because over
the following weeks and weeks the
largest food manufacturers were
scrambling to figure out if they even
used any of these peanuts in their
products and then i moved to e coli
outbreaks in hamburger and the same
issue came up with that so i think to
some extent the issue with the horse
meat scandal and pathogens is that the
food industry has grown so global and so
sensitive to pricing that many of these
larger companies are buying ingredients
from hundreds and hundreds of vendors
around the world and it's very difficult
for them to monitor
and to control the safety of those
ingredients i shifted to salt sugar fat
because the source said to me hey
michael you know as tragic as some of
these outbreaks are you know there is
this other looming health crisis afoot
obesity diabetes etc
over which the industry has total
control absolute control and which
they're intentionally adding to products
so they're two separate issues of the
same trillion dollar processed food
industry michael moss eli anderson
tweets in soda is such a popular
american drink but do you believe it's
as dangerous to the human body as a
dangerous drug as a dangerous drug i
think again if you're looking at at
patterns of compulsive intake for some
people they're going to find it really
hard to resist um drinking too much soda
and again it's a matter of degree i
think the other thing that interesting
to know about soda it's especially
coca-cola is so perfectly blended the
industry calls it um specific satiety um
and the um and they have figured out by
blending the ingredients in um an item
like coke so that you don't um remember
any single ingredient after you drink it
that will actually encourage you then to
sort of come back to it hours later um
it's a really really interesting concept
that the food industry uses both in food
and uh and drink
next call for you comes from daryl in
marina marana arizona hi daryl
hello suburb of tucson
uh
this is a little also beyond the three
topics of your current book maybe you
would write a book about
what i'm bringing up uh if you haven't
done so already and that's the recent
story if you would just share it with
the audience about bromulated vegetable
oil
and the young i think 15 year old girl
who got on the internet and come get
thousands of people to complain to the
makers of gatorade why is it in your
gatorade but it's banned in europe and
supposedly gatorade took it out of their
gatorade product but it is still and i
know this for a fact it is still in
their mountain dew
you know these companies are like big
aircraft carriers it really does take
them time to turn sometimes and
especially when they're changing up the
ingredients in their formulas i mean i
think that's a good example
of of consumers becoming more concerned
what they're putting in their bodies and
becoming kind of like it was for me in
researching and writing this book
getting inside a detective story and one
of the one of the fascinating things
about processed food is that you can go
into the grocery store pick up the box
or the bottle or the container and look
at the fine print and learn so much
about that product not just the salt
sugar fat but other additives and do
your own detective work and i think
that's a real empowering thing for
people i'm actually hoping that the book
is
not just a wake-up call for the industry
but but is empowering for us as
consumers because when you know
everything that the industry is throwing
at you whether it's a salt sugar fat or
other additives that that i find that's
really empowering as a consumer and it
helps you it helps you deal because look
ultimately we're the ones who decide
what to eat and and how much to eat and
what to buy and that that i think is a
real position of power
well the last two ingredients on on
gatorade are glycerol ester of rosin
and brominated vegetable i like the
caller mentioned so what's still in
there what does it mean brominated um
you know i don't actually know because i
didn't focus there are some 5
000 different additives in foods and
i've looked at a few of them but by no
means have had time yet to sort of look
at all of them it's an incredible array
and one of the stunning things about it
too is that the fda which is there to
regulate foods is not even aware of many
of these additives so it's it's a
serious issue of concern to people
michael moss kt reader sends in a tweet
there has been a rise in natural or
healthy processed foods how do their
salt sugar fat levels compare well
organics is an issue that's really
interesting um because an organic
product does not necessarily mean
it's lower or healthier in salt sugar
fat and or calories organic
you know refers to and hopefully it's
lower than pesticides because that's the
aim of the
of the organic level and the whole
growing of organics um one interesting
thing that i find though besides looking
at the
the fine print on containers boxes and
bottles
i really like to start with the front of
the package because that's where the
touting is that's where you'll see the
words all natural or added calcium or
with this vitamin or that vitamin or low
fat and it's really until and that i
often see that as a signal to
immediately
look for you know turn the package
around and look at the fine print
because you know that's where you know
that's where the information is that
they're not touting to you as uh as an
allure to buy the product
next call for michael moss comes from
george in wilmington delaware george
you're on book tv please go ahead hi uh
i can see where salt sugar and fat and
of course processed flour are bad for
you
and
recommending more fruits and vegetables
as an alternative i'm just wondering you
know with pesticides and herbicides are
we going from one bad thing to another
bad thing
you know that's a really good point um
to to be uh concerned about and again
the fda is there to
regulate the amount of pesticides and
herbicides um the i empathize with
people you know who don't have the the
financial wherewithal to buy organics i
don't think you need to buy organics to
be healthy generally and i think at this
point we have to be so you know we are
have to be somewhat dependent on the fda
to set you know tolerance limits for
pesticides herbicides so that if people
move more to fruits and vegetables they
don't get too much and that's a that's a
real issue to to look at mary mcgregor
who's watching us
obesity uh this is a tweet obesity on
full display behind you
address why americans are not interested
in even discussing discussing this issue
especially parents i actually think that
that america's is becoming more
concerned about what we put in our
bodies and more concerned about obesity
and diabetes and are talking more about
it it's really difficult for people to
break their own sort of eating habits um
and and to deal with that but i actually
find that the the conversation is
increasing and hats off to michelle
obama for
raising the the national conversation
about obesity and health and nutrition
on the one side on the other hand too
these products are so compelling i like
to call them the foods we hate to love
because you know it's it's hard to talk
about something that you love to eat in
negative and negative times michael moss
what was the reception from the food
companies when you approached them about
salt sugar fat i think that they were
actually
i mean i was surprised by how willing
they were to talk to me and i started
off with a trove of internal documents
which helped tremendously
these thousands and thousands of pages
put me at the table as the largest
companies were plotting and planning and
formulating their way to creating new
products those documents enabled me to
convince their top scientists marketing
officials ceos in some cases to talk to
me and reveal even more secrets and so
and i was really surprised by how many
companies have a cabal of insiders who
are generally genuinely concerned about
obesity and health issues associated
with their products um you know that
said the industries themselves when when
you know when their employees are inside
the game and a former president of
coca-cola expressed that to me the best
when you're inside
you are living you know competition with
your competitors and it's really hard to
see the big picture until you step out
and in going around the country and
talking about this book now i've been
approached by former industry officials
who've come up to me and said that
exactly michael look when i worked for
the company i just couldn't see what
you're talking about but now i can't
salt sugar fat is the name of the book
michael moss is the author and benny is
the caller from phoenix hi benny
hey guys how's it going going this
afternoon
hey uh listen michael uh
i i use the artificial sweetener to cut
down drastically on my sugar intake i
don't have a weight problem but i would
be interested to know what you have to
say about how artificial sweeteners may
impact the
consumption of
foods that are otherwise maybe loaded
with
salt and fat
you know it's where they might
psychologically or physiologically tend
to make people eat more of those foods
thank you benny i've heard that same
question raised by nutrition scientists
benny and unfortunately the studies have
not been done yet on that the other
interesting about diet soda is that for
you know for some people
it just doesn't work to help them reduce
or control weight and there's some
thinking that diet sodas can act almost
you know people people might view it
wrongly as like a prophylactic that will
that will you know inoculate them
against calories so you have a diet soda
one moment and then go back to eating
you know a sugary candy or or cookies or
a you know 800 calorie muffin the next
moment so i think that's one thing that
to realize about diet soda is changing
one element of your diet without looking
at everything else isn't going to be the
silver bullet that some people might
think it is but yes i know that there
are food scientists who are itching to
do um studies looking at that question
will well drinking a diet so an
artificially sweetened drink then compel
you to look for sweetness in solid foods
that might be sweetened with real sugar
and so you're gonna you're going to get
more calories that way just a few
minutes left with our guest jeff is in
summit new jersey jeff you're on book tv
uh yes hello
uh yeah i would just like to comment
that
what you really are doing there is to
talk about the symptom rather than the
cause
the principal
cause of this obesity epidemic that
we're facing is because of a
the collapse that we've seen in tap
water consumption
from about 75 to 80 gallons in 1960
to just 14 or 15 gallons today
and the reason for that is is because of
a
100
shift
from a refillable system for beverages
and milk
to a nut to 100 percent non-refillable
system for beverages and milk
that is what has uh
collapsed tap water consumption
and dramatically increased
consumption and other packaged liquids
if we went back to a refillable system
for beverages and milk
you would not see anywhere near
the consumption of soda
soda particularly so that bottled water
would be non-existent
all bottled water thank you
all right
that's a really interesting perspective
i actually had not heard that before in
terms of looking at all of the causes of
obesity the obesity crisis started in
1980 one of the more fascinating ideas
that was presented to me by a weight
loss expert was that starting in the
early 80s almost overnight it became
acceptable to eat anything anywhere
anytime and that's kind of when you
started to see people eating and
drinking walking down the street or
bringing food into even business
meetings and i think that what that led
to was sort of a mindless eating where
you're going hand to mouth and you're
cutting the brain sort of natural breaks
on overeating out of the equation and i
think much of what i'm hoping this book
does is help move people back toward a
mindful eating as opposed to mindlessly
because that plays right into the snack
food industry and i suspect it also
played into soda consumption as well
last call comes from will in lincoln
delaware hi will thank you peter quick
question for you a historical question
michael and that is when you think about
folks that influenced you in your
investigatory writing the adele davises
of the 1960s the jethro clauses the
william duffy who wrote books like sugar
blues
what were their influences on your
interests
you know it's funny the biggest
influence on me as a reporter was a high
school teacher of mine i took her
journalism class
and she said something to me which was
just about i was i was in a pretty tough
high school and she said look michael i
think you have a knack for this frankly
it was one of the kindest things any of
my teachers said to me and so i started
i started into journalism first and i
eventually you know did investigative
journalism you know mostly as an
opportunity to really dig below the
surface of things and there's so many
other great investigative reporters
out there upton sinclair was a great
inspiration because he went after the
meat industry at the turn of the century
and helped create the safety inspection
system that we now have in this country
and yes you named a number of other
people i'm in awe of the ability of of
journalists and writers and people
really care about issues to really dig
into things i admire them all
one more tweet another one from kt
reader but it's a something you discuss
in your book michael moss
how many of the food industry execs
that you met actually consume their own
products
ah i was surprised to meet so many
people top scientists marketers ceos who
don't indulge in their products
i spend time with the former top
technical officer of craft especially
especially i should say when they run
into health troubles he used to jog to
control his weight when he blew out his
knee one day the first thing he did was
stop eating potato chips because he was
one of those people who couldn't stop at
just one tiny little serving and for him
the grocery store became a bit of a
minefield in avoiding those products
that he knew he might not be able to uh
to control
you you note in here that since 1970 we
have tripled
our cheese
intake and our sugar intake
on the average is 22 teaspoons a person
per day yeah and another it's like we're
up to 30 food with cheese we're up to 33
pounds of cheese
again part of why by researching writing
this book to me was like a detective
story back in the 60s we began drinking
less whole milk out of concern for
saturated fat calories that left the
dairy industry with a glut of whole milk
and milk fat that they extracted out to
make low-fat milk they started making
ice cream butter they made so much
cheese it began piling up the government
began buying tons of it until ronald
reagan came into office and said hey
enough of this this is dumb the cheese
is growing moldy but what congress then
did was created a system for the dairy
industry to raise tens of millions of
dollars every year to promote the
consumption of cheese and that's what's
been going on ever since
they're they're spending this marketing
power every year to get us eat more
cheese and not just cheese
that's you know on a sandwich or cheese
you eat as an hors d'oeuvre before
a meal this is cheese that's sold and
used as an additive to processed foods
as an allure for the mouthfeel to get
you to like the food more
salt sugar fat how the food giants
hooked us
michael moss is the author
thank you for being on book tv oh thanks
so much for
now the doctor who did the youtube video
sugared the bitter truth it connects
sugar obesity and food policy and went
viral with more than three and a half
million viewers dr robert lustig is a
pediatric endocrinologist at the
university of california san francisco
he spoke to law students earlier this
year for an hour 50 minutes
thank you thank you david
thank all of you for coming and it's
just wonderful first of all to be back
now at my alma mater
marcia cohen even gave me a decal to put
on my car so i'm
fully equipped and i really want to
acknowledge so many of my mentors during
this past year in the audience david and
pat davidson and marsha and several
other people here as well that uh have
done uh you know just a tremendous job
and i have to say that it was really a
absolutely thrilling year um i wouldn't
have given it up for the world the
homework was another story but
um today i want to talk to you about
what got me to law school in the first
place and hopefully
light a fire under all of you
in the way that i first felt this as i
started researching the topic
um
it's appropriate today that this
talk today be done on the day the 50th
anniversary of the march on washington
because um we're going to talk about a
different form of oppression one that's
even a little bit more pernicious
and i also have a dream and that dream
is that our food supply would confer
wellness not illness i have to take care
of obese kids and
we're losing the battle
and the problem is
we're going to continue to lose the
battle until we fix the food supply and
i'm going to try to explain to you
why that is
and what we can do about it during the
course of this lecture i hope it won't
be so hyperbolic as to get you all you
know sort of you know uh
you know uh shouting in the uh in the
aisles it's not quite a a revival but uh
there's gonna be a lot of science and
the science should influence the policy
the problem is the politics get in the
way
but that's where law comes in so i'm
with that
let's go ahead and start
so first of all i have no disclosures no
food industry concern is putting me up
to this i promise you
so
in
2011 just two
years ago the un secretary general
announced that non-communicable disease
that is
type 2 diabetes cardiovascular disease
cancer dementia was now a bigger problem
not just for the developed world but now
for the developing world than was
infectious disease including hiv this is
a paradigm shift as to how
medicine is going to be conducted from
here on in and where the resources have
to go the question is how do you deal
with this so they plan to target tobacco
alcohol
and
diet now tobacco alcohol that's easy and
we have paradigms that already work for
those we have 15 years of alcohol
control policy for instance
but what about diet are we going to
influence total calories well you know
we've been doing that for 30 years and
look where we are we can do that with
changing fat we did that for 30 years
and look where we are red meat
dairy if you believe esostein and
caldwell
carbohydrate what is the factor
within our diet we can't stop eating
something has to change but what is it
i think all of these are incorrect i'm
going to let will smith tell you what
the real answer to this story is
but
i guess i'll use some answers awesome
what you going chatty always say
sorry i can't talk right now i got some
secret cases on my own i'm working on i
need to turn you away from your video
game
all right i'm hanging out
the most destructive force in the
universe
sugar
[Laughter]
you know
if hollywood knows this why don't you
anyway
here's the problem um it's very clearly
delineated on this slide and this comes
from coca-cola's coming together youtube
video it's two-minute commercial where
they are going to tackle childhood
obesity and they say straight up beating
obesity will take action by all of us
based on one simple common sense fact
all calories count no matter where they
come from including coca-cola and
everything else with calories in other
words a calories a calorie and you can
get those calories from
carrots
or cheesecake
or coca-cola or anything else with a k
but the bottom line is it doesn't matter
where it comes from
calorie is a calorie well that's based
on common sense well i don't believe in
common sense i believe in data and the
data say something else entirely because
what the data say is that some calories
cause disease more than other calories
because different calories are
metabolized differently in the body
not every calorie is handled the same
way and that means that a calorie is not
a calorie
and that is what i've spent the last 16
years
figuring out and i'm not the only one
who's figured this out many other
investigators have figured this out and
this is now a wave of controversy
throughout the endocrine and the
nutritional literature and at meetings i
just debated the corn refiners
association just a week ago on exactly
this point
so the question is if a calorie is not a
calorie could there be calories that are
worse than others so of course we know
that there are certain uh environmental
toxicants that are certainly bad for you
as you know witness tobacco the question
is what about this stuff over here
is this possible could this be the
problem
so i'm going to be referring now to
two papers one one is actually a journal
a new york times magazine article
written by gary taubbs about our
research at ucsf and also our nature
comment last year where we actually
called for regulation
so in order to regulate an environmental
substance
society has
said that you have to fulfill four
criteria
unavoidability or ubiquity you can't get
away from it toxicity it has to be
dangerous abuse you can't stop using it
and finally externalities or negative
impact on society how does your use
affect me
those are the four and i have to show
you that sugar meets every single one of
those four in order to even be able to
stand up here and talk about it so let's
start with unavoidability
now we are all eating more no argument
275 calories more in teen boys over the
past 20 years no argument we are eating
more the question is what are we eating
more of
is it fat
you know we were told to go low fat
we're not eating more fat
we are actually eating the same amount
of fat as we were before
5 grams up 45 calories of those 275
calories of fat and if you look at the
secular trends and specific food intake
here are the fats
whole milk way down meat and cheese up
very slightly milk desserts up minimally
bottom line it's a wash
we are not eating more fat in fact as
our percent calories from fat have gone
from 40 to 30 percent because the ama
the aha and the usda remanded us to back
in the 1980s as we were to go low fat
our obesity and metabolic syndrome
prevalence has gone through the roof
no it's not fat what are we eating more
of we're eating more carbohydrate okay
228 calories 57 grams in teen boys
and here's the trend in carbohydrate
intake all up through the roof that's
what we're eating more of and of course
remember that was the bottom of the food
pyramid
and specifically what carbohydrate well
beverages for that matter 41 increase in
soft drinks 35 increase in fruit drinks
fruit aids etc
this slide sort of says it all okay
here is the original
uh bottle of coca-cola six and a half
ounces out of atlanta in 1915. if you
drank one of those every day for a year
assuming that the uh formula hasn't
changed and we don't know if the formula
has changed because only three people in
the world know the formula and they're
not allowed to ride the plane at the
same time
that would be worth eight pounds of fat
per year
now in 1955 after sugar stopped being
rationed after world war ii we got up to
10 ounces
13 pounds of fat per year now the cokes
were sold in vending machines
then the ever ubiquitous 12 ounce can at
16 pounds of fat per year
and here we have the current
ever present 20 ounce
coca-cola everybody know how many
servings you get out of that 20 ounces
supposed to be 2.58 ounce servings
anybody know anybody who gets 2.58 oz
servings out of that that's a whole
serving
so that's worth 26 pounds of fat per
year and then you have the 711 big k
thirst buster big gulp etc 44 ounces 57
pounds of fat per year if you did that
every day and my friend dr dan hale at
the university of texas san antonio
tells me that down there they got a
texas-sized big gulp 60 ounces of
coca-cola a snickers bar and a bag of
doritos all for 99 cents
so you'd say well qed that's the obesity
epidemic right there well you would be
only partially right so what is this
stuff well in america it's this stuff
high fructose corn syrup our current
annual consumption is 63 pounds per
person but there's a problem the problem
is
only the u.s canada and japan use it
there's very limited exposure in parts
of europe yet the rest of the world has
just as much of an obesity metabolic
syndrome epidemic as we do in fact
everybody is so fond of mexican coke
mexico has the highest increase in the
rate of obesity in the world today
and they don't have high fructose corn
syrup they have sucrose so here's high
fructose corn syrup up here one glucose
six membered ring
one fructose five-membered ring and they
are free they are not bound together but
here's sucrose one six-membered ring one
five-membered ring o glycosidic linkage
linking the two your enzyme in your
intestine called sucrase cleaves this in
about a nanosecond you absorb the two
moieties basically it's a wash they're
the same they are equivalent and all of
the studies pitting the two of them
against each other show that they are
equivalent they are equivalently bad
that's the problem
and that's why every other country has
the exact same problem as we do
here's what u.s sugar consumption has
done as we have developed the ability to
refine isolated and marketed so we've
gone from four pounds per year which was
basically from honey
all the way up and you can see the
different parts of the curve here's the
growth of the sugar industry in the late
1990s through the early 1900s and then
stabilization just before world war ii
here's the dip from rationing right here
and here's the introduction of high
fructose corn syrup and also as we were
remanded to reduce our fat and you can
see how high things have gone now you'll
notice
in the last
five six years there's actually been a
decline but that decline is nothing
compared to the rest of the curve
now if you believe that there is a limit
to how much sugar you should consume and
the american heart association has set
this threshold here and based on the
analogy with alcohol that i have made
this would be the theoretical basis for
alcohol right here the question is do
these actually work in terms of
understanding how disease gets
promulgated well here's the emergence of
cardiovascular disease as a health risk
in the united states in 1931
due to paul dudley white's famous
treatise on heart disease and you can
see as things went up above the aha
threshold that's when heart disease
started to become an issue
and here's 1988 when we started
realizing that we had an epidemic of
adolescent type 2 diabetes
so you can see that the temporal
relation between sugar consumption and
our two biggest problems in terms of
chronic metabolic disease that is heart
disease and diabetes
at least temporally related to this
increase but of course temporal relation
is not causation
now this is the world wide per capita
sugar supply and you'll notice
the light blue here is how much the
american heart association says you can
consume every day notice the entire
world is darker than that here we are at
629 calories availability and the rest
of the world is you know just right
behind us because now sugar is cheap
the
early history of the sugar epidemic was
actually
nicely delineated in this
piece in the national geographic just
this past month for anybody who is
interested in sort of how we got here in
the slave trade and all of the other
things the pro political imbroglios that
sugar has caused over the uh centuries
but we're going to talk about just the
last 30 years right now because that's
what i've experienced and that's what
i'm interested in and that's what's led
to this adolescent type 2 diabetes
pandemic that i have to take care of and
that's what i'm trying to fix so let's
talk about what happened in these 30
years this is the perfect storm it
started actually with the fall of
batista and the uh the fact that we
could now not rely on cuba for our sugar
supply this
caused the increase in sugar
production in florida which actually
took over the entire country to the
point where now hawaii doesn't even have
a sugar refinery okay because it's now
the florida and the fan hull brothers
in 1973
richard nixon told his secretary of
agriculture earl rusty butts love that
name
that food should never be an issue in a
presidential election that fluctuating
food prices cause political unrest
indeed we know that because just five
years ago we diverted some of our corn
crop to ethanol and it caused rice riots
in thailand and caused the ouster of
their prime minister now whether or not
that prime minister deserved to be
ousted is a separate question but that
was the immediate and proximate cause
notice this slide here this is the
percent of gross national products spent
on food by country from time magazine
notice we are the worst we have only
seven percent of our gdp spent on food
here's the uk at nine percent here's
australia at 11 and we are the three
most obese countries
notice the uh countries in purple
they're all greater than 36 percent of
uh gdp spent on food and they've all had
a revolution within the last two years
indeed
fluctuating food prices cause political
unrest nixon had it right
well with the advent of high fructose
corn syrup that occurred in 1966 and
then introduced to the american market
in 1975
now we had competition for sugar
remember we'd always had a sugar tariff
in fact it's the second oldest piece of
legislation in america dating back to
1789
so we always had propped up prices but
when hfcs invaded our shores now all of
a sudden there was competition and look
what happened so here's the u.s producer
price index the goal here is to keep the
u.s producer price index at 100 that
means price stability any ups and downs
mean fluctuating sugar prices and you
can see what happened in the early 1970s
up down up down this is what nixon was
responding to
and notice here's the advent of corn
sweeteners here and look what happens
everything settles out at a hundred
percent because now there's competition
and look what happened on the
international stage here's the london
price they didn't have high fructose
corn syrup but we still saw a change a
stabilization in their prices compared
to hours and here's the us retail price
for refined sugar against high fructose
corn syrup it was half the price and so
now
the food industry could start putting it
in everything because they could afford
to because it was cheap and it was
miscible because it was already in
solution
so here's the change in high fructose
corn syrup and the change in sugar
now this comes from the corn refiners
association themselves and they say well
it's just a substitution we're just
taking something that's cheaper and
substituting it for something more
expensive not quite
because if you look here the 73 pounds
per year here back in the 70s up to 93
pounds or 95 pounds per year here and
this is missing something anybody know
what's missing from this slide
juice
because juice is sucrose okay that's
sugar as well and we started making
juice like crazy right anita bryant a
day without orange juice is like a day
without sunshine okay that was because
juice could be frozen and stored it
became a commodity fruit is not a
commodity but fruit juice is and sold on
the market as such so here's juice and
here's most fructose items in fact we
consume right now 120 pounds of sugar
per year and the question is is that
over our limit
based on the american heart association
based on the analogy with alcohol we are
way over our limit and the question is
is that what's causing the disease
the fourth
item
back in the late 1970s we were told to
go low fat why
well in the early 1970s we discovered
this molecule in our bloodstream called
ldl low density lipoprotein by the
mid-1970s we learned that dietary fat
raised our ldl so let's call dietary fat
a and ldl b we learned that a lead to b
then in the late 1970s we learned that
ldl levels in large populations
correlated with coronary disease so
let's call that c so we learned that b
correlates with c so the logic was well
if a leads to b and b correlates with c
then a must lead to c therefore no a no
c get rid of dietary fat ldl will go
down and cardiovascular disease will
reverse
is that what happened
not at all not at all if anything it got
worse
now why did it get worse well for a
couple of reasons this was the fight
that was going on back in the 1970s
there was a huge nutritional war going
on it was actually quite nasty
and
a lot of name calling
so over here we had john yutkin who was
a british physiologist nutritionist
physician who said that sugar was the
bad guy back in 1972 he wrote this
missive called pure white and deadly and
i read this several years ago and
realized that i was just basically
parroting what judgment had said
25 27 years earlier i was really quite
amazed that i had just rediscovered what
he already knew
over here we have ansel keys and he was
already pretty famous back then because
he was the inventor of the k ration back
in world war ii
and so he was already sort of on the
scene nutritionally and he was the one
who said saturated fat was the bad guy
well let's look at his data so this is
ansel keys seven countries study right
here japan italy england and wales
australia canada the united states
percent calories from saturated fat and
here's coronary disease deaths over here
looks pretty good right
except for one thing it wasn't the seven
country study it was the 22 countries
study
and here the whole 22 all plotted out
now there's still a minor correlation
but not nearly as
you know good looking as it did before
and the question is
why did he cherry-pick those seven
countries and why is it that he left out
the countries that actually blew a hole
in his hypothesis here are the messiah
inuit rendelin tocao indigenous tribes
that's all they eat is fat they don't
have any carbohydrate at all and they
have the lowest rate of heart disease on
the planet
so let's read what
keys himself said this is from page 262
of his own work
the fact that the incidence rate of
coronary heart disease was significantly
correlated with the average percentage
of calories from sucrose sugar
in the diet is explained by the
intercorrelation of sucrose with
saturated fat in other words donuts
these guys here
eat
donuts
these guys
don't
partial correlation analysis shows that
with saturated fat constant there was no
significant correlation between dietary
sucrose and the incidence of coronary
heart disease
now when you do a multivariate linear
regression you have to do it both ways
you hold one constant and show that the
other one still works you have to do it
both ways he didn't do it
he only did it one way
the question is why did he only do it
one way i don't know the answer to that
because i don't you know i don't have
his data and you know this was before
computers kind of hard to check the work
but it leaves a major question as to
whether or not this was actually correct
nonetheless this started the low-fat
craze in america now the content of
home-cooked food you can control the fat
you can decide how much fat you're going
to put in your own food but low-fat
processed food tastes like cardboard
because the flavor was in the fat which
meant that you had to do something when
you took the fat out you had to
substitute something well carbohydrate
and which carbohydrate well sugar so
here's snack wells they're still with us
okay two grams of fat down 13 grams of
carbohydrate up four of which are sugar
and the question is which was worse for
you the fat or the sugar that's the
question we're asking today
here's berkeley farms
one percent low-fat milk my daughter
when she was in second grade brought
these two containers home and said dad
you're not gonna believe this okay so
this is
130 calories
15 grams of sugar all lactose
and here's berkeley farms one percent
chocolate milk
okay 190 calories 29 grams of sugar high
fructose corn syrup is the second
ingredient
so when you give your kid chocolate milk
you're giving them a glass of milk and a
half a glass of orange juice
the question is is that okay to do and
the school
dietitians say well we got to get our
kids to drink milk somehow
why don't we put the fat back in the
milk in the first place that was that
made it perfectly fine and i drank that
my entire uh you know uh
young livelihood
okay number five the third worst
hurricane in american history and it
never even hit our shores everybody of
course knows katrina and sandy but this
was hurricane allen in 1980 and what it
did was it destroyed the entire
caribbean sugar crop which really put a
fire under u.s sugar consumption because
now we knew that we needed
to
have another sugar source aside from a
far
a foreign soil
and that led to this right here
everybody remember new coke
1985 and we revolted
right and they brought back coke classic
where'd coke classic go
that's coke classic right there you're
looking at it okay
under the wire that's what you're that's
what you're drinking today
so as far as i'm concerned from a
ubiquiti standpoint we've had our food
supply adulterated right under our very
noses and with our tested approval
because we haven't complained with the
addiction of fructose for palatability
and also because it's a browning agent
it browns the bread better well that's
the mayard reaction that's the reaction
that actually creates hemoglobin a1c
which is the thing that we look at in
diabetics blood to determine whether or
not they're getting sick
it's a sign of cellular aging so if you
had an orange juice this morning you're
browning faster
and the removal of fiber for shelf life
and for freezing because you can't
freeze fiber
and finally the substitution of trans
fats which we used as a hardening agent
an increased shelf life vis-a-vis the
ten-year-old twinkie
okay but we know that those are bad and
so we're removing those because we know
that those are the devil incarnate we're
trying to get those out of the food
supply but there are certainly issues
with that as well as marcia cohen and i
have explored this year
all right next toxicity this is the
tough one
i'm going to try to convince you that
obesity is not the problem
obesity is irrelevant obesity is
the marker for the disease not the
disease itself because you don't die
from obesity you die from the diseases
that travel along with it which are
called metabolic syndrome those are type
2 diabetes hypertension dyslipidemia
cardiovascular disease cancer dementia
polycystic ovarian disease non-alcoholic
fatty liver disease and the list goes on
that's what you die of and we're going
to talk today about diabetes because in
diabetes we got the best data and that's
where the money goes
that's what's breaking the medical bank
the health care bank so here's how you
need to look at this
here's a venn diagram of the entire us
adult population
72 million obese people at 30 percent
168 million people at normal weighted
that's 70 percent
okay
everyone thinks these are the bad guys
these are the sick guys these are the
guys costing us the money 80
of obese people are sick and cost money
usually double the medical expenditures
of the general population so everyone
assumes these 57 million are the problem
and they're costing us the big bucks
this is incorrect
this is completely incorrect here's what
the real story is let's start at the
beginning again
yes
eighty percent of obese people are sick
but that means twenty percent of obese
people are healthy
they are metabolically normal and a
paper just came out today in the journal
of clinical endocrinology metabolism
showing exactly why they're normal
because they do not have inflammation
they are metabolically normal they're
just fat
conversely up to 40 percent of the
normal weight population has the exact
same chronic metabolic dysfunction due
to inflammation as does the obese they
get type 2 diabetes they get
hyperlipidemia they get
cardiovascular disease they get cancer
they get dementia they get at a slightly
lower rate agreed but they actually 40
percent of 168 million is 50 67 they
actually
outnumber the obese
so really what we're talking about is
more than half of the us adult
population so this is not a personal
issue this is more than half of the
population this is a public health
problem
in addition
everybody
thinks that it's the obese person's
fault because it's convenient to think
so
let's hearken back just 30 years to a
different public health disaster hiv
now
hiv
1979 patient zero 1981 aids got coined
as a term
1986
c ever coupe said we got to do something
about this
when did hiv become a public health
crisis
when
anybody know
1991
why in 1991 did hiv become a public
health crisis
because that's when magic johnson got
aids
and all of a sudden everybody said you
know what
it's not the gays and the addicts
anymore it's not them
everyone's at risk it's now us and
everybody realized we needed to do
something about this as a society and it
became a public health crisis well guess
what this is a public health crisis
because everyone is at risk whether
you're fat or not because it's not about
obesity
so let's talk about what it is
so toxicity how do we define it
the degree to which a substance can
damage an organism
now
a substance could damage an organism in
several different ways and a nutrient
could potentially damage an organism
through calories if i'm going to say
that
sugar is specifically toxic i have to
show that it's toxic irrespective of its
calories unrelated to its calories and
unrelated to obesity everybody
understand that's my charge i have to
meet that bar
in order
to make my case
okay
so those are the caveats it's got to be
exclusive of calories it's got to be
exclusive of obesity it's got to be
human data only because the food
industry will say well who cares about
animals it's only about humans and it
has to be in doses routinely consumed it
can't be using
doses that are so outlandish that you
could basically argue that it's a a
an artifact everybody with me those are
my charges i have to meet those
so here we are here's world sugar
consumption tripling over the past 50
years okay from 50 tons million tons per
year to 150 million tons per year notice
brazil
they used to be so poor they couldn't
even afford their own sugar they were
always sugar exporters but they weren't
sugar consumers well now they're a brick
country they got lots of money and now
they have the highest rate of increase
of type 2 diabetes on the planet
because now they are consuming their own
sugar
where is the diabetes the highest
the middle east saudi arabia qatar uae
kuwait malaysia
why them
why them
no alcohol that's right no alcohol
but they got soft drinks like they're
going out of style why because it's hot
and the water supplies a question mark
and
no alcohol
this is their reward this is their
reward now i'm going to tell you
alcohol is better than soft drinks and
you know why
number one it's way more fun number two
number two
alcohol for lack of a better word is
self-limiting
because you can only drink yourself
under the table once a day
i have a little shot glass at home
beat hangovers stay drunk right
but the fact of the matter is with soft
drinks you can keep doing it and doing
it and doing it and that is exactly what
is going on in the middle east today
that is their reward and that is their
uh
oppression is what it is
now
this is
a
an analysis of
uh called the epic interact study from
europe and what it shows is that when
you adjust for calories and you adjust
for bmi you just look at sugar sweetened
beverages against the risk for diabetes
every sugar sweetened beverage that you
consume increases your risk for diabetes
by 29 percent over time
this is in doses commonly used this is
human data but it's correlational data
correlational because it's a snapshot in
time the question is do we have
causational data that's what we have to
meet and that's what we supplied this is
a study that we published in february of
this year in plus one it's called an
econometric analysis and that's very
specific it actually uses uh what ech
economists use to predict stock market
changes and fluctuations in crashes
we looked we melded four databases
together the food and agriculture
organization statistics database melded
with the international diabetes
federation database which had diabetes
prevalence we looked at total calories
fruits excluding wine oils roots tubers
pulses nuts and vegetables that's fiber
containing foods meat cereals and
finally sugar sugar crops and sweeteners
we melded that with the idf and then we
melded that with the world bank world
development indicators database to
control for poverty urbanization aging
and physical activity and obesity
we had data for 175 countries and the
countries that we did not include were
not different based on what we call a
heckman test we had a very very fancy
data monitoring and analysis that's what
an econometric analysis gets you
generalized estimating equations with a
fixed effects approach called a hausmann
test a hazard model control for
selection bias called the heckman test
the longitudinal data to predict what
preceded what in order to show causation
you have to show precedence you have to
show that something occurs before the
other thing
in a correlation analysis you only have
the snapshot you can't tell
directionality you can't tell what
caused what you can't tell if
sugar caused diabetes or diabetics drink
sugar beverages you couldn't tell that
but if you have the whole decade
now you have the movie
and now you can determine precedence and
we use period effects to control for
secular trends and we control for gdp
obesity urbanization aging and physical
activity we control for everything we
could control for and here's the data
during the decade diabetes rose from 5.5
to 7 percent worldwide
here's the effects model you'll notice
it does not cross zero which means it's
significant
for every 100 calories diabetes preval
in sugar diabetes prevalence went up by
0.87 percent
worldwide
and here's the adjusted association of
sugar with diabetes prevalence very
clearly significant and correlated
here's the take home message this is
what i want you to remember
only changes in sugar availability
predicted changes in diabetes prevalence
not total calories total calories were
irrelevant now that doesn't mean the
total calories can cause diabetes that's
not what this means it could
but in this study for every extra 150
calories that any country consumed it
only increased diabetes prevalence by
0.1 percent
nothing
but if those 150 calories happen to be a
can of soda diabetes prevalence
increased 11
fold 11 fold by 1.1 and here in america
we don't consume
one soda a day we consume 2.5 sodas per
day so that's really a 2.4
increase in prevalence when you consider
that diabetes prevalence in america is
8.3 percent that means that 29 of all
diabetes in america is explained by
sugar and sugar alone irrespective of
its calories and irrespective of its
effect on weight
that's causation these data meet what's
known as the austin bradford hill
criteria for causal medical inference
that is we showed dose
the higher the dose per country the
higher the diabetes rate we showed
duration the higher they were exposed
the higher the diabetes rate
we showed directionality those countries
where
sugar went down and there were a few
showed lower diabetes rates and we
showed precedence by three years
whenever sugar changed in any country
diabetes followed by three years in
either direction
that is causal medical inference
and we again we estimate that one
quarter of all the diabetes in the world
today is explained by sugar and sugar
alone you want something to work on you
want something that's actionable
here it is and this is direct and
causation this is proximate cause
now it has limitations and i'm gonna
take it through very quick quiz of time
it's not it's a raw it's not a raw data
analysis that is it's not person by
person that would be even better it's
country by country
okay and so but it has time course and
precedence
now could be subject to something called
the ecological fallacy that is
inferences about individuals are based
on aggregates who says that the people
who drank the sodas were the people who
got the diabetes
except of course that we know that from
other studies where they did have raw
data analysis
could the sugar consumers and the
diabetics be different people really
unlikely
it's food supply not consumption data
because we don't have consumption data
there's always a concern about wastage
but studies of wastage show 29 wastage
across
foodstuffs
not anything specific for sugar
and leaving the us out of the analysis
where we waste the most food did not
change the findings
it's only one decade but it was a hell
of a decade
not a complete dietary analysis could
micronutrients be important in this
because we didn't look at those
and that might actually be very
important so that's you know that's a
potential uh complicating factor
different techniques used to screen for
diabetes in different countries
different diagnostic criteria for
diabetes in different countries and some
countries uses self-reported data and
most diabetics don't even know they have
it about two-thirds of diabetics don't
know they have it that would only make
the data even worse
and the data includes both type 1 and
type 2 diabetes but type 1's been
relatively stable on a percentage basis
this is driven by type 2. 90 of diabetes
is type 2.
so
just so you don't think i'm
fructo-centric as it were
okay there are actually four foodstuffs
that are metabolized all the same way to
cause this same chronic metabolic
disease
trans fats do this but trans fats are
going down
branch chain amino acids leucine
isoleucine valine these are essential
dietary amino acids and the place you
get them
corn fed beef
higher than grass-fed beef
so that might be a problem as well
alcohol
alcohol a little bit's okay and a lot is
not and same with fructose a little is
okay and a lot is not
and the reason that these four travel
together is because they are essentially
metabolized all the same way and
differently from other calories
the liver is the only site for energy
metabolism so everything goes to the
liver so when your liver gets overloaded
it has to deal with the excess
it's not insulin regulated so there's no
way to
divert the calories into another
direction
no glycogen pop off glycogen is liver
starch it's non-toxic so if you make
glycogen
you're actually helping yourself that's
why marathoners carb load with pasta
before a marathon race is to up their
glycogen and that's non-toxic
and the mitochondria of your cells the
little energy burning factories are
overwhelmed because all these go
straight to the mitochondria and they
have no way to stop the onslaught and so
what the mitochondria do is they turn
all the excess into liver fat and the
liver fat drives the chronic metabolic
disease
what this proves is that a calorie is
not a calorie
if you believe a calorie is a calorie
number one
you're lost
number two two we're sunk and number
three the food industry wins
if a calorie is not a calorie that's the
place
where we can exert some action
now abuse we'll do this real quick
is sugar addictive
yes or no
what do you think
for some people just like alcohol lots
of people can drink alcohol and be fine
and there's a small minority of people
who
are clearly alcohol addicted about 20 of
the american population is alcohol
addicted it's probably the same 20 that
are sugar addicted and there's something
called
addiction transfer oprah is the you know
world's expert on addiction transfer
okay so the light public seems to know
this the scientists are having a hard
time getting on board with this
now if you look at a brain of a control
patient
you're looking now here at the dopamine
receptors in the reward system dopamine
is the feel good neurotransmitter when
your brain sees dopamine it goes i like
that
okay that's good okay and as long as it
has receptors to receive that
information you will get reward
notice here's a cocaine brain okay
cocaine addicted adult the dopamine
receptors are way down regulated and
that's what addiction is is down
regulation of those dopamine receptors
because now it means you need more of
the substrate more cocaine in order to
get the same level of reward because you
have fewer receptors to bind that
dopamine that is called mass action and
this phenomenon is called tolerance this
is what tolerance is this is the
neuroanatomic
equivalent of tolerance well here's a
control brain over here
notice there's an obese brain right next
door
what do you see
same thing
same thing and in fact nora volkow the
head of the national institute of drug
abuse has said that obesity is a form of
food addiction for many patients so i'm
not the only one who says this so is
there really such a thing as sugar
addiction well we have to look for
similarities to other drugs of
dependence nicotine morphine amphetamine
cocaine the one i think is the most
appropriate is alcohol because number
one
that's what
sugar gets turned into right it's called
wine
so the metabolism is the same number two
it's a market commodity just like
sugar is and number three
it affects the brain in the same way
now i'm not the only one who thinks that
sugar is a problem let's see i'm gonna i
thought i
took care of this let's see
why is it not working i thought we had
this work working this is
well
i apologize i thought we had this
working
it is
i'm gonna have to pass for this this is
eric clapton
um talking about his addiction to sugar
when he was five or six years old
and i apologize i i had it working
before the meeting started
all right let's go let's go on i
apologize for that
okay in animals
here are the criteria for addiction
binging withdrawal
craving and cross-sensitization with
other drugs of abuse meaning
that
you expose an animal to one drug of
abuse for three weeks and you
addict them to the one drug
and then you expose them to a second
drug they've never seen before and
they're addicted to that one too because
the dopamine receptors are the same and
once you down regulate them you down
regulate them for all the substances of
abuse that's called cross sensitization
in animals we have slam dunk causative
evidence that sugar is addictive done by
many many very very reputable
investigators
what about humans now it's really hard
to determine this in humans because
number one everyone's got a baseline
there's nobody who's naive
number two we can't grind up people's
brains the irbs won't let us okay
and number three it's very hard to show
causation especially with our current
diet but here are the dsm 5 criteria for
addiction tolerance and withdrawal and
here are all the psychological
dependencies now if you read through
this this reads just like obesity this
is what the obese patients tell us
so the question is is sugar addictive so
anybody see this movie
okay i've got another clip and i'm
hoping this one works let's see yes
sorry about the work
i was feeling really really
sick and unhappy
started eating
feel great
feel really good now
i feel so good
and that right baby
now everybody know the story morgan
spurlock was a vegan because his
girlfriend was a vegan chef he started
eating mcdonald's for 30 days nonstop
every meal okay this is day 18 and he
just described withdrawal
so it can happen to anybody
can happen to anybody if you down
regulate those dopamine receptors you're
going to need a bigger hit in order to
do that that's called abuse
now finally externalities negative
impact on society now societal
intervention says that
your abuse of some of a substance has to
affect me in a negative way for us to
regulate it for instance
nobody
is saying we should regulate caffeine
because your use of caffeine does not
affect me
if you smoke or dick drink or take drugs
though that is bad for me
because of secondhand smoke car
accidents from alcohol declining housing
prices when your house gets turned into
a coke den a crackdown altered work
productivity and absenteeism i have to
do your friggin work because you're a
drug addict okay all the reasons you
know about these are the reasons we
regulate these substances
so how does your obesity affect me
274 million extra for jet fuel that
doesn't quite do it discomfort on the
subway
yeah
sinking of boats due to the weight
9 2003 lake george ferry uh coded for
17 160 pound adults they had 25 195
pound adults and the
ship capsized ain't going to do here's
the reason 65 billion reduction in work
productivity 50 increase in absenteeism
50 increase in health insurance premiums
currently we are at 2 750
per employee for obesity whether the
employee is obese or not it's breaking
the bank the employers know this is
unsustainable
we look we spent 245 billion for
diabetes and 200 billion for dementia
last year that is one
third of the entire medical budget
for those two diseases 192 billion
wasted in health care resources
obesity is a threat to national security
because 27 percent of the recruits can't
pass the phys ed exam
and finally the government pays twice
they pay for the corn subsidy and then
they pay for the er visits and that's
not going to stop because there is no
preventative services for metabolic
syndrome we're going to take 32 6
million sick people onto the rolls
and we can't stop the heart attacks or
the dementia
it's going to break the bank and
medicare will be broke by the year 2026.
this is why your obesity affects me
now
we have toxic substances that are not
abused now everything's toxic in do in
the right dose even water will kill you
if you overdo it but here are some
substances that will definitely kill you
iron vitamin d oxygen right retinopathy
pseudoephedrine until you turn it into
crystal meth then it's abused too water
these are all toxic substances that are
not abused we don't have to regulate
them
we also have abused substances that are
not toxic like for instance caffeine as
i mentioned nicotine until the tars are
added right but you can buy nicorette
gum down at walgreens and it's no
problem
but when you have toxic substances that
are abused now you've got a problem
like morphine heroin amphetamine coking
alcohol well guess what sugar meets all
those same criteria for all the reasons
i've just laid out for you so the
question is what are we going to do
about it now the american heart
association says this is a problem
they said and i actually contributed to
this
scientific statement that we currently
in america consume 22 teaspoons of added
sugar per day
and we need to reduce that to 9
teaspoons per day for males and 6
teaspoons per day for females that's a
reduction by two-thirds to
three-quarters
is that achievable can we do that in
america today
so what does the sugar industry say back
to this what's the politics of this okay
well here we go
so first what they say is that fructose
for glucose exchange studies show no
significant difference and if you look
at isocaloric that is where you just
change the fructose for the glucose at
the same level of the of calories you
see no change that's what they point to
but if you look at hypercaloric trials
that is people who are over consuming
which is what we all are right because
we're all over consuming by 275 calories
per day now all of a sudden you start
seeing the effects
and that's what we're dealing with me so
what they say is well everybody just eat
moderately problem is you can't eat
moderately because it's being abused
because we're all addicted
so it's a tautology
they also they also say it shows no
significant difference but the problem
is oral fructose is absorbed poorly so
it doesn't even get into your
bloodstream
in the fasting state the amount of
fructose that gets turned into liver fat
is actually quite low but in the obese
insulin resistance state it's five times
higher
it's not fructose-4 glucose it's
fructose and glucose because sugar and
high fructose corn syrup is fructose and
glucose and that matters because when
you do these studies with fructose alone
you don't get much but when you do them
with fructose and glucose together now
the liver fat jumps triples and if you
double the amount it goes up six times
there's no asymptote
so the more sugar you consume the lower
liver fat you make
especially in the hypercaloric state
which is what we're all in this is a
problem
they also say fructose doesn't raise the
blood sugar it has a low glycemic index
now who here knows about glycemic index
so
glycemic index is the amount
of
uh
blood sugar rise that 50 grams of
carbohydrate will give you
and that means the amount of insulin
rise that will come with that fructose
doesn't stimulate blood glucose why
because it's fructose
it stimulates blood fructose instead the
question is is that dangerous by itself
and the answer is absolutely yes
because it causes cardiovascular disease
by itself because it binds to the
proteins in your arteries
and causes them to become less flexible
and that starts the foam cell process
it has nothing to do with your blood
glucose
a little fructose has been shown to
improve insulin secretion just like
alcohol but that's dose dependent and as
long as you stay under that dose you're
okay the problem is we're over that dose
by a lot
information on total sugars is available
on the food label for everyone to see
and for everyone to make their own
choice
right the nanny state argument well
that's not really true and here's why
the nutrition labeling and education act
of 1990
lists total sugars
that includes glucose galactose which
are no problem and fructose all together
and that's on purpose and the reason is
because they don't want to tell you
about added sugars they want to
obfuscate the
what they've added to the food because
they say that that is proprietary
if we told all of our customers how much
added sugar we put in all of our foods
processed foods
our competitors could duplicate our
recipes
this is proprietary information and you
can't know it
that's a problem yogurt is the perfect
example
how many grams of sugar
in a pomegranate yogurt
anybody know
19.
now how many of those are lactose
and how many of those are added sugar
you can't know
you're not allowed to know
now how many
grams of sugar are there in a plain
yogurt
seven
that means that 12 grams of added sugar
to that pomegranate yogurt that's the
same as a bowl of cat and crunch
so when you have a pomegranate yogurt
you're having a plain yogurt plus a bowl
of captain crunch the question is are
you okay with that is that what you
bought into was that what you expected
when you purchased that item
yogurt's supposed to be healthy not only
that but there are 56 names for sugar
and that's on purpose because they don't
want you to know that sugar has been
added yogurt's another example a perfect
example evaporated cane juice anybody
know what evaporated cane juice is
what happens when you evaporate cane
juice you get
sugar
well evaporated kinesis is not a
sanctioned sweetener by the fda there
are nine sanctioned sweeteners and ecj
is not one of them and so this is
misbranding and 30 percent of foods in
the american grocery store today are
misbranded to keep you from knowing
what's going on
and here's the list of the 56 names in
case you thought i was you know a little
hyperbolic
so the question is where's the sugar in
what foods how about all of them okay
one third of the sugar that we consume
is in beverages okay fine we know about
those 1 6th in desserts candy ice cream
etc that means fully one half of the
foods that
have
sugar we didn't know had sugar like
salad dressing yogurt tomato sauce
ketchup condiments crackers other
carbohydrate products all things we
didn't know anybody like wheat fins
check it out
next they say wait a second we were
wrong about fat
we all said fat was bad
and now you're telling me it's sugar
what makes you think you're right now
okay we need more research indeed we do
i don't argue that we absolutely need
more research but you know what that's
called
that's called the pessimistic
meta-induction theory look it up on
wikipedia it's a real deal okay this
says that
whatever we thought
10 years ago is already wrong
and whatever we think today will be
wrong 10 years from now
true
and i've seen these cycles come and go
in medicine
the question is why should we do
anything
if everything is going to be wrong
anyway why should we change anything so
you know what that is that's moving the
goal posts
that means we'll never do anything that
means we might as well just stick with
the dogma of the day because everything
will be wrong okay ask galileo that's
what they wanted to do with him okay
the question is what level of proof do
we need in order to make change that's
the argument for today is how much do
you need to know now i agree
correlational data is not good enough
because you don't know directionality
and you have these questions about
multivariate versus univariate and other
things that might be going on but when
you have causal medical inference which
is what we have for sugar and diabetes
that's exactly what we had with tobacco
and
lung cancer in the 1960s and guess what
it's still all we have
we've never done a scientific proof
experiment because you'd have to take
naive people and start them smoking for
50 years
you think any irb is going to let you do
that
okay that's unethical and immoral and
too expensive so 90 percent of what we
know in medicine today is causal medical
inference only 10 percent is scientific
proof
but the food industry says we need
scientific proof to make any change why
because they know will never get it
and finally regulation is tantamount to
the nanny state right like michael
bloomberg right the nanny okay
well the fact is we've already been told
what to eat it's too late okay everyone
says keep your hands out of my kitchen
keep keep lusting out of my kitchen you
know fact is your kitchen's already been
invaded and you've already been told
what to eat because of the 600 000 items
in the american supermarket 80 of them
have added sugar added by the food
industry for their own purposes not for
yours you've already been told what to
eat this isn't about big brother it's
our big brother's already here
so the big question is
who do you want in your kitchen
you want government who will take your
money
and your freedom
or do you want the food industry who's
already taken your money your freedom
and your health
that's your choice
anything else is a false choice
and the question is how does the food
industry stay where they are well this
was published by michelle simon a former
graduate of uc hastings and the former
research associate of david's okay
called and now a word from our sponsor
and the word and is very specific a and
d academy of nutrition and dietetics
are america's nutrition professionals in
the pocket of big food because that's
who's paying their bill
and how about this
co-opting health professionals i gave a
talk at the american academy of
pediatrics in october of 2009
and i had this slide in my slide set and
the american academy pediatrics says if
you show the slide we won't let you on
the dais
so i had to take it out
but i'm showing it now
so here's what's happened to our food
dollars
1982 30 years ago 2012
meets down 10 because we're all told to
go low-fat
fruits and vegetables exactly the same
everybody tells us we need to eat more
fruits and vegetables
we're eating all the fruits and
vegetables we can
grains and baked goods
up a percent not even a big deal
dairy products down from 13 to 10
because we're all lactose intolerant
and finally here's the big one processed
foods and sweets 11.6
22.9 a doubling in 30 years that's where
the money went that's what you're paying
for and that's what's causing the
chronic metabolic disease you are
looking at it
and this is a war because what's good
for them is bad for us what's good for
us is bad for them there's no middle
ground
it's a war the question is who's winning
well here is the stock price
of the s p 500 against mcdonald's coke
and pepsi for the last five years here's
the economic downturn of 2008 right here
and you'll notice mcdonald's coke and
pepsi are doing quite well thank you and
here is monsanto hormel adm general
mills conagra procter gamble craft
against the s p they're all doing better
than the s p if you want to make money
invest in a food company because they
have a winning formula they have a
formula they can't miss
because it's legal
and addictive
the problem is we're all dying in the
process
so this paper just came out just a
couple months ago in lancet profits and
pandemics prevention of harmful effects
of tobacco alcohol and ultra-processed
food and drink industries and they make
the argument and i totally subscribe to
this that we used to practice the old
medicine which was about infections and
the vector was microbes that's what i
learned and now the new medicine is
something else entirely it's about
chronic disease and the vector is
multinational corporations who have
figured out how to game the system
now what are we going to do about it
well this is a public health problem and
that means we need a public health
solution now take a look at all of these
diseases every single disease on this
list
was
a personal responsibility issue before
the sheer gravity and enormity of the
problem made it a public health crisis
as we talked about hiv as an example
okay every one of these how about guns
is that a public health problem
except that it's a personal
responsibility problem isn't it
depends on who you ask
right if you ask the supreme court it's
a personal responsibility problem
but it's not it's a public health
problem
and i would put sugar right down there
as well
so here we have what the government is
doing right now it's called the let's
move campaign this is michelle obama's
campaign to try to reduce obesity in a
generation everybody familiar
so what she says is focus on the
individual focus on the family and focus
on the community but
she leaves government and the food
industry out
now
anybody
remember her very first
speech after let's move was rolled out
in 2010 it was to the grocery
manufacturers association of america the
gma and she pointed directly at them
just as i am to you right now and said
this is your fault you can see this on
youtube i'm not making this up this is
your fault and you have to help come up
with a solution
she has never said it again
not once
why is that
why
she's been muzzled by her own
administration
because they don't want this fight and i
know they don't want this fight because
they told me they don't want this fight
sam cass is michelle obama's personal
chef and her point person to her obesity
task force and he told me after reading
the new york times article everyone in
the white house including the president
said they're all in agreement and they
will do absolutely nothing about it not
a wink not a nod because they do not
want the fight with the food industry
they have enough enemies
that's what this is about
and you'll notice anita dunn who
actually founded let's move now lobbies
for the food industry
and now a word from our sponsors
so the questions i'm going to leave you
with are number one can our toxic food
environment be changed without
government or societal intervention
especially if they're potentially
addictive substances involved
did just say no work
does education work
for substances of abuse the answer is no
it doesn't
question two can we afford to wait to
enact public health measures when
healthcare will be bankrupt due to
chronic metabolic disease we've got 13
years people and we've got to do
something now
not wait for more research we have the
research we have what we need
now policy what do we do what are we
going to do so there's something called
targeted prevention that is
treat
the patient
right treat the obese person except for
one thing we just learned that there are
more
non-obese people who are sick than obese
people who are sick so that's a problem
now that's the strengths is that it's
the target to the individual limits to
those who are effective easier
incorporate into medical care a benefit
to risk ratio that's high the weaknesses
are the medicalization of prevention
which is hard to do behavior
modification which is impossible to do
especially with addictive substances
cost and feasibility and extraordinarily
limited success across the board
but it's not
targeted it's public health prevention
that we need
so what are the strengths there well
it's radical it's gonna work because
we're gonna make it work it's powerful
okay because everybody's on board
environmental modification fix the
environment not fix the behavior and
that's what our data and many other
people's data show about obesity is fix
the environment the limitations are
the libertarians the acceptability if
you will the feasibility and the costs
so what could we do well we could tax we
could restrict access and we could
intervene now i'm not suggesting
intervention we tried that with alcohol
and it was a complete and utter disaster
you couldn't possibly you know have you
know storm troopers you know invading
people's homes you know for baking an
apple pie you know that's just not gonna
happen and i don't even suggest it okay
because my wife would be the first one
they'd have to take away
what we need to do like we have with
every other substance of abuse has come
to peaceful coexistence
we have to find the right amount of
legislation regulation to be able to
manage the problem rationally like we've
tried to do with tobacco and we can
argue about the wisdom of that
especially worldwide and alcohol
certainly no interdiction but plenty of
taxation and restriction of access as
needed
so
what factors contribute to increase
soft drink consumption well price
since 1980s the introduction of
introduction of high fructose corn syrup
the price has increased only 50 percent
of that of food
foods gone up way higher than sodas have
the
soft drink price
increased only 25 against fruits and
vegetables we're supposed to be eating
fruits and vegetables how are we going
to do that when sodas are so cheap and
fruits and vegetables keep going up
because they're not subsidized
we've allowed the serving size to rise
in most developing nations this is a
huge problem soda is cheaper and
actually safer than water and it's been
said that until
potable water is cheaper than soda we
cannot solve this global health crisis
and i totally agree with that
access well it's available worldwide
especially in schools fifty percent of
flavored milk sales at school and that
was you know that's a that's chocolate
milk that we're talking about there and
marketing in 2006 food marketers spent
1.05 billion on marketing to children
and adolescents and half of that was for
soda
so the question is are children
a rational target
is that acceptable
why is alcohol so relevant to this
question i actually think that the
analogies between sugar and alcohol are
very very strong and we should look to
alcohol control policy and my colleague
at ucsf laura schmidt and i and alan
taylor who's a visiting professor here
at georgetown are planning on writing a
book on exactly this shortly
both are extensively nutrients but aside
from energy they have no health value
metabolic and essential pathways in the
brain are similar both are legal
substances that produce health harms
when overused
there's little danger from moderate
consumption the problem is
what's moderate and how do you keep
things moderate when they are abused
and the burden of harm falls
disproportionately on the poorest people
who can afford the problem least
so here are the strategies that have
actually been shown not to work
governmental guidelines are useless
we keep saying well let's come up with
new guidelines like every five years
right the dietary guidelines advisory
committee it's garbage
it's it's not going to work
public information campaigns
have not worked warning pro labels on
product packaging have not worked
vis-a-vis smoking
school-based education programs everyone
wants this to work
everybody says let's put the money into
school-based education
all the data so far shows salutary
effects almost non-existent for this and
menu labeling everybody says well let
everybody know what they're eating so
you can decide for yourself all right
well let's look at menu labeling i like
this one
so here's the adult menu labeling study
out of new york city it's a historical
cross-sectional study so we had data in
2007 before labeling and we had data in
2009 after labeling the question is what
happened and the answer is nothing
nothing happened
mean calories did not change they
actually went up
three major changes showed very small
decreases
15 of the respondents reported using the
caloric information
and those that did purchased 106 fewer
calories than those that did not but
that's almost none of them because when
you go into a fast food restaurant
you're going for taste
and they say so
okay they may say they're coming in for
salad but they buy the burger and fries
right and there's a reason for that
here's for children
349 children and adolescents most
accompanied by their parent and most
from ethical uh racial minority groups
no significant differences in calories
purchased before or after labeling
35 ate fast food six or more times per
week
57
noted the labels well that's good at
least they had their eyes open but only
9 reported
using the information
indeed and 72 percent reported that
taste was the most important factor so
do you think that knowing what's in your
food changes what you eat
not at all
so education how are we going to do that
which nutrients are going to educate
people about
do you think that
total fat on the label actually matters
because there are some good fats and
there's some bad fats and they're all
bunched in together how are you supposed
to know what about salt marsha and i
have had long discussions about salt and
whether or not salt even matters in the
american diet what's the target and
what's the message if it's about total
calories we are sunk we will never get
past this and that's what we've done for
the last 30 years and you know the
definition of insanity right doing the
same thing over and over again and
expecting a different result well we've
done the same thing over and over again
for the last 30 years and somehow
somebody in washington still expects a
different result good luck
food labeling right added con sugar
content could we put it on the front of
package could we put the number of
teaspoons in teaspoons on the front of
the label and would it matter
menu labeling has not worked in new york
city education alone hasn't worked for
any other substance of abuse why would
you think that this would be enough
i think it's necessary i absolutely
think people need to know what they're
consuming but it is not sufficient
necessary but not sufficient
what about strategies that might work
so controls on advertising and marketing
have been talked about a lot
counter advertising campaigns anybody
ever see the new york city's man
drinking fat
commercial it's on youtube it is
disgusting
it is fantastic i love it okay and it
hasn't changed soda consumption in new
york city at all
and finally industry self-regulation
really so in istanbul in 2007 52
european health ministers got together
and agreed that we needed to cease
marketing of junk foods to children
i agree
i approached the community fcc director
deborah taylor tate under george w bush
with this exact same issue after this
meeting had occurred and she said this
is a direct quote i expect the food
industry to police itself which is
exactly what they've been doing all this
time
they it's hands off
food industry is hands off
the corner finders association you may
remember last year tried to rebrand hfcs
as corn sugar
and the fda told them no
well guess what they've done it anyway
and you know what they're going to get
away with it why
because the fda does not have an
enforcement arm
the enforcement arm's the department of
justice and they got better things to do
they're dealing with drones
and other
things
right
how about
on a community level santa clara and san
francisco in 2010 instituted the toy ban
right why should you coerce a child into
buying a happy meal just for the toy
let's dissociate the two you want the
toy buy the toy you want the meal buy
the meal makes perfect sense
well since then three states have banned
toy bands
sorry let me get rid of that
i don't know why it did that
okay let's go back
okay
and finally the campaign to retire
ronald which is uh ever ever continuing
how about things that are likely to work
pricing strategies are likely to work
because people actually care about price
control's at the point of sales bundling
strategies government agency action
those are the things that are likely
work those are things that have worked
in the past problem is you need people
on board you need government on board in
order to be able to enact these so let's
talk about pricing soda taxes so canada
and europe already do this they have the
general services tax or the value-added
tax they already do this the price
elasticity though on a can of soda is
very small everybody understand price
elasticity it's how much of a change in
consumption you're going to see with a
one percent change in price
it's very small it doesn't change much
in fact the 10 price increase only
reduces consumption by two percent
that's not very good
and that's what we're talking about is a
ten percent price increase a penny an
ounce
existing taxes on soda so far have not
resulted in soda consumption at 3
percent so this
fits this
soda taxes
are they for programs or are they to
reduce consumption
if they're for programs but not for
consumption you know what's going to
happen
soda companies are going to say see it
didn't work
worse yet
some unscrupulous politician will take
the money collected by the soda tax and
use it for general funds or personal
funds and that's what everybody's
worried about because that's what we've
seen already with tobacco
large taxes are necessary to reduce
consumption roland sturm at the rand
corporation says we need a
36 percent tax to effectuate a 25
reduction in consumption basically what
we need to do is double the price of a
can of soda you think anybody's ready
for that
or should we tax the ingredient instead
of the product should we tax the sugar
before it goes into the food rather than
tax the food itself that's a possibility
the problem is you would need that to be
national you'd need congress to do that
only they can levy such taxes you
couldn't do that state by state because
of the commerce clause that would be
outlandish otherwise
finally restriction controls on the
point of access age limits maybe we
should card kids for coke right if a
parent wants their kid to have a coke
let them buy it for them
okay i i actually and that would cost
nothing we could do that tomorrow we do
that for beer now
licensing and zoning controls over the
number of sales outlets why is there a
convenience store within 500 feet of
every single school in america
because the kids are a target
and they know it
how about use permits that control hours
of operation maybe they can't sell soda
between seven and nine in the morning
and three and five in the afternoon when
kids are coming from and going to school
we have sodas out of schools here in the
united and in california we have sb19
the last survey said that school obesity
rates are stable so maybe that's an
improvement and maybe it's because of
this we don't know and then of course
there's the big gulp ban which was
struck down as arbitrary and capricious
by hermann tingling of the new york
state
appellate court citing boreali v axelrod
1986 anybody familiar with boreali
so this was a us a
case about public smoking the thing was
it was 1986
in 1990 we learned about secondhand
smoke
if boreali had been decided four years
later there's no way in the world it
would have gotten decided in this
fashion well we have
uh the secondhand smoke of
uh obesity and sugar consumption it's
called
healthcare disaster is what it's called
the fact is
using boreali as a reason for striking
it down made no sense and this will
ultimately be appealed to the new york
state supreme court
here's what's happened to
sugar sweet and beverage access within
schools you can see it here in terms of
purchasing in fifth and eighth grades
okay look at the arrows right there
so
in the schools where
sugar sweetened beverage uh sales have
gone down
sales have gone down that's great except
for one thing
here's their total consumption hasn't
changed
why because they get it on the way home
or they get it at home so until we
change the entire food environment
concentrating on schools is not going to
work
how about bundling how about
differential subsidization why can't we
tax the bad food and subsidize the good
food could we subsidize broccoli
so that it would actually be in the best
interest of the food industry to try to
promulgate it we could we can modify
behavior through pricing we always do
the nordic countries have done this they
have subsidized low alcohol beers and
taxed the hell out of hard spirits in an
attempt to try to reduce alcohol
consumption and they have been
absolutely successful in terms of car
accidents
uh you know trauma and also cirrhosis of
the liver and they have done this over
the last 30 years
so differential subsidization we could
discount diet soda and tax sugar soda
now i'm not sure diet soda is any better
but it sure isn't a hell whole lot worse
this is the thing to remember the iron
law of alcohol policy says that reducing
the availability of alcohol will reduce
alcohol consumption will reduce
alcohol-related health harms the same
holds for sugar the problem is how do
you get there
how about government agency action we're
coming to a close
regulation of the food industry by
congress is a non-starter they're not
touching this
there's no way in the world anyone in
congress will go out on a limb for this
but why can't the farm bill subsidize
real food instead of food ingredients
that's what it used to do but not
anymore it could go back food stamps
remember bloomberg tried to remove food
stamps from snap from the supplemental
nutrition assistance program and he was
rebuffed by the usda why
because the usda is in the pocket of the
food industry and several other states
have since applied and the usda has
rebuffed them as well
but the question is why is the usda in
charge anyway that's like the fox in
charge of the hen house the usda's job
is to sell food it's hhs's job to keep
us healthy shouldn't they be
more active in this shouldn't this
really be an hhs issue an fda issue not
a usda issue
the fda and the efsa the european food
safety administration could influence
the court of public opinion to make
sugar less appealing you know cigarettes
went from fashion to filthy habit in
just a few years when people got on
board that there was a problem
the fda could revisit the nutrition
labeling education act and so instead of
total contents labeling could
reflect the degree of processing of the
food so what was added what was taken
away because all food is inherently good
it's what we do to the food that's not
if we add something that's a problem if
we take something away that's a problem
tell us what you did to the food instead
of what's in the
carton
okay if we did that
breakfast cereal would disappear
gone
the fda could re-examine their 1986
grass determination generally regarded
as safe one of the reasons we're in this
mess is because sugar is generally
regarded as safe this is something that
was determined in 1958 with no data
the results were inconclusive back in
1986 at a mean dosage of 50 grams per
day problem is our current dosage is now
80 grams per day so we didn't do it at
that dose and the whole issue with
the
with grass is intended use
no one intended for sugar consumption to
be
this high nonetheless the sugar industry
took that information and said the
government gave them a clean bill of
health when it was only inconclusive
there are lots of problems with this
document it was based on 1978 surveys at
53 grams which is just barely enough no
data on excessive consumption no data on
high fructose corn syrup back then and
fruit juice was considered fruit
not
sugar
which it is so who knows what the real
story is
but this is what the 1986 document said
and the person who wrote that document
walter glinsmann is now a consultant to
the corn refiners association
and there is no dietary reference intake
for sugar it's right there there's your
nutrition facts labor label here's the
percent daily value for everything
nothing for sugar it's not listed why
sam cass told me
he said
why would you need a dri for something
that was not a nutrient
something that is not a nutrient well
you know what he's actually right
because sugar provides no nutrition it
only provides energy
you do not need sugar to live there are
people who have a disorder in their
livers called hereditary fructose
intolerance if they consume any sugar
they die
we figure these patients out when
they're six months old when they get
their first dose of juice and they
become hypoglycemic down to five and
they are sugar-free for the rest of
their lives and you know what they're
the healthiest people on the planet
and they consume no sugar you know why
because sugar is not a nutrient it's an
energy source but it is not a nutrient
is alcohol a nutrient
yes or no
is alcohol and nutrient it supplies
calories but is it a nutrient it's a
toxin is what it is and we treat it as
such same thing here
how about legislative options advocacy
attempt to apply pressure on the
government good luck to us cspi is doing
that center for science in the public
interest but nothing's happened so far
legislation has a very long on-ramp
okay takes a long time to make anybody
do anything in congress and part of that
is due to corporate lobbying
other strategies for congressional
action so far nothing how about the farm
bill well price subsidies cause market
distortion it'd be much better to just
get rid of all the subsidies and let
every
uh food stuff reach its appropriate
market capitalization that would work
very nicely problem is
the food industry would have a cow
the question is
is that okay is it okay for the food
industry to have a cow i think it is
okay
finally
legal legal options
this is the statement that got me to law
school right here the hyderabad
statement from hyderabad india from an
indian public health forum when i heard
this i went
yeah that's right
all significant advances in population
health require and involve the use of
law
that is exactly right
and that is why i came to hastings to
get my masters
much shorter on ramp you can actually
make something happen you can do
regulation through litigation and it's
the most bang for the buck if you've got
court support
first question who's the defendant in
this case
is it the corn refiners
is it any sugar producer or is it the
distributors and the manufacturers
themselves hard to know
that's a big question
many companies theories to ascribe
culpability do you do it by excuse me
market share then coke would pay for 29
of the diabetes in the world
okay responsibility for contribution to
added sugar in the environment how would
you do it these are questions yet to be
answered
would you do this through individual
plaintiffs actions would you do it at
the state or the federal level
so you know they were not successful
against tobacco 845 individual actions
brought against big tobacco only two
were successful and both of those were
overturned on appeal
how
do you think this would go with
something like sugar which would be even
harder and there are so many different
defendants
how about class actions well class
actions were a great idea until at
mobility versus concepcion and walmart v
dukes which basically
said the supreme court doesn't want to
hear these cases anymore they're not
interested
but there's still 12 states that have
class action availability miss branding
is one and that's going on right now and
it's going on right now in superior
state court of california
because there are 56 names for sugar and
total sugars are on the label not added
sugar which is what we need
how about strict liability so this is a
big question right here is soda a
defective product what do you think
if used as directed does it kill you
yes or no
what do you think
eleven-fold increase in diabetes what do
you think yes or no
other products contain nutrients so they
would be like unlikely to be considered
defective but soda
ain't nothing in the soda you need
in fact everything in it is something
you don't
and finally failure to warn
it turns out latinos are particularly
susceptible to this and they get the
worst non-alcoholic fatty liver disease
and the worst
incidence of diabetes 50 percent of
california latinos get diabetes because
they have a genetic polymorphism that
makes their liver particularly
susceptible they need
a warning label on every in a soda
saying latinos
you will get sick from this
because they will and they do and i have
to take care of them
so where's the label
and finally parents patriot the state is
the parent how the mississippi attorney
general sued big tobacco
because the state is more than a nominal
party they stand to lose they stand to
lose big
they're losing
1.5 billion dollars for diabetes in the
state of california every year
there's no requirement for tort
liability for parents patrioti all we
have to do is show the economic harm and
that the state's not a nominal party
which is easy to do
we could recoup medicaid for cost
diabetes and possibly other diseases as
well because for diabetes we have
proximate cause we can prove it
so for further reading i will address uh
direct you to all sorts of academic
papers and more academic papers and oh
and then non-academic
uh missives fat chance which you can
purchase today this will be out in
six days september 3rd it's an e-book
that people can use to go into the store
and use it to shop properly because it
lists the added sugars in each food in
the supermarket sugar has 56 names a
shopper's guide and finally in january
we'll be releasing the fat chance
cookbook because in order to turn this
around people are going to have to learn
how to cook again
and the question is how do they do that
and what is it they're going to make and
how do they do it fast
well every one of these recipes was
vetted by a mount diablo high school
student and if they can make it in less
than a period so can you
and they're good
so and lastly we have started a
non-profit organization to provide
medical nutritional and legal analysis
and consultation to promote personal and
public health
versus big food
called the institute for responsible
nutrition responsiblefoods.org
come
join sign up okay we'll let you know
what's going on and you can contact me
for more information and with that i
want to thank all of my collaborators at
ucsf and at uc hastings
in particular david marsha john diamond
pat davidson here in the audience and
also my colleague sanjay basu who did
the heavy lifting on the statistics on
the diabetes study that i showed you
laura schmidt and claire brendas at the
ucsf ctsi and kristen kearns who is the
person who is basically doing the sugar
documents in the same way as the tobacco
documents and stan glance who is mr
anti-tobacco and has realized that
non-communicable disease whatever it be
okay is the problem of the 21st century
we need to solve it and we're going to
need all of you in the room
to get on board and help us do it with
that i want to thank you all and i'll be
happy to answer
[Applause]
just questions us a few minutes with
questions if you have questions you can
make your way over to the microphone
[Music]
every i i answered everyone's questions
that's pretty bad
i'm happy happy to answer any questions
okay
all right
thanks go ahead regardless
uh many questions
go for it try and limit it uh to a
couple
um
so the the last uh
the last piece of information you shared
with regards to
latinos and
in a higher likelihood of metabolic
disease
given exposure i'm wondering if you
could um
talk a little bit more about
about what we know about that or where
we can find more information about that
we do have a community group here in san
francisco
um
interested in and health equities
impacting the latino community
absolutely who um who wants more
information with regards to ssb's i gave
a talk uh two years ago at the latino
health forum on exactly this question
roberto and it's a huge problem
especially here in san francisco
what we know is that
sugar gets converted to liver fat but
there are certain things that go on in
the liver that can make that worse
there is a gene called pnp la3 potatin
like
phospholipase a3 that's not important
it's just it's a gene and if you have a
certain polymorphism it's the gg
polymorphism which 19 of latinos have
19
a little sugar makes a lot of liver fat
way more than if you have or
heterozygous or homozygous for the wild
type in addition there's another
polymorphism for another gene called
cert iii sir two and three which is one
of the
molecules that helps the mitochondria
function properly and if you have a
polymorphism in that which latinos also
carry
you are going to you're not going to be
able to put enough energy through the
mitochondria which means that the backup
is going to get turned into liver fat as
well so both of these
are known risk factors for developing
non-alcoholic fatty liver disease which
is a proxima cause of type 2 diabetes
and latinos are particularly susceptible
the point is that latinos of all
different denominations and ethnicities
have to be careful about their sugar
consumption
the fact is that latinos are the least
careful about their sugar consumption
they don't even drink water
they drink agua fresca
right they have more names for sugared
beverages
in spanish than virtually you know there
are in english and i actually composed a
list of it and it uh published it in um
in the journal of pediatric astronomy
and nutrition back in 2012. it's pretty
ridiculous you know rompope uh
chomperado uh you know i mean and the
list goes on it's really pretty uh uh
astounding
and you know kids they tell us they tell
us you know they drink it because it
tastes good
well yeah i know
but this doesn't mean it's good for you
and
we have a real hard time convincing uh
parents latino parents of the hazards of
uh this practice
so we have a lot of work to do thank you
and i know there are folks working on
that locally
um and we have a lot of work to do
one more question since uh
there aren't there isn't anyone else at
the mic yet but uh so
and i should introduce myself my name is
roberto vargas i work at uh
the clinical and translational science
institute's community engagement and
health policy program at ucsf
uh the other question is with regards to
differential pricing you pointed to the
example in the nordic countries
subsidization of uh subsidizing beer
heavy taxes on alcohol do we have any
other examples of that has there ever
has there been any testing of that with
regards to sugar sweetened beverage no
there's been no testing of that with
respect to ssbs at all anywhere that i
know of
what i can say is that there is one
study that was out of peter ben brigham
hospital at harvard where they changed
the price in the hospital cafeteria to
see whether or not they could get people
off sugar sweetened beverages and they
had to change the price significantly
we are about to embark on a study at
ucsf that dan henry head of food
services at ucsf is a uh
is the principal investigator on where
we're going to basically try to do the
same thing in the hospital setting which
is very different than you know a
general setting
but um you know hospitals have to start
this you know the bottom line is you
know it used to be that people smoked in
hospitals you know and now they don't in
fact hospitals were the first places to
ban smoking entirely and uh we'll
probably have to be the first people
first uh places to ban uh sugar
sweetened beverages entirely too thank
you
hi rob can you just say a little
few words about the reversibility of the
condition so for instance what's the
duration of exposure to put a child at
risk and let's say they you know stopped
their
um soda consumption when they turned in
you know the age of 20. you know
non-smokers or smokers will ultimately
go back to the risk for lung cancer over
many years what happens to children
right so so there are two issues surely
there's the there's the non-alcoholic
fatty liver disease issue and then
there's the diabetes issue
so the non-alcoholic fatty liver disease
issue
if it's just fatty liver it's eminently
reversible
it can take time but it's eminently
reversible we are doing a study at ucsf
right now that i'm the co-pi on where we
are iso calorically taking
sugar away and substituting complex
carbohydrate iso isocalorically for 10
days
i'm blinded to the results so i can't
give you the answer to that but
we anticipate that we will reverse their
fatty liver disease during that period
of time because we have data in adults
that 14 days of doing the same thing
did uh was effective 38 reduction in
liver fat
during that time now
if you have
sorry what's the duration of exposure
that would bring about fatty liver in a
in a child oh two weeks
two weeks two weeks absolutely two weeks
if you did heavy heavy drinking
of drinking of soda or soda yep
you would get it in two weeks and you
get it in uh in in
in alcohol too huh oh that would be like
three sodas a day
three sodas a day will get you there
um
in terms of the
scarring that occurs the cirrhosis once
that occurs that never gets better so
once you go from fatty liver to fatty
liver plus inflammation that never
improves that's five percent of the
patients with fatty liver they go on to
develop cirrhosis over time now you can
slow it down
by getting rid of the substrate and by
using antioxidants
but it's a progressive lesion from that
point on which will ultimately either
kill you or require a liver transplant
now diabetes
is eminently reversible type 2 diabetes
is eminently reversible in most patients
the problem is not with our current diet
but people who go on the paleo diet
see all of their medications go you know
uh
you know
they don't need their medications within
like eight weeks of starting a paleo
diet once they actually change uh their
diet in their dietary composition
so i i think that diabetes is eminently
uh reversible
if you do the right thing
doctor let's say uh during the
role of
ethnic communities in ethnic communities
which i don't disagree with
what plans do you have for say
translations into other languages and be
able to make it accessible too right
well the thing that i'm most upset about
is that there's no spanish version of
fat chance
and i if anybody here is a spanish
language publisher come talk to me
we have tried to get
various publishers interested in
publishing a spanish language version
and there are all sorts of uh
problems with that i mean we're it's
it's in norway it's in slovenia it's in
turkey it's in um
new zealand it's in korea uh it's in the
uk in australia that's you know that's
english um it's in a lot of countries
but it's not in latin america and it's
not here and it's not mexico and the
reason is because no spanish language
publisher has picked it up and i cannot
tell you why
so i don't know i mean i can't publish
the book i mean it's copyrighted i can't
publish the book myself
i need somebody to do it for me
but that would be really good we have
all sorts of materials that we hand out
in our clinic
that are in spanish language very
specifically because that's the audience
that needs it and we work very hard to
try to make sure that they get the
message but you know the bottom line is
we don't go home with them
you know there they ultimately do what
they do we do the best we can but as i
told you education has never fixed any
substance of abuse
thank you very much dr lester the
last comment you made education's not
fixed an addiction abuse uh situation so
in a stressful society uh sugar serves a
role it's satisfying it's comforting and
triggers dopamine yeah and so i'm
curious about that um
is there any possibility of creating no
if you're going to take something away
what are you going to give them
absolutely this is this is
this is like the the holy grail the 64
000 question
if you take something away that gives
pleasure
won't they search for something else
pleasurable instead could it possibly be
that they would substitute something
even more dangerous in its place might
they go back to smoking might they go to
cocaine etc these are very very
concerning and very worrisome issues
and i don't know the answer to that i do
know that something has to be done about
this because we can't afford the health
care
that's associated with this so this is
an unsustainable model
now if you think about what happened
with tobacco let's talk about tobacco
for a minute as sort of the flip side of
that
when did
smokers
die
average age 64. that's what the
actuarial analysis from metlife said the
average age was 64.
well you know what happens at 64.
you pay in to medicare you pay in to
social security
and you die and you don't get anything
out this was actually a sustainable
model in addition
when you got lung cancer
how long did you have before you were
dead
six months
so how much money could you spend out of
your health care dollars
in six months of lung cancer
not that much
so
you paid in
you didn't get out and you didn't cost
society a whole lot
now we don't smoke or we've cut down
smoking significantly at least by half
so what are we doing instead addiction
transfer we have chosen
an addiction which seems safe
except that it's not and worse yet it's
causing adolescent type 2 diabetes and
these patients are going to be sick
for 20 30 40 years before they're dead
and their productivity is going to be
nil and they're going to chew through
all the health care resources of this
country
and they're not going to be productive
they're going to be on the dole
because they won't be able to work
so mike the question is
is this a better model than what we had
before what i say is let's get everybody
smoking again
so then so then i say that
tongue-in-cheek
so you've said that education alone
would not work but right but maybe some
like pricing policy or something more
hard
plus an educational model right with
that oh absolutely i think you need for
every substance of abuse
we have needed both personal
intervention which for lack of a better
word we can call rehab and we need
societal intervention which for lack of
a better word we can call laws
for every substance of abuse we've
needed both rehab and laws rehab and
laws that's what we have for alcohol
that's what we have for nicotine that's
what we have for cocaine that's what we
have for heroin etc etc rehab and laws
for sugar which meets all the criteria
and i've shown you how
we have nothing
so the question is how are we going to
do that in order to salvage our health
care system
that's the big question
your point is absolutely it's the holy
grail what's going to happen if we
actually reduce sugar consumption if
that's
a
matter of pleasure now i'm going to say
one thing though on that on that subject
remember tolerance
down regulation of the dopamine receptor
if you reduce consumption what happens
to those dopamine receptors
they go back up you know what you get
more pleasure
so is it conceivable that we could find
a peaceful coexistence with sugar that
would ultimately
provide the pleasure
that you're asking about and still
keep our health care costs down that i'm
talking about and i would say the answer
to that is almost assuredly yes yeah and
so one of the educational aspects is
what is the nature of pleasure opioids
endorphins oxytocins how do we
self-generate those molecular structures
in our body to create behavioral states
right and and training that within our
education on a societal issue so that's
part of it is because it's the the
anatomy and physiology of medicine but
also law i think that's the question for
the legal issue is you know what is
responsibility what is self-generation
of behavior itself from a legal
perspective this is the this is the
new
ethics of
health care is how do you balance
the you know personal responsibility
against societal uh needs and you know
that's why i went to law school was for
exactly that you know public health law
pat davidson sitting right here i mean
jacobsen v massachusetts 1905.
you know there was this pastor in
cambridge massachusetts who refused to
get vaccinated for smallpox
said it was a religious objection the
supreme court said too bad
you live here you're getting vaccinated
tough luck
and you know the bottom line is
there is a point at which every personal
responsibility issue becomes a public
health one
and the question is where's the line and
what are the legal doctrines that govern
the crossing over of that line
i would submit to you that we have
surpassed that for this problem yet we
have not enacted any societal
interventions
that are meaningful to try to fix it
that's what needs to change
thank you dr elastic
um i was wondering if you could speak a
little bit to uh other disease in
addition to obesity uh such as
autoimmune disease and well
autoimmune disease is a real grab back
okay and i'm going to tell you
this is being televised is being taped
and i'm about the science and the
science on autoimmune disease is still
very much an open question so i'm a
little loath to sort of tell you how all
of this might tie into autoimmune
disease other than to say people are
working on it and i'm very interested in
it but i'm certainly not willing to you
know go
go public on it not until we actually
have hard science so i'm going to have
to sort of beg the question right now
sorry
thank you dr elastic i just wanted to
make one brief comment about the
idea of
um if you're taking something away what
are you giving if you're taking sugar
away what's the reward that replaces
that i have a very small sample by the
way i've never said take it away oh sure
just said reduce the exposure reduce
availability right to a manageable level
so i've never said take it away a lot of
people say i say that i've never said
that thank you so don't put words in my
mind thank you so if we would heavily
reduce the availability or reduce the
exposure to added sugars right
in a very small sample size that i have
mostly of middle-aged midwesterners in
the united states i can say that one of
the main rewards that
these people are getting in a health
education program i'm running on this
exact topic
is reduction in when you reduce your
waistline circumference people start to
notice yeah and you start getting a lot
of compliments and people really really
respond to that and it keeps them going
so i know that behavior is not the only
uh behavior modification isn't the only
answer but it's one piece when people
start to be rewarded by observation and
i can speak from
being a midwesterner myself and seeing a
lot of people in this
area of the country and and this age
group specifically respond very well to
that
i don't i don't disagree with you at all
my mother had a famous saying a minute
on your lips forever on your hips i know
i got it i got i got that a long time
ago
okay and still i'm i you know that's the
way it goes okay the bottom line is
you can only
change your behavior
if the environment allows for it
when six hundred thousand food items
have eighty percent
uh adulteration by added sugar it's
awfully hard to change your behavior in
a toxic environment the toxic
environment has to improve in order for
you to be able to manifest those changes
in behavior that's what i would say and
mostly to sustain them over time yes
absolutely yeah that's all thank you
um
so that's all the time we have i'd like
to remind you and i think rob will stick
around a little bit
to sign his book and make it available
to you
and finally i would just like to thank
rob for just a fantastic thank you
let me answer your questions you're
talking about like litigation yeah
now a conversation on the role of the
sugar industry in hawaiian history we'll
talk with gregory rosenthal who teaches
history at the state university of new
york at stony brook
gregory rosenthal a professor at suny
stony brook a native of upstate new york
and somebody who is studying the
hawaiian sugar trade how did that all
come about
well i did grow up in upstate new york
and live in new york city now and
originally this project
the first idea i was going to study
native americans in upstate new york
where i grew up and look at
native relationships with the
environment because my training is as an
environmental historian and then
that morphed in that going way back in
undergraduate as a college student i
studied abroad in china and i studied
chinese history and mandarin and i
thought is there a way i can bridge
these two things together my interest in
indigenous people's history
environmental history also the pacific
world
and so i changed my project after
starting and said i basically looked at
a map of the pacific and i looked at
what's between china and the united
states and right in the middle is hawaii
and there's indigenous history there
there's labor history there's
environmental history there's a
trans-pacific history and i thought
here's here's where i want to put my put
my project into this seems like an
incredible place to do this well let's
talk about all of that but let's start
with the issue of sugar which is such a
basic commodity
not only in our
society today but in our history yeah
that's right and one of the interesting
things about hawaiian history
many people today know that the sugar
plantations are a big part of hawaiian
history and in fact when you go to
hawaii today and you see a lot of people
of asian descent particularly chinese
japanese filipino etc all of those
migrant peoples came in the late 19th
century early 20th century originally
people today their grandparents their
great grandparents to work on the
plantations and so the heart of hawaiian
labor history and the environment is
about those plantations so sugar
plantations so in my project what i'm
doing though is looking at native
hawaiian workers on the plantation we're
often forgotten often left out of those
stories
it's seen usually that
a lot of these euro-americans from the
united states had come to hawaii and
wanted to start plantations and they
looked around and said where's the labor
where's the workers
and so imported
asian contract workers and others so in
my work i'm trying to look at native
hawaiian workers though who worked in
the in the sugar industry
but you're right sugar is a global
commodity and of course when it comes to
hawaii it's coming with a lot of
knowledge expertise technology
and ideas that have been fostered
already in the caribbean sugar uh sugar
trade for centuries and so there's a
connection there too from coming from
the caribbean to hawaii what processes
changed which ones uh which ones were
kept the same during that transformation
why is that climate the climate in
hawaii and in the pacific and the asian
countries so conducive to sugar itself
yeah um that's a great question actually
so in sugar you know in hawaii for
example sugar is brought to hawaii by
the native hawaiians who first come to
hawaii well over a thousand years ago is
one of the so-called canoe plants uh one
of the
scores of plants and some domesticated
animals that polynesian peoples brought
with them from island to island to
island to island over thousands of years
so sugar is in the dna of native
hawaiian culture they brought it with
them and brought it to hawaii and
planted it
so it's within that tropical belt
that sugar
is indigenous i mean in this case when
we talk about the indigeneity of the
cane itself
hawaiian brought it from south pacific
and it originally goes back to southeast
asia
but somehow through these
migrations and then especially as we
come into the age of global capitalism
we see sugar get brought basically
anywhere and to wherever it can be
planted and produced most cheaply right
but that tropical band around the world
is is the heart of where sugar is
produced walk us through then the
development of the need for labor in
hawaii and how that all came about
yeah so
in my larger project i'm looking at
native hawaiian workers basically the
rise in the fall of the native hawaiian
men as as labor in hawaii and in fact
going all the way back to when captain
cook
took all discovered hawaii in the 1770s
it was very clear from that moment on
that hawaii was not so much a source it
was not seen originally so much as a
source of here's a great fertile land
that we can develop plantations on for
the first century so it was look at
these people
look at these strong-bodied uh skilled
workers skilled in oceanic activities
fishing boating
that kind of thing skilled in
agriculture
and so hawaiian labor was seen as this
great asset
all around the pacific
by ships from america from england from
russia all around the world they came in
and they got
hawaiian workers but depopulation was a
huge issue there the epidemic diseases
that were brought by cook and then
brought by others
decimated the hawaiian population down
from several several hundreds of
thousands of hawaiians to
by the 1870s so about 100 years later
below 50 000 indigenous hawaiians still
alive
so
when the sugar plantation started to
grow and this is really in the 18
the second half of the 19th century and
particularly after 1875
and 1876
this is when the first binational treaty
is signed between the united states and
the kingdom of hawaii which removes the
tariffs on hawaiian sugar basically open
creates a free trade environment where
hawaiian sugar can flow into the united
states
at that time the planters realized the
indigenous population is now below 50
000
is about at that time maybe 3 000 or
less native hawaiian workers working the
plantations and when that free trade
bill
as i'll call it is signed um
at that time the planner said
you know we really need to break we need
more than 3 000 workers
and and though although there have been
experiments with chinese labor
experiments with foreign labor in the
50s 60s and 70s it's really after 1876
you see the floodgates open in the next
70 years or so about 25 000 chinese
coolies as they were called were brought
into hawaii um then an anti-chinese
paranoia takes hold there just as it did
in the united states in the 1880s with
the chinese exclusion act etc and hawaii
moves to japanese labor and then when
there's too many japanese and there's an
anti-japanese paranoia filipino there's
also portuguese puerto ricans workers
from all over the world are brought in
because of this belief that there's not
enough native labor to satisfy the needs
of an industry that now has a huge
market in the united states and wants to
expand beyond really what beyond the
labor and resources available in hawaii
so they have to bring that in from all
over the world in terms of the timeline
with all of this at what point did
hawaii become an american territory and
obviously subsequently after world war
ii in american state right so
there's a couple key moments here a lot
of historians look at that 1876 this
reciprocity treaty that binational
treaty as really the beginnings of the
u.s
intervention in at that stage the
economy of hawaii through that free
trade deal
but it becomes political within the next
20 years the 1890s in 1893 when a group
of
people of american descent in hawaii
overthrow the queen liliuokalani they
overthrow the kingdom and take power
they petitioned the united states to say
recognize us we've just overthrown this
kingdom and we want to be a part of the
united states in fact grover cleveland
who's president of the time says
no you guys did a bad thing we don't
sanction this um and there's in fact a
u.s fact-finding mission that goes to
the kingdom of hawaii is then the
republic of hawaii this break-off group
much like texas broke off it's the same
kind of thing
and um this fact-finding mission to the
united states finds that these americans
did a bad they they committed an act of
war as the fighting mission called it
and they say the kingdom of hawaii
should be restored
that doesn't happen these americans hold
on to power
1894 to 1898 and at that time there's a
new president mckinley
with expansionist dreams and the
spanish-american war has just begun and
the philippines which is a and guam
which are spanish territories out there
are now
in the target range of the united states
and they see this hawaiian territory as
a great asset so in those five years
there's this independent republic in
1898 the united states formally takes
over
hawaii it's 1959 then when hawaii
achieves statehood later
um
but you know so 1898 at that time the
sugar industry is king
and so when hawaii does become part of
the united states
besides the military
function of hawaii which continues from
the spanish-american war up till today
military is a huge part of what makes
hawaii tick and part of the economy and
part of the reason the u.s holds on to
hawaii so tightly
but besides that sugar industry was a
huge deal then
during that time period from the late
1890s through the early part of the 20th
century give us a sense of what hawaii
looked like the demographics of the
country
what honolulu was like just overall
paint a picture sure
the bulk of my research i look at hawaii
in the period before the u.s takes over
and i'm interested in when native
hawaiians are a majority of the
population that that will hold true from
the beginning of hawaiian settlement uh
over a thousand years ago up until about
the last two decades of the 19th century
1880s 1890s is when you're going to see
the native hawaiian population go from a
majority to a very small minority
because as i said tens of thousands of
chinese tens of thousands of japanese
immigrants
especially in the late 19th century
early 20th century then we see tens of
thousands of filipino immigrants
particularly because the philippines
becomes a u.s territory after the
spanish-american war after 1898 so that
creates a route for filipino migrants to
come to the sugar plantations also
thousands of puerto rican migrants which
a lot of people don't know as well come
to hawaii same thing puerto rico becomes
a u.s territory so it's sort of the u.s
creates this empire in 1898 it's
overseas empire
and creates all these new routes of
labor from the philippines from puerto
rico from hawaii to move amongst these
places and of course the sugar in it in
puerto rico as well
so you really start to see this this
large empire of sugar production and
migrant labor moving among these places
so by the time you get into the 20th
century you have
a very small quite oppressed native
population some of the rules that are
put in place very early in the in the
american colony there is to suppress the
hawaiian language
in the schools for example to make
everyone learn english etc
you have
a white population that is also a
minority and to this day is still a
minority today only about 20 some
percent of people in hawaii
identifies white
and so from 1900 to today what you have
demographically um is an asian majority
and today the the largest uh ethnic
group of people of japanese descent and
that was probably true even a hundred
years ago in the early 1900s as well by
that time the chinese which were the
first migrant workers brought in
they become a minority as well and it
really is a
japanese immigrant dominated
population for the last 100 years or so
your research has also included what is
called the big five and the missionary
role in all of this can you explain
yeah so well one family that a lot of
people know about the dole family we
know about dole fruit no pineapples
that's a fascinating story
which is not quite in the sugar but we
can use it as an analogy the pineapple
industry starts up right in the very
first years of the 1900s in fact you
know pineapple is not indigenous to
hawaii it's brought in and the idea of a
plantation style industry is built on
the foundation of sugar which is already
there the dole family we can trace back
to daniel dole
who is a missionary a christian
missionary from new england who came in
the early 19th century
he had two sons james dole worked in the
sugar industry i used his papers quite a
bit
in my research on sugar his other son
sanford dole became a judge and sanford
was one of the americans who helped
overthrow queen liliu kalani and took
power in fact he was elected the first
president of the republic of hawaii this
breakup group dominated by white
americans who took over and then when
the u.s took over in fact he was became
the first territorial governor
so he was the son of a missionary and
then he became the president and then
governor of this then u.s controlled
hawaii his cousin james dole was the
founder of dole pineapple company which
then became the dull corporation we know
today so the linkages between political
power
and the overthrow of the native kingdom
sanford's role as a judge first and then
as president governor and his
relationship with the old missionary
establishment who you know a lot of the
the saying about the missionaries is uh
they they came to do good and they did
very well
right um after that then you have this
cousin too james still who's able to
take advantage of his relationships with
that power nexus to build up the
pineapple empire right so sugar
pineapple these industries that actually
build up really on the coattails of
earlier americans who had came perhaps
with good intentions
but really had taken control of a lot of
the institutions of power as well
what is the dole family's connection
today to the company and to hawaii
politics if any
uh that's a good question something i i
don't i haven't really looked that much
into of course you can go on oahu today
if you go to central oahu there's a dole
pineapple kind of playground there
there's a historic site a tourist
attraction you can go to and learn more
about the dole pineapple history but
what that really is is um it's you know
i live in new york city and it's very
much like little italy in new york city
today there's not really that many
italians there anymore but they're
keeping it going as the sort of heritage
tourism industry that's very much what
sugar is in hawaii today if we want to
talk about the present legacy the last
sugar production facility in hawaii
closed down in the 1990s
and so today a lot of people still think
that there's hawaiian sugar
that's history
pineapple is history there's this dull
site there to commemorate the history
but there's no pineapples really being
grown anymore
a lot of the reason for this is the same
reason why these industries came to
hawaii in the first place is
globalization we talk about
globalization and outsourcing today and
we can see that dole i don't know dole
specifically for example but a lot of
these major multinational corporations
that produce sugar that produce
pineapples they want to find cheaper
labor they want to find a place with
less environmental regulations labor
regulations etc hawaii is no longer that
place but in fact those are the various
impulses in the late 19th century that
brought these industries to hawaii they
thought that they could
get the land cheaply if not outright
steal it they thought that they could
get cheap labor first from natives then
when natives resisted from asian workers
so linking these histories of
globalization together is actually quite
fascinating because we see that the
forces that brought these industries to
hawaii in the first place
in fact ironically i think the united
states taking over and u.s labor and
environmental regulations to this day
make it to the point where then these
corporations say and we don't want
hawaii anymore let's go somewhere else
where we can get cheaper labor and less
regulation well labor being an issue but
what about real estate as well because i
would imagine that that's a huge reason
why this land that was used for sugar
plantations now valuable real estate for
homes and other development
absolutely and you can see a lot of the
old plantations become resorts
and
resort communities sort of second home
communities that sort of thing
certainly economically hawaii today the
two big engines of the economy are the
military and tourism
um tourism you know in the 19th century
the period i study tourism is not really
a thing except for
quite elite adventurers who go off and
go around uh
you know people like herman melville who
he said i'm going to go on a whaling
boat and explore the pacific and then
write a bunch of books about it you know
he sort of has the privilege to go do
that sort of thing mark twain who goes
to hawaii and a lot of people read his
dispatches from hawaii sort of gentlemen
travelers in a sense but it's really the
cruise ships in the early 19th early
20th century that start to build up
places like waikiki places like that as
tourists uh
enclave serving a tourist community
but really it's just jet travel
1970s really 60s 70s when you start to
see the number of tourists coming hawaii
from the hundreds of thousands go up to
the what it is today i know several
several million tourists every year
and so in fact running a plantation and
growing these crops with such a
historical legacy doesn't make the same
money as building a resort and bringing
a tourist or building a gated community
of second homes that sort of thing have
you studied the environmental impact of
the sugar trade in hawaii over the years
and if so what have you learned um i
have been traced it into the 20th
century and it's the 21st century so
um
so i'm not sure what i can say about
that you know in the 19th century
the thing about plantations
i mean the environmental impact that i
look at with the onset of the
plantations is that basically this is
land where native hawaiians used to grow
kalo or taro it's land that they used to
uh
uh
live a subsistence lifestyle on the land
as the commons
in the 1840s a process known as the
mahele or the great division takes place
where the land is privatized and these
common lands that were shared by the
native hawaiian community are broken up
turned into private property and very
quickly within a few decades
the great majority fold over into the
hands of white people
and what happens with the rise of the
plantations environmentally that i look
at is that it it takes away the means of
living the means of production for
native peoples and in fact that's where
the labor comes from this
proletarianization as it as it is that
native hawaiians who used to be able to
grow their own food and live off the
land they find they start to get boxed
in on all sides by these huge
plantations and there's nowhere that
they can grow their own food and live
their own lifestyle anymore or they get
cut off
from the ocean or from the mountains or
from some other place where they used to
extract resources for for subsistence so
they forced them to sell their labor for
a wage
so that's the big environmental
transformation i look at there's
certainly probably our legacies that
go on into the 20th and 21st centuries
but the loss of the land itself
is the most
uh revolutionary environmental
transformation i think because it means
for native people it's
it's very much the land is swept out
under their feet and they're forced to
become workers
and so many of them forced to move away
to find work
and it's part of the dissolution of sort
of native hawaiian control over hawaii
where does most of our sugar come from
today who processes it
that's a good question i mean i think if
you look at a lot of the products that
we eat today
most of the sweetener it comes from corn
i mean most things are sweetened with
corn syrup and michael pollan has
written very elegantly about this in his
book omnivore's dilemma there's this
whole chapter about everything is corn
even the plastics we use the sweetener
foods
he says over 50 of everything in our
lives is made out of corn
that's a whole nother history about u.s
subsidies to the corn industry and so on
but sugar you can still get cane sugar
but it's not coming from hawaii
and i haven't checked the labels so
that's something we you know we should
do and viewers can do is check the label
on their cane sugar and see where it's
coming from
but very unlikely that it's coming from
any part of the united states you may or
may not know this question but how much
sugar is in a candy bar that we purchase
or is that artificial sweetener
that's a good question too i would guess
that it's probably corn syrup solids or
something like that it might be cane
sugar
and it's a lot i mean the thing about
sugar the great book to read about sugar
is sidney mintz's spoke sweetness and
power sort of a classic statement about
sugar and he looks at the idea of
sweetness itself as this kind of
defining agent this force that pushes
the history of sugar that pushes the
rise of african slavery in the caribbean
right that pushes all of these links it
all goes back to the fact
the period he looks at which is this
links between the caribbean and england
it goes back to the fact that sugar is
addictive and these english consumers of
tea this is how sugar was mostly
consumed in the colonial well what we in
the united states call the colonial
period at the early modern period the
17th century the 18th century in england
and then increasingly in america too
right we had the boston tea party which
was about
this addiction to tea and sugar too
um
both in america and the year and both in
america and in england people drank tea
with
you know one lump or two with sugar
that
addiction to sweetness that addiction of
sugar fostered
african slavery in the caribbean it
fostered in the 19th century
in some ways the conquest of hawaii and
certainly the demographic mix-up and
change of hawaii and the loss of native
power there
this addiction of sugar and sweetness
if we trace it out around the world
has has caused the rise and fall of
peoples and land lost and land stolen
and workers exploited and
lands degraded all around the world it's
a really really
powerful thing like a drug
that
pushes pushes history forward and so i
think i think actually more attention to
this issue of why are we so addicted to
sugar and why do we allow
our love of sugar to push these these
global changes is a really important
question that goes beyond our
conversation as historians it goes to a
moral question as people as global
citizens uh how can we how can we
sweeten our food without exploitating
others in other places around the world
which brings me back to my opening
question and my concluding question now
is you're gathered here with historians
here in atlanta at the organization of
american historians why is this such a
passion for you personally
and in your research what has surprised
you the most
yeah history i didn't think history was
my passion i got a bachelor's degree in
music when i was in college and i took
one history class in four years of
college um
but i've always been interested in going
to historic sites and i think that's
actually an important
aspect of what's going on here at this
conference as well
it's not just academic university-based
historians here but public historians
too who are at museums historic sites
public institutions
etc that's actually where i got my start
uh working at a little house museum in
upstate new york
and i realized that history is something
that that's not just interesting to
historians
everyone is interested in history
when i worked at the house museum
everyone
had an interest they had a passion they
had a question and today in new york
city i also gave walking tours
on the side and i love meeting people
who want to learn about new york city
history
who are not historians but history
matters to them um
it helps them understand who they are
and who we are
as a people
and so i find it's an incredible line of
work
to work in to do history
in that it's something that
i think inspires everyone
and i do think everyone feels like it's
part of their life it's part of their
story
uh their grandparents are immigrants
from somewhere
their dad used to work in a factory
that's now closed down and understanding
how those waves and flows of people and
economies and goods and processes
changed over time and how the world's
connected helps us all better understand
ourselves and the way we relate to each
other so i think it's important work
we're doing
professor gregory rosenthal who teaches
at suny stony brook in long island
appreciate you being with us here on
c-span 3's american history tv thank you
robert strauss was an aide to president
lyndon johnson chairman three
this week on lectures in history robert
paulette of southern illinois university
city edwardsville talks about caribbean
sugar and its role in the development of
britain's atlantic colonies especially
ideas of race and slavery in the 1600s
he focuses on the island of barbados and
argues that the rise of race-based
slavery was driven by the desire for
economic profits
because the island was dedicated almost
solely to sugar production inhabitants
had to rely on other colonies for
necessities like food and wood
his class is about an hour and 10
minutes
all right so right everyone everyone got
a free packet of sugar right for
stepping in the door here uh and you
know y'all don't seem particularly
grateful for this
uh
i wanted to hand this out right as a
kind of a lesson of
set us up for this lecture thinking
about right how we're still connected to
the past
right to do what i had just done which
is to hand out probably maybe a quarter
cups worth of sugar
uh to people that you know i don't
you know
that aren't my close personal friends i
like you all very much don't get me
wrong right but to do that right just to
hand out like a quarter cups worth of
sugar if this was the middle ages in
europe that would have been an
incredibly extravagant gift
right
sugar
back in the 1300s right when we when
this class started
was a very rare and expensive good it
was treated as a medicine
it was prized and was available only to
the richest of the rich in western
europe
so to hand out this small amount that i
just gave you
would have been seen as an extravagant
gift
but today right sugar's so common it's
so everywhere it's so much a part of our
diets right that it's nothing right you
can go into a gas station and
grab a handful and just take it with you
right i paid for these um but
uh sugar is so cheap it's so common that
it's
it's tougher now to avoid sugar right
than it is to get it
does anyone here for various reasons
ever had to like give up refined sugar
for dietary or medical reasons
how easy was that
right it's really hard it's it's in a
lot of stuff it's in everything stuff
you wouldn't expect it like medicines
and pills right it's everywhere
um
and
how this came to be how it went from
being this rare and expensive good
to being this thing that was so common
it's so hard to avoid
right this gets us to the heart of the
class too
because the story of sugar's development
as this commodity from being a rare and
expensive good to being something that
everyone had access to
was tied very closely to the
colonization of the americas
and to the development of slavery in the
new world
so this little good right that we don't
think much about
was actually part of a massive
reorganization of all the cultures of
the atlantic ocean that bordered on the
atlantic ocean
so that's what we're talking about today
right is the history of sugar in the
americas and it gets us to
not just where the food stuff came from
but gets us into
some really significant questions
because
sugar was
one of the main motors of the slave
trade in americas
75
of all africans brought to the americas
in the 1600s were brought to areas where
they were growing and making sugar
it was a huge business
it was some scholars argue
the first industrial enterprise uh in
the western world
so this tiny little thing this little
sweet stuff in these packets here uh
right has a very very significant
history and that's what we're talking
about today
and right
it has a lesson in just how
boring evil can be right when we think
about slavery we think about as one of
these great evils in history
the people at the time did not see it in
that way
it was made out of thousands of tiny
decisions that made lots of sense
that added up created this institution
of slavery in the americas
all right so what
focusing on sugar focusing specifically
on the english caribbean because this is
a
course in
uh english colonial history in united
states history uh
and so we're talking about
sugar but we're talking about
much more than that because without this
commodity without this development
without the caribbean
the shape of north american history
meaning here on the mainland would be
very different
too and just to kind of give us a sense
of what's
the scale right
you sort of chart a timeline here with
the colonies right so we start in 1607
with the english plant jamestown right
and chesapeake bay right and so english
colonies in the new world right there's
just that one
and then after
20 or so 30 years of experimentation
right there's been some expansion
our puritans have settled new england
have expanded out from massachusetts bay
to form new colonies
a second tobacco county has been founded
next door to virginia and maryland
and the english seeking right colonial
ventures seeking opportunities for
investment in colonial wealth the things
we've talked about in this class right
they've tried other experiments focusing
particularly on
uninhabited small islands in the
caribbean so you have a few colonies
being
formed on these small volcanic places
these small volcanic islands mostly in
the lesser antilles on the eastern edge
of the caribbean sea
60 years later
england hasn't really expanded that
dramatically in the caribbean they've
conquered jamaica which is no small
prize and that's certainly true
but when we look at the mainland of
north america
we've seen a rapid explosion of colonies
along the east coast of north america
right 12 of the famous 13 colonies have
been founded by this point
and are being developed rapidly
and it's why sugar is so important
because the development of the east
coast of north america is tied closely
to what's going on in the caribbean
as these tiny islands
slightly less tiny in the case of
jamaica become developed become planted
become home to these massive
sugar-producing plantations
uh owned by the english
the east coast of north of north america
develops as a kind of support system
to these caribbean islands
so traditionally in an american history
class we just we just focus on this part
of the map up here
but by doing that we lose
some very important information about
what's happening down here that's
pushing the history
in those places so again sugar seems
trivial today it seems unimportant it
doesn't seem like much a big deal but
the history of sugar particularly
english sugar
right it's tied closely to
everything we do today
history of how we do things in the
history of the country we live in today
all right
so these little islands here right have
a big influence
in things particularly if we focused in
on right uh the island of
barbados down here which will be the
main focus of today's lecture
almost impossible to see on this map
right we zoom in
still pretty hard to see
we zoom in further right and we've got
this little cluster of greenish pixels
here in the middle of this digital map
all right that's the island of barbados
uh
tough to spot right from a satellite
view
not terribly large right the island of
barbados about 170 square miles that's
less than one-fourth the size of madison
county illinois where we are right now
but this tiny island has a majorly large
influence
on the shape of england's empire in the
english atlantic
all right
and so all of that right driven by sugar
questions before we
jump in
the mic is open
there's more sugar in it for you if you
like
all right
all right so let's catch up right with
the history of sugar prior to the
english settlement of barbados right so
right we've talked in this class about
how sugar was a rare and expensive good
we talked about it way back in the day
and we talked about early portuguese
expansion into the atlantic in the 1400s
so portugal had tapped into this
european love of sugar right and sugars
are you know sugar is an easy thing to
love it's sweet it tastes good it makes
other foods taste better
it gives you a jolt of energy that you
miss when it's gone right it's a very
addictive substance so sugar right
there's a reason people wanted it so
much uh it tastes good uh and it gives
you that buzz
so portugal had tapped into this right
uh expanding sugar right it the crop had
originally developed uh in south asia
had come west through various trading
networks most european sugar in the
middle ages came from the eastern
mediterranean
portugal sort of gets this technology
expands it onto the island of madera and
then the 1500s
takes the sugaring technology it's
developed and expands it even further to
the coast of brazil down here at the
bottom of the map
and
as part of this trade network right the
portuguese it also innovated other
things tapping into west african slave
trading networks to provide
a source of labor for its sugar growth
not the only source of labor
but an important one and so
this is what's happening to sugar right
between 1500 and 1600 this slow
expansion through portuguese trade
networks
and throughout the 1500s the portuguese
had expanded and innovated and invested
in sugar and developed a basic set of
techniques for producing it improved
upon older techniques
uh improved upon meaning you know in
terms of production capacity and all of
that
and so the system the portuguese has
developed right this is a later image
but shows the basic technologies that
the portuguese had developed in the
1500s
and hopefully looking at this we're
already getting a sense that
growing sugarcane is one thing making
sugar is another
to take the raw cane juice that grows in
sugarcane that plant that was on the
slide when you first walked in
and to turn it into crystalline sugar to
turn it into the stuff in these little
packets right this is a very elaborate
science
right to to
refine that juice and turn it into
crystallized sugar right you go to a
sugar refinery now looks like an oil
refinery right it's a massive thing
smoke stacks everywhere turning raw
juice into
uh crystalline sugar
and so this was right uh
all based upon right this is the 25th
you know the sugar refine is a 2015
version of what the portuguese had begun
developing so growing sugar cane fairly
easy right uh it's a grass that grows
well in tropical climates first
developed in the southern parts of asia
you plant it in the field and it grows
fairly easily on its own as long as you
keep the rats from rawing on it
but the thing about sugarcane is it has
a 14 to 16 month growing cycle so you
can't plant it anywhere that gets frost
otherwise the plant won't come to
maturity
but anywhere where you don't have any
frost right tropical climates it grows
very well and grows relatively easily
the trick with sugar right is taking the
raw juice out of that plant and turning
it into something that people want to
eat
and this is what the portuguese innovate
uh
building upon older technologies
right so the processing right this is
what we're seeing here in this
uh engraving
right a sign of how important sugar was
to europeans that they would take time
to engrave right and show
the actual manufacturing of it right
they were interested in the technology
of it interested in as an enterprise
right so the process of making sugar
right that's shown here
on this slide right so right back here
we have the sugar cane growing and these
nice tall rose back here it's being cut
the thing about sugar cane is once
you've cut it you've got about two or
three hours to harvest the juice
otherwise the stalk will dry up
and it's no more good to you you've
grown it for nothing
so once it's cut you got to rush it
immediately to some sort of crushing
mill to squeeze the juice out of it and
this is the big portuguese innovation
here
this vertical roller mill you see here
these three cylinders are just big
wooden trunks basically that are very
tightly pushed together
they roll against each other
you feed the stalk of sugarcane into it
right and the wood crushes out the juice
that runs down a little trough
and then the hard work begins this is
already hard work hard physical work
but the really tricky part begins
uh when you actually have to start
refining it
and there's a development right of just
boiling this raw juice over increasingly
smaller increasingly hotter fires and at
each stage you remove certain kinds of
impurities from the cane juice
and so as you boil it right
this is all supervised in the 16th and
17th century by a very skilled
tradesperson called the boiler
and this person is sort of like a master
chef
that's the kind of skill level we're
talking about someone who can see the
juice bubbling
can skim off the impurities leave the
good stuff behind and then knows the
exact right moment when that juice has
to go from one kettle to the next it's a
very tricky thing
and knows the exact right moment when
the sugar is as refined as it's going to
be but before it's burned then you take
it off the last fire and leave it to
cool
so this is
a labor-intensive process to make this
it requires
massive amounts of labor you've got to
have people running cane from the field
to the mills you gotta have people and
animals turning the mills
constantly during harvest season you
have to have people cutting firewood and
stoking the fires to keep these kettles
burning because once that cane is cut it
has to move fast you can't take a break
and you have to have people hauling you
know sugar from place to place juice
from place to place and so this is a
very labor intensive business
and it's around the clock
endeavor
and then
once it's all done it cools down and
after all of this work right all this
juice all this boiling the end result is
you have
basically a loaf of sugar
one third of which has too much molasses
in it so you can't use that one third of
it is just kind of foamy and kind of
dirty and you've got one pound of good
raw sugar
right in the middle of it that then has
to be refined again to turn into white
sugar
the molasses you take and you convert it
and you distill it you make rum out of
it um just to kind of recoup a little
bit of money out of the waste products
but here you go
this is sugaring on the brazilian coast
as it's developed and throughout the
1500s we get
more and more towards this kind of
system
so two things should jump out to us
about this right now
is that one you need a lot of labor to
make this happen
and two
this is a complicated technology for the
1500s and the 1600s
this is not cheap to build it's not
cheap to maintain you have to have
people that know how to make this kind
of machinery
in order to make it all work so it's
expensive to start a sugar operation
but europeans love their sugar so much
right that people will pay enough to
justify all these expenses maybe sort of
down the way
so while cane is easy to grow the mills
needed large labor forces
right and i don't want to make it sound
like the cane is
i don't want to diminish the work of the
field labors right this is hot heavy
work working out in fields you know
uh planting and harvesting king
um so i guess
it's simple but not easy maybe that's a
better way of putting it but you need
boilers and distillers you need people
to build and maintain mills you need
carpenters and masons uh and so it's
expensive right to create a sugar
plantation it's really pricey
you need a lot of land
you need a lot of labor
you need a lot of know-how you need a
lot of materials you need a lot of skill
right so there's not a lot of mom and
pop plantation operations popping up
here
and
what's developed in brazil because it's
so expensive to develop a plantation is
you have this kind of mixed
sugar economy in brazil
right the portuguese
individual portuguese
subjects in the 1500s very few of them
ever put together enough money to create
a total system
what happens in brazil is some people
have enough money to put together the
mills and they're sort of at the top
they own the mills
some people have enough money to have
some land and labor so they farm the
cane
other people
can't afford the land they work as
tenant farmers and you have the sort of
mixture of rich mill owners relatively
well-off landowners smaller free farmers
and then you have
a mixture of
slave labor from africa slave labor from
native americans and then some kind of
contract labor for native americans
making this all happen so while many of
the elements right of the modern
plantation system are being developed in
brazil
they're not being put together into a
total system yet
you have this mixture of medieval forms
modern forms medieval technologies of
labor modern technologies of sugar
making all kind of mixed together
but
once you take this basic technology of
sugar production and you insert it into
a different geography these small little
islands of the caribbean that the
english settle the dynamics change
enough
that a different country
with a different kind of resource
and a different level of investment
money
takes this stuff that's being slowly
developed in brazil and turns it
in a span of a couple of decades
into the modern plantation system as we
know it
and from that
launches
a rapid expansion of sugar development
and so now we move from brazil right
up to barbados get the english involved
here
because that's where we're heading
all right
so
the pre-sugar history of barbados
is going to sound very familiar because
it matches very much the history of
virginia and new england that we've
talked about already in class
you have these english companies of
investors looking for places to plant
colonies looking for places
to find resources to make money to
recoup their investments right so you
have small companies put together
expeditions to settle in the caribbean
thinking right they might grow something
useful or pirate some spanish stuff or
what have you but looking for something
in these
parts of the world that england can't
get
and so in the 1620s these various
companies settle a number of these small
islands
and barbados
is just one amongst these
barbados was
in the long run
one of the most successful ones and this
has to do with basically barbados which
is kind of stuck out
uh from the edge of everything it wasn't
occupied by anyone at least the time the
english settled there
no native americans lived there no
french or spanish lived there it was
just a
volcanic rock covered in rain forest and
the english plant there
right
looking for right an unoccupied space
they move in
uh and you know there wasn't a whole lot
inviting about the colony except the
fact that it was in tropical climate it
looked like it would grow stuff right
you got a rain forest as a sign that the
soils are fertile
and so for the first 20 years barbados
developed slowly it's a limited success
um
the company right
offers head rights they borrow from the
virginia system right there all these
colonies are learning from each other
they borrow the system of head rights
they offer land to people that will
settle in barbados english people come
they settle the island
and they slowly carve out small tobacco
farms from this rainforest
uh tobacco grows well in the west indies
the kind of tobacco that made virginia
successful was originally grown in the
caribbean
so great we got it good
uh cotton two certain strains of cotton
grow well and so great
and you develop these small farms
but they're not immensely profitable
um
you know
and a lot of this has to do with what's
going on virginia's already dominating
the tobacco economy
by the 1620s
and virginia's already overproducing
tobacco to the point where the price is
dropping right the virginia's already
starting to glut the market
the 1620. so there's not a lot of profit
in barbadian tobacco there's some some
people do all right
and
slowly right the settlers of barbados
create these small
okay
seeming farms right they import servants
to help them
farm their fields they get more head
rights they grow some tobacco and so we
have
some modest success in barbados
a few small farms carved out of the rain
forest slowly growing
and that's the arc that barbados is on
just looking like a marginal colony for
20 years
and then around 1640 right
all the forces of world history or at
least atlantic history combine
to create one very small but incredibly
significant event
which is that some dutch ships
come to barbados
from brazil
and bring the technology of how to make
sugar to the english right sugar's so
valuable the technology was very closely
guarded
and in sort of a early
version of corporate espionage some
dutch folks take the technology and
bring it to england
we won't go into detail right but this
involved world wars for this to happen
right uh it involved wars between
england and holland on one side and
spain and portugal on the other side and
during these wars the dutch basically
conquered everything portugal had built
they took over portuguese trading factor
trading posts in west africa they took
over the
sugar plantation districts of brazil for
a couple of decades and so through all
this war
the thing we want to focus on is that
the dutch bring
the technology of how to make sugar to
the english settlers of barbados
sometime around 16 40.
we're not totally clear on the date we
just know what happens somewhere around
them right it's one of the significant
events that no one really sat down and
recorded because it didn't seem like a
big deal at the time
but oh what a big deal it would become
because the technology alone was not
enough to change the island
but
bringing that technology to that english
space
links barbados in a different way to
england's wealth it links it in a
different way to capital networks it
links it in a different way to economics
so
i promised next last week we went and
talked about economics the entire class
that we need to know this right because
it's these
tiny little mundane economic decisions
that transform the island transform
slavery transform so much
of north america
because what happens when the technology
comes to barbados
is an investment opportunity is created
where one hadn't been before
the tobacco plantations of barbados they
weren't turning out enough profit that a
lot of people back in england were
thinking yeah let's invest our money
there
but when english people realize they've
got a space that can grow sugar
and they've got a space where they can
mill sugar
all of a sudden that's a prime
investment opportunity
and so what happens when this technology
comes to barbados
is that all the pieces come together
there's a settler class
right there's people on the island that
have established it as an english domain
uh you've got a small group of tobacco
farmers who've established credit and
connections back with england so
barbados has a reputation as a place
that can grow stuff and is relatively
secure
right it hasn't been burned the ground
by the spanish
in the past 20 years so it seems like a
relatively safe space for your money to
go
it's got access to this valuable
technology the portuguese had developed
now
and through the dutch
it's got access to
a west african source of labor right
it's tapped into these west african
slave markets
the portuguese and the dutch had been
developing
and now if you put all that together
with the most crucial ingredient of all
money
all of a sudden barbados explodes
right
not completely overnight
but it's still kind of amazing how
rapidly it happens
right it takes some time
but within 20 years
barbados has gone from this island with
a few small tobacco farms growing slowly
to the heart of an emerging modern
plantation complex dominated by rich
planters producing sugar on a scale
per acre that is hard to fathom
and in the process transforming the laws
attitudes ideas beliefs of english
people around the atlantic here
all right
so the process is slow but it happens
investors in england
buy up land in barbados right that's an
investment opportunity sugar growing
acreage that's valuable so they start
buying it up
knowing that they can grow it now and
mill it themselves
other investors build mills sometimes on
land they own sometimes on land just
build mill to process other people's
sugar cane juice
free inhabitants and servants right some
new immigrants come and take up land as
tenant farmers but they very quickly
kind of get pushed out
because these investors
putting money into the island
expect to see a return on that
investment
and and because of the geography of
barbados because of the nature of
investment because of the emerging
economy right this is
tied closely to the emerging
idea of capitalism
because of all these factors coming
together in such a small space
these investors then start pushing more
and more to accelerate the development
of slavery on the island
all right
because investment has a number of
effects
one of the first ones that land values
shoot up right people start buying up
all the land and there's not a whole lot
of land to begin with remember again
tiny island
right the values of the property shoot
up
so that
automatically the people that can afford
to buy acreage
see an increase in their wealth their
real estate holdings go up that's
important because that's money you can
borrow against
right that's a source of collateral it's
a source of credit
so
investment leads to more investment
right as people borrow against right the
value of their rising land
but
if the land values rise
there's an incentive
right
if you've spent
all of this money on some acreage in
barbados
you want to make sure you get enough
money out of it to cover that investment
so if the land is expensive you want to
get as much out of it as possible
you don't want to waste valuable acreage
with trees and wilderness or ducks or
whatever might be on that so right get
as much possible plant as much sugar as
possible the most valuable crop
in as many places as you can
so there's an incentive to maximize
production because of the nature of the
island
but and this is where the trap of
colonialism begins
no one had yet developed the idea of the
law of supply and demand but they were
feeling it right
uh
and what happens is as these people
plant more and more sugar grow more and
more sugar the price starts to come down
which means that if you're going to
recoup your investment you have to plant
more and more
and alongside that
there's an effort to cut costs wherever
you can and this includes labor
so the incentives very quickly build in
barbados
to turning from
a system of farming that is based mostly
upon servant labor to slave labor
because the incentives build so quickly
because it's such a small island the
value of land goes up so much the costs
are so big
right so
what's so scary about slavery
the thing about the institution that
should terrify us
right is how it made so much economic
sense to people in the 1600s
that's the kind of terrifying thing is
that slavery wasn't just an act of evil
done by people for totally irrational
reasons
it made a certain kind of sense
and that's the kind of dangerous thing
about it
especially when we take into account the
fact that 17th century englishmen were
comfortable with the idea of slavery
and they didn't have a very well
developed sense of human rights as we've
seen in ireland as we've seen in
north america jamestown
there's not a whole big belief right in
human equality going on in 17th century
england so slavery and you know english
people were used to a world in which
slavery was normal
in which there were various kinds of
captivity and unfreedom uh
going around in western europe
so
you put all that together the economic
incentives the cultural beliefs of
england you very quickly lead to
thinking
like this
up here on the screen
right and so this is just a very short
letter this is almost the entirety of
the letter from right this fellow george
downing who's an english person in
barbados to a fellow john wethrop who is
an english person in massachusetts if
you go to barbados you shall see a
flourishing island many able men i
believe they have bought this year no
less than a thousand negroes and the
more they buy the better able they are
to buy for in a year and a half they
will earn with god's blessing as much as
they cost
a man that will settle there must look
to procure servants which if you could
get out of england for six eight or nine
years time only paying their passages or
at the most but some small above
it would do very well so it's good to
get servants because
so thereby you shall be able to do
something upon a plantation and in a
short time be able with good husbandry
to procure negroes the life of this
place out of the increase of your own
plantation
right so a lot of words here but what's
important about this quote
is that the english are already thinking
about africans right not as just
laborers who get something out of a
plantation
they're thinking of them as an
investment they're thinking about them
in terms of cost and increase they are
taking human lives
and turning them into commodity value
right
this is the scary thing
about slavery is that it's so much a
part of this economic thinking that's
developed colonies developed settlement
that's developed
the modern english economy as of the
1600s
because this is what's happening here
right when you take folks who already
don't you know they believe that certain
groups of people are barbarians and are
eligible to be enslaved you take that
belief right that already exists
and then you add this economic motive to
it
you get something that's a little bit
different and is moving towards
something uh
even more brutal
than captivity and slavery as it existed
in medieval europe
because we're getting into a dark place
here but that's history sometimes
history is full of these kind of dark
places
what barbadian planters are doing as
this quote reveals
is they're thinking about
the lives of these africans in
particular in terms of how much sugar
they'll produce
and how quickly they'll produce it
and the economics of the time the late
1600s
after this quote develops right
barbadian planters started thinking in
terms that
a single enslaved laborer would produce
enough to pay their purchase within a
couple of years
and then anything they produce after
that right
would be
mostly pure profit once you subtracted
the bare level of subsistence given to
these workers i have shelter and food
and clot clothing
right medieval laws on slavery still
insisted right that masters of slaves
provide bare sustenance to their slaves
but now these human lives in addition to
these old medieval laws are developing
this new thing commodity value a value
in terms of what they produce a monetary
value
and
this also means that slave labor unlike
servants right servants you pay for the
term of work
a slave who is kept in bondage forever
can always be sold again and this is
part of the investment idea of them
one of the creepy things right that is
a person who is a slave can be sold to
another planter and you can recoup
their price at some other point
so as you can see right
they will earn as much as they cost
increase your own plantation so this
idea that human bodies now
are something that can be invested in
for their value
that's something that's being cooked up
here
and as sugar prices decline
and the pressure to produce more and
more
increases right
it's much easier for the english to
start emphasizing
slave labors in terms of what they
produce rather than as people in and of
themselves
in addition to just the mental thinking
about what it means to hold a person in
bondage the english are also changing
the way work gets done
right
in the english islands they're
developing
a more complete control over their labor
forces these are small spaces right
and
increasingly full of thousands and
thousands of forced migrants from africa
right so in barbados and in places
nearby the english developed what's
known as the gang system of labor a way
of organizing a workforce
right to ensure maximum productivity
and you know we don't think of this as a
major innovation because it seems fairly
simple but it's you know because
we live in a world transformed by it
the idea is basically you line everybody
up and make them work side by side so
one person at one spot can supervise a
lot of people
and
person who works too slow you can see
them right because the line will move
ahead of them
and so this is how cane was planted this
is how it was harvested this is how
vermin were driven from the field
once it became harvest season right
uh these
folks could be lined up as a kind of
human conveyor belt to move cane from
place to place to move juice from place
to place to move fuel from place to
place
right so this idea of
organizing labor as a kind of military
style gang that can be supervised by one
or a few supervisors this is an
innovation in labor practices going on
in the islands
but allows maximum production right to
force everyone to work at the pace of
the fastest worker
uh
so you put all this together right this
incentive to maximize production in a
small space the economic incentives of
slavery and sugar production this
colonial trap of
always producing a good but the more you
produce of it the less it's worth so you
have to produce even more next year
get caught in this cycle
this adds up to creating a very unique
society in barbados
different than what was created in
brazil in the 1500s different than what
was going on in jamestown or new england
in a similar time period because what
you have now
is in these small islands
you have
a very unusual situation you've got a
very small number of wealthy white
planters
and within 20 years right the only
people that could afford to purchase
this much land this much labor to
purchase the mills we're very rich
people
so there's again no mom and pop shops
operating here
a very small class of wealthy white
planters some of whom got so rich they
moved back to england and they're
managing their plantations from a
distance
but a very small population of english
subjects
free english subjects that own the land
that own the mills that own most
everything
a
slightly larger but not significantly
larger class of employees clerks and
bookkeepers and merchants and field
supervisors and mill supervisors
and then
the vast majority of people in places
like barbados or antigua another english
sugar island you've got tens of
thousands of enslaved africans held in
bondage on these various plantations
and this system right you know and the
labor organized according to the gang
system
uh producing sugar almost exclusively
right because the idea is
sugar is still even if the price is
falling sugar is still so valuable
and
the planters feel like it's a better use
of their land to plant every acre in
sugar and then use that wealth to buy
whatever else they need
and this is where the rest of north
america comes into play
this is where
this gang system
the innovations of the sugar and the
caribbean all start to
come together and start to reach beyond
just these tiny islands and come north
to mainland north america which is
ultimately what we're interested in in
this class
so
i have to back up just a second before
we move to mainland north america
it is important to think about right how
people survive this system uh think
about the human beings involved right
this is a dehuman dehumanizing system
one thing historians have had to work to
recover right is the humanity of the
enslaved
uh because these were real lives and
it's very imp we don't want to let the
system that dehumanizes them when so we
want to recover those lives and so how
do people deal with these conditions
right
tens of thousands of people that so
radically
uh outnumbered the people that held them
in bondage you would expect to see
massive rebellions and they didn't
happen in the 1600s
uh you'd expect to see lots of escape
that's very difficult in an island right
and the rebellions are very hard right
because
even though there's tens of thousands of
slaves
right they are very closely interspersed
with heavily armed
overseers planter classes
and while
bear in mind right there are also family
networks and community networks here so
while you yourself might be willing to
risk your own life in a rebellion would
you be willing to risk the life of your
children
so that's a real thing that people had
to think about
so how people survived it mostly right
was something historians are focused on
called everyday resistance right one of
the most profound and powerful things
that develops
in these slave societies is
just the ways in which the enslaved
asserted their humanity right became one
of the most radical forms it's just in a
system that dehumanizes them to assert
that they are in fact people
and so very small things have very
profound meaning
not big rebellions not massive escapes
not fleeing to freedom
but small things maintaining some sense
of yourself
right in the system holding on to
african languages african religious
beliefs becomes enormously important
enormously powerful
in this context
playing with the rhythm of work slowing
down work sabotaging equipment playing
with how fast you're being forced to
work asserting the fact that you're a
human being with human limits
testing that boundary is always risky
right
there's a lot of violence that backs up
this system so it's always risky but
just to do that
is important and then
in the islands very particularly
important
is
something that scholars refer to
and the language is french because a lot
of this was developed in studies of
french sugar plantations in the
caribbean something known as petite
marinage running away a little bit
this was a simple act right
we can kind of see right
on the screen here these are volcanic
islands there's a lot of mountains
there's a lot of caves even though
they're very small
so simply sneaking away from the
plantation for an evening to visit
friends to visit family who might have
come over from africa who you've been
separated from
simply to
write
have a drink
chat with each other talk to each other
as family as relatives as friends
and then sneaking back in before
anyone is missing you
this becomes incredibly powerful right
to just
remember how to be a person in a system
that dehumanizes you
and
it's important to note right that
these small acts
also become very important because
slave owners in the islands and in the
mainland colonies are always trying to
legislate these actions out of existence
and we'll see that when we talk about
slave codes uh next week
the humanity of slaves is a constant
problem for the law
uh enslaved colonies
we'll get to more of that next week here
but it's very important right after
thinking about the brutality of the
system
to at least
not let the brutality
take away these people's lives all right
so but
no mistake right
this is a brutal system
it's backed up with a lot of violence
and
all right this is just to kind of give
us a scale of what we're dealing with
this is a map of barbados in 1651
right thailand is covered in plantations
images of violence images of chasing
down slaves that are running away
all of that interspersed on the map's
margins so this system of slavery is
being developed very quickly here
and
when we think about the relationship
between these islands and mainland north
america
it's important i mean the thing that
kind of keeps coming to me is that these
islands
they were zones of consumption they just
consumed so much
they consumed people first and foremost
right sugar
was a dangerous dangerous business
this is one of the first industrial
sites it's dangerous business
long hours working in very hot
conditions when you're out in the fields
the milling process in particular was
brutal right this is heavy equipment
being moved here uh fingers arms were
lost in the mills people were overcome
by the heat of the boiling houses
uh
the sugar boiling itself right by the
time we're getting into those kettles
right we're talking about boiling liquid
sugar
uh
anyone make here make candy
at home
no
you do
you ever get like you're boiling sugar
right get it on your skin what
happens it burns and it burns and it
sticks to you
yeah uh right so
you know brutal injuries at every step
of the process
so
thousands and thousands and thousands of
people brought each year right to keep
this thing running
so again just kind of give us a sense of
the scale here
and
my numbers uh here from an older study
they might have been changed but
the 1600s right the century we're
studying here 1600s about 1.3 million
give or take africans were brought over
the americas of slaves
of that number of that 1.3 million
75 percent went sugar plantations or at
least zones that had sugar plantations
so either brazil or the west indies
barbados alone right this tiny little
island
right here uh between 1640
when sugar comes in 1700 right
10
right 130 plus thousand of those
africans were brought just to this one
island of barbados
so it consumes a lot of people but
that's also a lot of people who aren't
growing their own food
and this is where north america comes
into play
the east coast of north america by and
large at least large chunks of it
develop as kind of a support system for
these caribbean islands
right because down in places like
barbados down in places like jamaica
down in places like antigua you've got
thousands and thousands and thousands of
people large population centers
and they're
not producing much of their own food
right the incentive is to plant
everything in sugar
and sugar is too valuable right to just
eat yourself and you can't just eat
sugar yourself
despite what you might have thought when
you were three right you can't just eat
sugar um you got to have something else
right so to support these populations to
keep the sugar machines running
uh to keep the enslaved populations
alive and working right
it creates all these other investment
opportunities all these other business
ventures in other parts of the world for
those that can provide support services
for
the sugar islands
because these islands right they need
things they need food for the people
that live there
they need fuel you know uh
these are clear-cut islands and it takes
a lot of fuel to keep the kettles
boiling to keep the fires burning
the folks living there they need meat
they need protein
they need just basic nutrition to live
and so
sugar is still valuable enough
that it's in many ways a more efficient
decision for the planters to produce
nothing but sugar and they use some of
that value
to purchase food from nearby
and here's where
right mainland north america comes into
play
you look at any history tech book in the
united states history uh if you look on
the chapters dealing with the second
half of the 1600s you see lots of stuff
happening in all these colonies at once
and a lot of that right is being pushed
by what's happening in the caribbean
this
colonial system right it's kind of like
billiard balls one thing moves in one
spot and it affects the others right
they're all tied together
so just kind of give us a sense here
right
to keep
you know these tiny islands running
one of the things right they need is you
need boats you need ships but you also
need fish right fish are an easy source
of protein and relatively cheap to get
because they don't have to be raised
they just have to be caught
right so in the second half of the 1600s
new england which has lots of great
forests for shipbuilding and easy access
to great fishing grounds
our new england colonies start to
develop a shipping and fishing industry
and most of their early business is
spent running up and down the coast down
to the caribbean islands and back
so our maritime new england coast right
a huge boost to that business is the
fact that you have this massive market
of islands looking to consume fish and
in need of boats to carry goods back and
forth
folks down here right they need cereal
they need grain they need basic food and
so
colonies that can produce things like
oats and barley and wheat
there's a ready market
for their produce right
uh thousands and thousands of people
that need to eat and so places like
pennsylvania and new jersey both founded
in the 1670s 1680s right
a huge part of those farmers early
markets is shipping goods down to the
caribbean
south carolina
south carolina
develops pretty much entirely as a
support colony for barbados
right
other things the islands need right they
need
food they need protein they need timber
they need fuel
and south carolina right being
relatively close right
the barbados
right
becomes a key stop
and so south carolina develops pretty
much entirely as a subsidiary of the
island of barbados producing goods that
are needed on the island
the early industries of south carolina
raising cattle
mostly to send livestock to power the
mills
and fresh meat fresh-ish meat uh
to feed the folks on the island
timber right just cutting down wood to
send fuel for fires and uh
lumber to construct mills right coming
from the big pine forests of the
southeast
and then there's also the fact that the
islands need people
the second half of the 1600s it's no
accident
you see the rise of a trade in indian
slaves native american slaves
being run to the islands
pretty much every colony in north
america engages in it to some extent
south carolina on a larger scale than
most but new england colonies right
the settlers of new england
they sell
uh native americans into slavery in the
caribbean virginians uh sell native
americans into slavery in the caribbean
south carolina on a massive scale tens
of thousands of native americans go are
sent down
to
the islands
and even for a colony that wasn't
directly involved in supporting the
islands the older colony of virginia
which still had its tobacco plantations
virginia still becomes closely tied to
this
right because virginia is another colony
right that has this colonial product
tobacco that the price keeps falling on
virginia planters are constantly looking
uh for
right ways to maximize their profits on
these tobacco lands
so virginia planters start coordinating
with barbados planters virginia imports
the gang system it imports the
plantation model
new investors from england come to
virginia in the late 1600s after the
sugar boom to
recreate in virginia what the barbadians
had already created and they start
trading back and forth what the laws of
slavery should be there's a very close
correspondence between these two
colonies
and so all of these big developments
we're going to talk about these in more
detail
over the next week or two all of them
are fueled by the presence of these
large tobacco plantations
down in the caribbean
so
i think this is a good stopping point
for
today uh but we've got time i've left
some time here for some questions so
hopefully right you've got a few i've
had to move kind of quickly through a
lot of material so a chance to kind of
process relax
right
questions you might have
yes i need to ask you to come up to the
mic
thanks caleb
talk right into it yep
how comfortable would you say
the indentured servant system is with
the slave system like would you
compare them to slaves or
would you say they're treated a lot more
fairly
uh
excellent question so caleb justin
compare indentured servants slavery
it depends and right every answer in
history begins with it depends right
so in this case it depends on when we're
talking about
at the very beginning of this process
there's not a whole lot of light between
the system of indentured servitude and
the system of slavery
especially in terms of treatment right
servants were considered inferior
classes people that could be treated
fairly brutally
uh
so the laws governing servants the laws
governing slaves they're all they're
actually very similar
uh though one and the actual day-to-day
treatment was very similar the biggest
difference being someone that had a
servant's contract served a defined
number of years
which could stretch into an entire
lifetime
someone who was a slave served for life
right that was the biggest difference
was the term of service but then once we
start getting into the later part of the
1600s and these laws have started to
change you start to see a much wide much
bigger gulf right in which
slaves are forbidden from having
firearms while servants might be slaves
or have much more restrictions on their
movement uh than servants might
and
so as we get into the late and we'll
talk about this more as we get into the
later 1600s
there's a bigger gulf wat you know
opening up between the life of the
servant the life of the slave
so originally they start quite closely
and the laws of slavery come out of the
laws of servitude but they get bigger
and bigger as we go on the servants
weren't protected under like the laws of
christianity that say you can't enslave
other christians
uh they were they were protected on that
the biggest difference being that slaves
also were so there were more legal
protections perhaps for a slave in the
earlier part
those legal protections get stripped out
one by one and servants
servants keep right so for example right
by the early 1700s
it's still illegal to kill a servant
but it's legal to kill a slave right
that's sort of like a big example one of
the big examples right there
i could give you three more hours of
lecture on that
that one question but let's let's
other questions
so i'm actually curious
what started the thinking for giving
slaves their rights back
don't be too sadist
no uh i mean that's an excellent
question right and it's one again
that we'll talk about later in class
because the answer is
this system right and its offshoots
create a kind of slavery
and a kind of ideology
that
actually
shapes an idea of freedom and liberty
and equality later on so
right what actually happens is
this system of slavery gets improvised
in the 1600s and
in reaction to this system
this idea of freedom and equality and
liberty get developed in these 1700s
that eventually comes back and ends the
system of
slavery the part of
efficiency investment
play with also
these the very first ideas of just
incorporating these slaves we need to
make money we need to make profit let's
get these guys and do this
either they're killing them too fast
they're not working efficiently they're
not making enough money does that then
create codes to treat them better to get
more profits does that kind of work hand
in hand
uh
you you'd like to think um right but
again
when we're getting into the id laws of
treatment thinking they get into
questions of race and difference
sort of perfect reason and rationality
kind of also gets thrown out the window
too we get into some places that don't
necessarily make economic sense but make
a certain kind of other logic logical
sense based upon the ideologies
but yeah so
right
if we're talking like just brutal
calculation
uh of you know a plantation
treatment is tied to what point
a person starts producing profit for you
right so
in a system like this in which a person
is paying for the
cost of their enslavement in just a few
years the treatment is pegged to
keeping that person alive just a little
bit past a few years and then
purchasing another human to pay for it
to help yeah uh but yeah i mean
it's
i got one more thing yeah was it more
the whites who thought we should give
the slaves their rights or was it more
the slaves themselves that pushed the
whites to think about it well again
history right it's not us
we weren't there
them right was it the slaves or the
slave owners
uh it was very much uh the enslave
themselves right that that push
pushed the laws that that get overturned
uh the first and most sustained cries
for the abolition of slavery come out of
african-american communities
particularly free african-american
communities in the late 1700s
but the movement only gains
steam and success right when the people
who actually have political power
small subsets of european descendants
not necessarily slave owners the slave
owners very rarely are saying we should
get rid of slavery
it's other people for reasons and again
right this basic question
of when does the idea of slavery go away
and how does that happen that's pretty
much the rest of this class is talking
about the conditions that shape and
change and transform that
so that's a big question you actually
asked about how we get from a system
where this is okay
to a system where it's not okay
so i got thank you all right
you
sneak this way
so what's going on in south africa at
this point in earth not south africa uh
south america at this point in history
to where we're taking uh north america
which is further away from barbados
using it as a a a food producing
opportunity
where south america is right there
and why aren't we pulling slaves from
the same region not us
historical people at the time
uh
well i mean the
that's a big question right uh one of
the short answers is south america has
already settled
by the time that
the english is settling these colonies
and looking for places to establish um
but it's also right that
you know the coast of brazil for example
right
uh is not
it might be physically and i don't know
the actual shipping lanes and all this
but is it worth going to war which costs
a lot of money to get these relatively
marginal profitable things up and
running
or just settling the areas you already
have and paying a little bit extra in
shipping each
each trip um perhaps so
uh so that's i mean part of it is the
fact and there's also the fact that the
incentive right people have already
invested in those colonies in north
america they want to see stuff coming
out of it they're not going to just
abandon those and try and go settle
somewhere else
so i know that was the first part of
your question you asked me a whole lot
of other things so
the the second part was um i guess i
guess it's along the same lines your
your answer answers both but you know
why not pull
slaves from that region instead of
having to ship them all away from africa
you know go down from portugal grab them
from africa and then ship them all the
way to barbados
because
was it no no it's not well not quite
they have no problem enslaving native
americans mostly it has to do with uh
what exists in west africa and that
doesn't exist in places like brazil or
exist in many parts of north america is
you have these large
civilizations that are at war with each
other right so the wars and politics of
west africa
right most slaves are war captives uh
created during internal affairs in west
africa
and europeans just sort of tap into that
existing slave market which
geographically might seem more distant
actually is it's
a lot of ways easier for europeans to
show up in a boat and make that
that trade
and the coast to the coast of brazil
you've got these amazonian cultures that
don't have these large state systems
that don't have this massive sort of
warfare that don't have these existing
kind of captive markets
so the europeans would have had to
create those and that's actually much
more difficult
so i mean this is
again right sort of
right
one of the tricks of the slave trade
europeans always find it easier legally
in terms of their conscience
economically to purchase
people who've been made slaves by
someone else right and that way they can
just sort of take them and plug them
into their own
slave system and in many cases a much
more brutal form of slavery than they
would have known in west africa or north
america anywhere else but
that's by and large how the europeans
operate they take advantage of the fact
they have these boats and can move
people from place to place and just sort
of tap into these existing networks
so
at that at this stage uh it was the
spanish that was mostly in the
mexico south america area correct uh
central america and the western parts of
south america yes and then the
portuguese are on the east coast of
brazil
okay so
so there's still this still you know
really doesn't
make much sense they is they couldn't
just you know build farms on the east
coast of the
of the place that's closest to barbados
islands
well bear in mind right that
when brazil was open for settlement in
the early 1500s barbados just an
uninhabited volcanic rock they didn't
know what it was going to become
right so
once barbados has been settled and sugar
has developed in the 1640s right the
english already have these established
colonies along north america so it's
easier to invest in them to produce for
barbados than it would be to conquer an
entirely new territory and start a large
long war um
okay
make sense okay
conquest and occupation are always
expensive right
there
like as i said few universal laws in
history but that's one right to pay
people to occupy and conquer
all right
other questions
well if not
thank you all very much if you have
questions right that you're not
comfortable asking in front of the
microphone by all means come up and
talk to me
otherwise we can talk more
about all this stuff in class office
hours etc etc so
all right thank you all very much
and see you all on tuesday no thursday
thursday
join us every saturday evening at 8pm
and midnight eastern as we join students
in college classrooms to hear lectures
on topics ranging from the american
revolution to 9 11.
lectures in history are also available
as podcasts visit our website cspan.org
history slash podcasts or download them
from itunes